this is Jocko podcast number 398 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko willinka good
evening Echo good evening
waiting for Isis to come popping out of
the threshold I leveled my rifle and
watched the doorway as David prepared a
grenade from across the courtyard he
waved it to signify he was ready and I
nodded he crept around the corner of the
Hut toward the door my finger on the
trigger I aimed no more than a foot away
from David as he tossed the grenade into
the room and darted back around the
corner I ducked behind cover and counted
out loud one thousand two thousand three
thousand four thousand five thousand
boom David was already rushing toward
the smoking doorway as I turned the
corner and hurried to get behind him he
put his rifle on automatic and sprayed
the room with lead Jam he yelled with
his rifle momentarily disabled he ducked
out of the way batter up
I'd practice this scenario a hundred
times in the military as soon as David
was clear of the doorway I was already
shooting my own rifle in
I walked in Arc directly in front of the
doorway being sure to shoot into the
room at every possible angle reloading I
stepped back and slammed the Fresh
Magazine into my rifle David rushed into
the room and I hooked left I followed in
and went right as we entered an Iraqi
soldier rushed up and grabbed the a bkc
light machine gun that was laying on the
floor
entering the House's tiny kitchen I
quickly scanned for threats kill count
clear there were no no shoot targets
open door I moved to the doorway toward
the dirt floor that lay Across the
Threshold
tunnel I cleared the room and fired into
the tunnel now at my feet then took
further stock of the room around me Isis
sleeping pads and gear IEDs homemade
grenades and other explosive components
littered the floor screw this it seemed
like everything in the room was designed
to kill me
they're all in that tunnel and there's
no way I'm going down there David of
course thought otherwise we need to
clear that tunnel while we still have
the initiative
handing his rifle to Shaheen David drew
his pistol and hopped down into the
tunnel I shook my head in disbelief I
had read about the guys in Vietnam
called tunnel rats who would go into
Vietcong and NVA tunnels
I explicitly remember thinking those
guys were the ballsiest guys on the
planet and that I wanted nothing to do
with it
but I took my medical bag off left it
with Shaheen and followed David into the
blackness
and that right there
is an excerpt from a book called city of
death by Ephraim Mattis
Ephraim served in the SEAL Teams and
when he got done with the SEAL Teams he
joined the humanitarian group called
free Burma Rangers where he fought in
the battle of missoul
and it's an honor to have him with us
here tonight to share some of his
experiences his lessons learned what
he's doing now with a stronghold rescue
and everything that he's got going on
Ephraim thanks for coming down man
appreciate it thanks for having me on
and good to be here I apologize that
this took so long I so I dug up I'm
holding a letter in my hand that you
wrote to me in 2018
of a nice cool letter basically saying
hey I've got this book coming out I've
been doing a bunch of stuff I'm still
doing a bunch of stuff it'd be cool if I
could come and share with you and let
people know what I'm doing
and the the letter and the book went
into a pile with a bunch of other
um books and letters that I get and
finally got it uncovered uh Andy Stumpf
hooked us up so there we go I apologize
for it taking so long but I'm glad
you're here now and I know that
you're kind of just getting warmed up
you're still doing a ton of stuff so
this story still needs to get out there
especially about what you're doing now
so thanks for coming man yeah thanks and
and uh no worries no worries that's all
good yeah it's like it's only been five
years it's no big deal it's all good
you're busy man I don't think I've been
busier than you all right so
um
I guess we can just start at the
beginning so with this book you kind of
talk about a little bit of where you
came from and stuff
um
yeah we'll get we'll get to it I'm gonna
go to the book so the book again the
book is called city of death it came out
in 2018 or 2019 2018 2018. it's been out
for a while
let me jump into this
go into the book my name is Ephraim
like my own like my brother and only
sibling Zeppelin am I saying that right
zebulun Zebulon I'm gonna get that one
wrong over and over again Zebulon my
name was taken from the Old Testament we
grew up in Milwaukee Wisconsin part of a
middle class family in Middle America we
couldn't afford frivolous things and
occasionally there were hard times but
we were always had a loving happy family
our neighborhood is safe and I spent
much of my days riding my bike building
Forts and playing Until Dark my father
Lonnie mattos is a kind gentle man I
can't recall any moment in my childhood
where he lost his temper or yelled at
anyone in our family even when his small
real estate business bankrupted in the
bankrupted the family in 2008 after the
financial collapse my father didn't
complain or ask for a handout he simply
got back to work and eventually dug
himself out
dad also loves his country while working
a blue collar job at Milwaukee Milwaukee
General Mitchell International Airport
for most of my childhood he also served
in the local Air Force Reserve unit the
440th airlift Wing as a flight engineer
on the massive C-130 Hercules cargo
airplane the Workhorse of the U.S
military after 9 11 in the invasion of
Iraq in 2003 dad along with the rest of
the 440th answered the call and went to
the war
he flew dozens of combat sorties over
Iraq carrying troops supplies and
evacuating the wounded my mother Bernice
Matos is a terrific Homemaker and during
dad's multiple deployments she doubled
down her efforts and put all of her
energy into her two boys
on top of her domestic responsibilities
mom took a job at our school as a
full-time secretary earning less than
half the pay just to support the family
while I was growing up Mom was a devout
Baptist
and you have devout italicized so it's
like I guess that means real devout yeah
yeah as a result my childhood sent
around centered around a small
independent fundamental Baptist Church
in Milwaukee we attended church services
Sunday mornings and evenings there was a
Wednesday night service and on Saturday
mornings instead of playing ball with
the neighborhood kids Zebulon and I
worked in the inner city Outreach
Ministry and if that wasn't enough even
the school we attended was run by the
church
there were usually no more than 75
students enrolled kindergarten through
grade 12. that's a small group very
small Church practices were no
notoriously strict governing most
aspects of daily life movie theaters
were forbidden and so was music with
drum beats this is the first time I've
ever heard of that yeah true story all
music with drum beats which is what does
that leave you with classical music I
guess pretty much just uh Christian
music and classical music yeah okay yeah
I guess there's Bluegrass some Bluegrass
what if something doesn't have drums in
it
um what if it's a Metallica song without
drums Metallica song without drums
that's gonna be a no-go it's really a
no-go yeah so even though they said no
drum beats you weren't able to find some
waivers around that
um I listened to a lot of classical
music actually growing up and some stuff
like that yeah you know uh here's a
self-admission
I think when people would say like well
don't you like classical music and I
think part of me my ego would think that
that would sound smart to be like well
yes of course I like classical music but
then I thought to myself I'm really
lying because I don't like it so at a
certain point people would say well what
about classical music do you like
classical music no it's boring so I
recognize now that it's not but you just
have to listen to it a little bit more
because since there's no drum beats it
makes it kind of hard to follow for
knucklehead like me but uh so here we go
although the restrictions were a bit
severe this is the only life I knew
alas the two great influence of my youth
were the church my mom and the military
my dad mom and dad mix the Two Worlds
together very well and this unique
mixture
made me who I am today a fighter who has
no problem going to toe-to-toe with Isis
or the Taliban but also a humanitarian
who cringes at the very thought of
hurting someone innocent so this is your
this is your life growing up so you
didn't have uh an Instagram page you
didn't have uh social media you weren't
going to school dances and chasing girls
or anything like this no that was no
absolutely not there was a Facebook was
around a little bit so we were able to
use Facebook a little bit but then
sometimes sometimes they would get mad
at us for having Facebook but then
people some people at church would have
Facebook and you know it was it was it
was it was all a bit odd
um in the end I think I think actually
I'm actually very grateful for how I
grew up I think it's actually really
good
um I I would I don't know if I would
call it sheltered I mean to an extent I
was I was definitely sheltered but I
think it was actually really good I
needed that discipline and as I got
older I realized wow it's actually
really good that I had that discipline
growing up
um and it kept me from probably from a
lot of a lot of trouble and a lot of
things I might have gotten into but
you're also going into the inner city to
work with like community outreach
programs yeah absolutely it's got to be
an eye opener as well yeah absolutely so
um every every weekend we would go to
the the particular area that I worked in
was the the heavily
um
African-American part of of Milwaukee
and that's where I would go into so I
would go into the houses and we would we
would meet the we'd meet the kids was
like a it was an Outreach for kids
primarily bring them to church and you
know
um and so yeah so I got to experience
and see like a totally different side of
life I got to see what it was like for
people who didn't have what I had and I
got to see I was exposed to to all of
that and so I got to see like hey
there's a there's a not not everyone has
it like you have it and there's a lot of
you know reasons for for that and um so
I was I always grew up I grew up not
sheltered thinking like my way was the
only way or like living on a commune it
wasn't like that at all it was it was
very much hey this is how we live but
we're also a part of this world we're
also a part of everything else that's
going on around us and it's our job to
to try to help in what ways we can and
that was primarily religious but as I've
got older I translated that more into
when you when the uh financial crisis
hit did you guys lose your house yeah so
we actually at the time we owned um my
parents own two places uh when the
financial crash hit we lost the house
that we were living in and had to move
back into our into our first home
um and then bankruptcy and and all that
stuff so it was yeah it was definitely a
rough time and I didn't understand it at
the time I didn't understand any of that
stuff and like I said my dad is just my
hero he's just the the greatest guy ever
he
um yeah he just he just put his head
down and was like all right cool I'm
gonna go I'm gonna go work and he works
for Coca-Cola and he's been working
there for yeah basically since 2008 and
and uh yeah and he just works his butt
off and he's just he's just the best
human and uh yeah so you you were raised
in this church and then I have a little
note in the book here it says but
and I'm gonna fast forward a little bit
and you say I began to question
everything
and again there's you explain a lot of
this stuff but this is um you know this
is like post 911 you're kind of
wondering how is this happening uh so
you say I began to question everything
what's the deal with music what about
movie theaters and I realized that
although well-intentioned the adults in
my life had applied their
interpretations of the Bible as if it
were biblical as if they were biblical
law
but now I understood God gave each of us
the ability to interpret his word and I
could navigate a course accordingly from
then on when a preacher or a
schoolteacher told me something I took
it with a healthy dose of skepticism
so you had a little bit of rebel
going through your your heart yeah I I
think one of one of the chapters in the
book I I I I think I call it I
respectfully disagree and that was that
was ultimately what my what my attitude
was I for me it wasn't about I didn't
want to like sort of you know break the
chains that bound me and go do crazy
stuff and that wasn't my intention at
all I looked at it and I just said ah
like that's that's not correct
um or that's a little bit odd
um and so you know what I think in the
future I'm not gonna I'm not gonna you
know go down this path in particular but
at no point I don't remember as a as a
kid at no point did I get like angry or
bitter or
um you know again like rebellious that
wasn't my intention at all I was like I
I was like there's a lot of really good
things here but there's also a lot where
I'm like dude this is this isn't how uh
how life is supposed to go or at least
not for me as I get older yeah and in
the meantime you see Black Hawk Down the
movie yeah yeah of course
and yeah that Band of Brothers the
series The Band of brother the series
um now you start doing research on the
internet yeah you start researching The
Green Berets you start researching you
know the PJs and force Recon
and then you get to the SEAL Teams you
start researching them
um
you write that it seems like it would
have been impossible like you didn't
think you could make it because what
sports were you playing uh so we
actually we played mostly basketball
growing up though because we had a small
school so basketball you know uh five
five Man team is a is the best best
option that you have uh so it's actually
good I still get to I still got to play
um Athletics still got to be physically
active and whatnot the the issue it just
seemed impossible to me because a lot of
the water stuff and I could I get doggy
paddle you know I could you know find my
way around the pool for for a minute uh
before I drowned right same as most
people
um but when I looked at it I looked at
all these different units and I thought
you know I could do that I could put a
rock on I could walk I could do all
these different things but then when I
every time I would look at the seal
thing I'd go which I just kind of put it
out of my mind I was like I couldn't do
that I couldn't do that but then I
thought about it and I and I realized
what kind of what kind of soldier would
I be what kind of Ranger would I be what
kind of Green Beret would I be if I was
just walking away from the the the
um the challenge of being a seal you
know what I mean like if I'm if I'm
going into those units because I'm like
oh it's too hard to do something else
I'm like then I'm probably not gonna do
well in those units either way because
it has nothing to do with the physical
ability has everything to do with the
mindset and I was like well okay I'm
gonna learn how to swim now and that's
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna become a
really good swimmer and so one day I
just I just sat there and I decided it's
so my attitude still I was trying to I
was explaining this to a team guy about
him and he was just sitting there
laughing he thought it was the funniest
thing in the world I told him I was like
look when I when I when I went to Buds
and I did all that I honestly didn't
think I was gonna make it I had no
intention of quitting I didn't think I
was going to quit but I was like they're
probably going to kick me out for
something and again I wasn't all you
know poo poo I was like I'm gonna give
I'm going to give the give it my best
I'm gonna do everything I possibly can
to succeed but I was like they're
probably going to kick me out because
I'm like who am I right I'm like this is
a strange attitude it's very strange but
I was like I'm not gonna give up I'm
like they're gonna have to drag me out
of there but I'm gonna go for it because
I was like I'm not gonna live the rest
of my life regretting and not have and
regretting having not tried and I was
like this is what I know I want to do I
want to be this if it doesn't work out
it doesn't work out but they're gonna
have to kick me out I'm not gonna leave
on my own so when I went in I was kind
of almost relaxed because I was like you
know running down the beach like at some
point they're gonna pull me out of line
and be like you're out you know and but
you know they never did and I just kept
going I was like oh okay how did you how
did you train like what were you doing
to get ready
um so I had very little background and
like actually
um like working out properly so I didn't
fully understand how to work out
properly so I got I want to Stew smell
myths you know was it 12 weeks prep or
whatever and so I would follow that
relatively close I did lots of swimming
lots of running I was all my PST scores
and everything were were like barely
passing you know like I was by no means
was I a stud and I talked about that
later in the book too like it was that
was like always a struggle for me
because I just didn't know how to get
faster stronger I did no idea because
that wasn't a part of my culture growing
up I had no idea we would just like play
basketball you know
um so that's what I did and I joined how
what year was this what year did you
join um I joined the Navy technically in
2010 yeah right after high school I'm
gonna throw I'm gonna throw this out
there man I talk about the fact that we
we didn't know about working out meeting
me and my buddies and this was like in
the 90s there was like no internet there
was nothing oh man so for you in 2010
you should have Googled like how to get
in shape yeah well that's all I got Stu
Smith's book and I was like reading it I
was trying to I was trying to do it um
but yeah the uh the struggle the
struggle was definitely real no doubt
and then how'd your parents feel about I
mean your dad must have been good and
your mom was she good with it um she
eventually was good with it the the
thing was so I I grew up in that school
and in so in 10th Grade I I uh during
that year I sort of like had this coming
out of the closet moment where I was
like hey you know what I'm actually not
gonna go be a pastor or something I'm
actually I want to be a seal and there
was a little bit of Kickback not like
crazy persecution I'm not gonna you know
exaggerate it but it was like everyone
was like definitely not happy with me my
mom thought I was going to go off the
deep end so all the ladies at church
were praying for me like that like the
prayer group was like praying for me
because they were like oh he's a good
kid and like why is he going off the
deep end and uh I I then decided in 10th
Grade I was like I'm not going back to
school and I'm not going back to the
school in 11th grade I'm not going to do
it um I was like because I was like I
want to go in a different direction with
my life my parents refused to let me go
to a public school so I had to
homeschool myself so and they didn't
they weren't able to like tutor me so I
spent my 11th because they were working
yeah yeah they were working but then
also too I was dealing with like 11th
grade you know level level stuff and
being able to you know prep for
different standardized tests and things
like that so they just they just didn't
have the ability to to Mentor me on that
so basically I had 11th grade I taught
myself algebra to teach by to like read
books and figure out all the stuff using
this online curriculum and whatnot
trying to figure out how all this stuff
worked and um so 11th grade I had to put
myself through basically I was my own
teacher for a year I worked at
McDonald's third shift 11 PM to 7 A.M
um and then I would leave I would leave
there and my grand plan to learn how to
swim was to become a lifeguard at the
YMCA because I was like well that's
going to force me to learn and uh so and
ironically it actually worked so I
joined the Lifeguard class and I just
everything they told me to do I was like
okay okay I just was like I'm gonna keep
swimming just keep trying keep trying
they eventually figured it out and
became a good swimmer and after that I
was able to leave McDonald's and and uh
continued continued teaching myself
algebra and everything else from books
and um then was able to make it through
my 11th grade year was was finally
working at the YMCA as a lifeguard and
then my senior year of high school my
parents let me
go to a public school because they saw I
wasn't up doing drugs I wasn't off going
going crazy I was I was like working
toward a specific goal and what I wanted
to do in life I wanted to be a seal and
so they eventually let me go to public
school so my senior year thank God I was
able to go to public school it was
actually really positive experience and
then
um yeah a few months later went off to
went off to the Navy so it's you got one
part in the book where you haven't left
your uh religious school yet and there's
if I remember this right they're they're
basically having Church you're at church
and and the pastor's up there saying
like he's like saying uh we don't need
any more we need more pastors we don't
need Navy Seals like and everyone's kind
of looking at you yes that was in Chapel
10 year old kid or whatever 10th grade
kid yeah yeah that was that was that was
one of the experiences yeah um I like
totally got called out again because
there's only 75 kids and it was in
school Chapel so to be fair I wasn't
sure it's with all the adults it was
just like all the it was all the like
75. they're just looking at you with
scorn and everybody like looked at him
and so you went to public school you
didn't get dragged off by like
you know some girl that was you know
little Mary Jane I was like I really
you're so cute you didn't go down that
path no sucked into that no I absolutely
did not I was like I was I was very much
focused on what I wanted to do and I was
still I was still trying to show my
parents like hey I'm not trying to rebel
against everything I've been uh been
taught and I I agree with a lot of it
you know at that time and I was like I
want to behave myself I'm not trying to
go be crazy
um I'm trying to be disciplined I'm
trying to at the time I thought was to
actually be an officer so I was like I
want to go to the Naval Academy that was
my original idea
um and thank God I didn't do that but
um
but uh yeah so like that was that was my
thought process like no I'm trying to
try and stay on the straight and narrow
because I've gotta I've got I've got a
goal I'm trying to reach it um yeah so
what point did you decide you weren't
going to go to the Naval Academy
um I think at some point during my
senior year I actually spoke with the
Naval Academy recruiter
um and I looked he looked at my grades
and we looked at everything and he said
you have a pretty you know pretty good
shot it's like not obviously nothing's
guaranteed like a pretty good shot
you're on top 10 of your class you're
you know taking these classes and and
all this stuff you're extracurriculars
like you're a pretty good shot
um I was like okay that's cool uh but
the more I thought about it the more I
looked at it um I kind of looked at the
wars going on and I was like these wars
are going to wind down and I want to get
some so I was like I'd rather like I was
like you know what I just want to go to
buzz I just want to get this over with I
want to go do this I want to go do the
do the job I don't want to go to school
right now for four years
um and I love school I actually
personally enjoy school I love reading I
love figuring things out I love
education and so for me I thought ah you
know what I'm gonna go I'm gonna go be
enlisted and later on I looked there was
the there was different programs I was
like listening but if I stay in the Navy
if there's the different you know semen
Admiral program at the time
and so I can go do that later if I if I
really want to yeah but you end up
enlisting I end up in listing
um I was still 17 at the time uh some of
both my parents had to go in and sign
for me and uh so and at that point they
were totally cool with it uh they both
fully supported it they all thought they
thought it was great they saw what it
was doing and um yeah so I I listed and
then a couple months later graduated
from high school and then a couple
months later went off to went off to
boot camp I heard a stat recently that
the graduation rate from buds under 20
years old is less than five percent
really yeah wow so I can see that it's
yeah all those guys that are like you
like me I was the same way and Jason
Gardner uh there's a bunch of guys but
it's rare because you don't have the
mental I guess maturity and fortitude
hasn't been fully develops a lot of
people when they're that young they're
just they just quit just that's what
happens yeah so so what years did you
take off uh 2010 late 2010 go off to the
go off to the Navy and how's boot camp
uh boot camp was weird uh so so okay I
was uh you know very um
uh you know to an extent like I hadn't I
hadn't intermingled with with other guys
really from from the world and so now
I'm here I'm thrown into this you know
Cesspool of like there's like 105 guys
in our in our boot camp division
um and so all these different guys from
totally different backgrounds like
totally different concepts of like right
and wrong and morality and I'm just like
I'm hearing I didn't I didn't know what
dip was I didn't know what it was so
guys were like oh man I just want to
chew and guys kept on doing a little
flick thing with everything like oh man
I need a different hit you I'm like what
are you guys talking about you know so
uh that was that was interesting
um you know meeting all those guys and
uh it was actually it was in the end it
was actually it was I have fond memories
of it it was it was very interesting
um but yeah so that was that was that
was boot camp uh it was yeah again just
very strange to intermingle with with
guys I just had no nothing in common
with except for the fact that we were
American and we wanted to be seals yeah
because out of the 105 guys in my
division 100 of us were going
specifically for the seal Pro oh so this
is back when they had a program
the 800 800 division exactly where you
got to be with all people that were
going for some kind of special program
yes 100 guys for seals Five Guys for
Navy diver a hundred guys for seals yeah
yeah yeah
exactly uh check yeah and how many of
them even made it past like the first
screening or the screening test to go to
buds
um I would say
so we had buds prep after that so we're
so after after boot camp which is two
months then we had two months of blood
buds prep all you do is work out
um and I would say yeah I would say
probably 90 of the guys were I I'm just
kind of pulling that number out of a hat
but I think probably 90 of the guys
qualified to go out to Buds and actually
go to go to go do it
um so it was actually it was actually
pretty good because again they're not
trying to weed us out at that point you
had some you know you know it's like
just someone like the weirdos you're
like dude what are you doing here man
like why are you here uh but they would
you know kind of get weeded out a little
bit
um but then by time you go to buds like
everyone's fit and everybody's you know
able to able to meet the standards so
knowledge just comes down to the to the
Mind Game everyone who shows up during
during the time that I was that that I
was there everyone had the physical
ability to do it everybody what's your
first impressions when you get in buds
um so
well actually I'll back up just a little
bit so my I'd never met a seal before I
never seen one in real life
um so like when I was going through um
when I was in the delayed entry program
in the Navy they had like dive
motivators who would like who would who
would work with us and train us the the
closest thing they had to a seal was a
guy who had made it to I think Tuesday
of week three in Buds and had quit that
was the closest thing they had to a seal
to like help prepare us for Buds and so
like for example his his advice was
always he would he sat me down one day I
remember and he was like all right all
right mattos when you quit this is
what's gonna happen he said he sat there
and went through this whole process and
explained to me this whole process of
what was going to happen to me when I
quit and I was like okay man like I
don't know why you're telling me this
like all right anyway
um so I never I've never seen a seal so
when I went to boot camp because we had
the 800 division
um there were a few seals who were
assigned to put us through workouts a
few days a week and things like that so
I remember sitting there and this guy
walked in and I and and we were just
sitting there doing administrative
paperwork and this guy walks in and I'm
like I was like oh that's the seal it's
like I just know it's like I know that's
a seal it's all tatted up and like in uh
in good shape and such
and uh I was like I just knew it and
sure enough he ended up being one of our
instructors Fast Forward 2014 he's my
squad leader in in Afghanistan yeah so
it was it was really really good
um that that was my first impression of
seal so when I get to when I got two
buds we did buds prep oh not buds prep
uh pre no is that buzz prep or pre-buds
what's is it indoc they call it once you
get to San Diego it's probably in dock
because prep is what you did in Chicago
that's right that's right but they
didn't call it in dog I think they
called it like buds something I don't
remember basic orientation basic Buzz
orientation okay that's right that's
right that's what they call it then
um so yeah we did three weeks of of uh
basic buds orientation and
um my thought process
90 of the time I was like okay I you
know this isn't that big of a deal we're
still kind of waiting for buds to really
hit us in the face
um but my first impression for example
when we did the when we did the boats
was dear God I'm not gonna make it I was
like this is so bad I was like I don't
know like how anybody has the physical
ability to carry these things so we did
our first boats on heads and that's
something
um when people talk about SEAL training
they don't fully
it's such a unique soul-crushing spine
crushing experience
yes and it's so weird you like how do
you explain to somebody like no no it's
like we got these boats on our heads and
they're like how bad can that be and
you're like no it's awful it's like put
a 40 pound Rock covered in sand on top
of your head and go run six miles with
it in the soft sand that's what it's
like right and this boat is like you
know this thing is bouncing in your head
just rubbing your head raw so we did
that if you tried to design something to
be just shitty and uncomfortable you
couldn't come up with a better thing I
think so I think honestly the most
uncomfortable thing I've ever had to do
in my life was just boats on heads just
carry carry that boat on your head yeah
but so we we did we did our first
evolution with that it was just crushing
me this boat was just crushing me and I
was like dude and I was I uniquely was
like having a very very hard time with
it I was like dude I'm like what is
happening right here right what is
happening right now long story short
what I ended up finding out was uh one
of the guys in our boat crew he was a
petty officer so he had to actually Bend
to buds before and he had like quit but
he was now back for his second attempt
at Buds and he was he was boat ducking
and that was my first experience with
boat ducking and I didn't know and he
was very good at being able to do it so
he was like hiding it somehow and so all
this extra weight as soon as he got as
soon as we rotated teams and that guy
was out
I was like oh okay now I can carry my
weight like it still sucks I can carry
my weight like this isn't so bad but I
realized I was like that dude was
ducking boat and he wasn't carrying his
weight so like I'm carrying extra weight
for him and that's and that's why it was
crushing me and then that was like my
first lesson of like oh okay teamwork
got it like yeah like that guy that
guy's not carrying his weight and
everyone else is suffering and I was
like I'm not gonna be that guy it's the
way it goes
um yeah so I'm gonna fast forward a
little bit in the book here you get to
after your 19th birthday you go into
hell week and for hell week you got
you've got vge which is a thing it's not
a thing I don't think it's a thing
anywhere else in the world like a thing
that you would talk about in normal
conversations yeah they call it veg in
buds vge what is it you got it here
viral gastritis enteritis basically
your gut is a disaster during this thing
and um you you had it what before hell
week you had it yeah so I got it Friday
before hell wait so couple weeks hell
week starts on a Sunday so Friday right
at the end of of training for that day
you have Saturday off and then you go
into uh you know hell week on on Sunday
evening Sunday afternoon Sunday evening
so right after training on Friday I was
like oh man I was like I'm not feeling
good so I went to my room and I started
vomiting and had diarrhea and all that
and I was like oh no I've got the viej
and I know viej lasts about five days
it's like it's this is gonna be in your
system you just gotta you just gotta
suck it up and so um what I actually did
was I like went and got a hotel room and
I just basically I couldn't keep it you
can't eat any food you can't keep any
fluids down
um honestly I should have gone to see
the doctor I don't know why I didn't
probably because I was in Buds and I was
like doctors with a plague because you
might get booed from training and I was
like that's not going to happen
um so yeah I went and sat in a in a
hotel room and uh just just vomited and
uh had diarrhea all weekend all day all
night until there was just dry heaving
and you know there's nothing else in my
system
um which ultimately ended up being okay
um so then I show up to I show up to
buds on Sunday report in for work and
I'm still sick as a dog and then they
put us in a room where you sit there for
about anywhere from eight to twelve
hours waiting for a hell week to start
and you just sit in this and sit in this
room and I started feeling a little
better I was like okay this isn't so bad
I was drinking some Gatorade I was like
okay like not so bad I had a couple
pieces of pizza I was like all right I'm
getting some calories in
as soon as hell week started literally
the second I step out of the tent when
they start the machine gun fire and
everything you have to run and hit the
surf the ver I didn't even make it to I
didn't make it three steps into how we
kind of vomited all over myself all the
red Gatorade all of that to this day I
don't drink red Gatorade I can't stand
it so I vomit this stuff all over me
as I'm running into the water I'm like
oh no this is not good
um and so then I vomit before we get to
the water and then we're on the grinder
um you know uh crawling around doing
push-ups and and all that stuff as
they're spraying us with hoses and I'm
I'm just continuing I'm continually
projectile vomiting I probably vomit on
myself a dozen times within that first
hour and all my fluids are gone and I'm
just like you've got to be kidding me I
was like you've got to be kidding me I'm
like 45 minutes into this thing and I'm
already smoked my one Saving Grace was
that VG is highly contagious so there
was a bunch of other guys who were also
sick and so because of that um
No Matter What boat crew you ended up in
there was another guy who had vge and
some of these guys they were on their
first day of it so they're crapping
themselves and so you have guys with
diarrhea running down their pants guys
vomiting on themselves the instructors
straight up do not care they would just
you know seriously like they were like
all right go go get in the water go
clean yourself off in the ocean that's
what they would do and we'd be getting
surf tortured and there'd be guys he'd
look over and there's a guy just you
know diarrhea just coming out of his
butt
um standing up in the surf and then that
water's like washing coming down towards
you yeah guys are getting sick the holy
was horrible but they just didn't care
you know and it was like hey man this
this is this is the real deal like you
you know put up or shut up Now's the
Time and um so then how we started and I
was you know sick as a dog
um I think I couldn't keep any food down
for Monday and Tuesday of hell week I
became completely emaciated the one
thing I think that kept me going though
was because I think my body was just
absorbing water my skin was absorbing
the water because you're always wet so
my body was getting hydration and
electrolytes I think literally from the
salt water and I don't know if that's
scientifically accurate or not but
something we're going with it we're
going with it yeah science
um yeah so that so they ended up uh
making it through
um and yeah it's arriving yeah you say
this
um going to the book here
at some point in the middle of the night
I reached my Breaking Point mentally my
vomiting had been reduced to constant
dry heave unless the instructors gave us
water which I puked up within minutes
the pain in my back it worsened in my
left hip locked up my muscles felt like
they were tearing as they tried to
protect the injured areas
and this was only a few hours into hell
week I still had five more days to go
and then it came lying in the oily
filthy San Diego Bay I began to feel
sorry for myself we were doing rocking
chairs an exercise where you lock arms
with the students next to you roll onto
your back in shallow water until your
toes touch the submerged ground behind
your head and then roll back over
coming back up salt water and sand Rush
up your nostrils burning like nothing
else
and that's just one rep it was too much
and with the instructors busy on the far
end of the line harassing some other
student I stopped even attempting to do
the rocking chairs which were nearly
impossible with my injured back
I stared at the black night sky shaking
my head as my body sent overwhelming
signals to my brain that it couldn't
possibly endure five more days I
scrolled through the reasons not to quit
your country needs you and what will Dad
think
but nothing worked the pain was blinding
then a strange thing happened in the
midst of my misery at the darkest moment
of my life I had a vision
it was as clear as anything I've ever
seen a Vietnam era U.S army helicopter
flying low between two jungle mountains
with a lone soldier standing on its Edge
I couldn't see his face because it was
looking toward the battle he was about
to get dropped into he was the only
person in the aircraft besides the
pilots and as my mental camera panned
around the side of the helicopter I saw
the man's face clearly it was me alone
with a rifle about to plunge into some
God forsaken jungle to complete some
kind of Mission to this day I have no
idea why I saw it except that it
mentally fortified me as I lay freezing
in the water sick and injured I suddenly
felt that I was meant to pass this test
quitting never crossed my mind again my
previous determination to continue
training until I fell unconscious
resumed and from that moment I was at
War the instructors were my enemy and I
would push forward no matter the cost
five days later I was still standing as
the instructors raised the American flag
and shouted hell week is secured as soon
as the words escaped their lips several
students felled the beach unconscious
and had to be dragged off in stretchers
I hadn't been the only one sick with
Vege and the hanging on for dear life
some wept some cheered
I just stared in disbelief
so there you go yeah dude you had the
freaking Vision that you were Rambo yeah
no that's that's I was like I look back
at that I go like what what was that
like what was like what was I seeing
what was I what was my brain was in such
distress
I had no idea what was going on I have
no idea was going on in that moment but
it was it was um yeah it was just 15
second
10 second even just image uh
visualization of something of what my
future could be or whatever I don't know
and I was like no this like this is what
you're supposed to be doing man you
don't you're not gonna quit and it was
yeah very strange very very strange yeah
so you end up getting rolled for your
back injury yeah I did get rolled um how
long do you rolled for four months four
months so two class two classes yeah and
then you get into second phase yep
everything cool in second phase yeah
everything everything goes well in
second phase uh past
um pool comp on on the first attempt
somehow made it through so that was good
yeah not too many people do that no no
uh they actually broke so when they do
the whammy knot the final knot that
you're not supposed to be able to get
and then somehow I got it undone
um and so when they when they hit me
again to tie the knot in my hoses
um they tied it so hard that they
actually snapped it they broke the hoses
and so they went through all the
emergency procedures to have me crawl
out of the pool and so I thought I'd
failed um because they were going they
only do those emergency procedures to
crawl out of the pool and stuff go
straight up if you failed your test so I
crawl out and I'm like all right cool I
failed I've still got three more
attempts and I stand up and then they're
the instructor is kind of like laughing
at me actually and they're like how do
you think he did I was like I don't know
I just like I know I messed up one thing
but they were like they hold up the hose
and it's just completely snapped in half
and they're like maddows 20 minutes pass
and I was like oh thank God all right
and then third phase all good yeah third
phase uh third phase no issues yeah made
it through
um definitely I mean it's as the as the
instructors put it you know third phase
is is Medieval when you get out to the
island
um but once you yeah once you get
through that
um yeah then you smooth sailing into
smooth sailing into sqt and sqt this is
you're probably getting trained by
um what is this now two thousand and
so you got a bunch of veterans a bunch
of guys that have been yes Iraq and
Afghanistan and stuff absolutely so all
of all of our instructors I'm very
fortunate the time that I went through
everyone was yeah everyone was a veteran
everyone had combat experience everyone
could tell us real world applications of
hey man like I've done this before
listen to me
um and there was also this certain level
of
um
intensity there and again I only have my
one experience with with the teams and
going through training but there was a
certain level of uh intensity there
because they knew and that the guys that
they were training were going to be
their new guys on the next deployment
when they were done with their training
cycle the dudes who they're putting
through training are going to be with
them you know going through the door on
their next deployment and so uh there
was a sense of I don't know a sense of
urgency there wasn't a ton of um uh it
was a little bit of a little bit of
coconut joking around but I mean it was
it was it was like it was very very
serious I remember it was very very
deadly serious because we were gonna we
were gonna be working together yeah in
the near future I mean that's the way it
goes like you if you're an instructor at
buds you literally get done with your
instructor tour and you're going right
to a team and you're with
X number of guys that you just put
through training that you either allowed
to get through training or you supported
getting through training but they're
going to be there yeah and you're going
to be working with them so that's a good
way to keep those guys honest for sure
yeah absolutely and then you end up
going to team one yeah did team one did
uh two pumps at team one so in 2014
um so this was also another reason why
it's really good that I didn't do the
officer rep uh because I did one of the
one of the last like West Coast
deployments to Afghanistan in 2014.
um and so when we were there we didn't
even do a full six month deployment we
did like a three month deployment or
like four month deployment because uh
the position that we were at um The
Outpost that we were at was literally
getting shut down so I left a couple
weeks before they shut down the
um the uh The Outpost because I had to
go to uh the Middle East a different
country in the Middle East because to
backfill some guys who had to go into
Iraq because there was this new uh
terror group called Isis and we're like
what's Isis uh in 2014 but no idea was
going on
um but anyway so when our when when my
platoon left Afghanistan they literally
just got helicopters in the middle of
night and just left left the Afghan
allies and just had to get out of there
because that was their their mission was
just to shut down the base and so it was
right at the end of the war and I think
you know obviously within a matter of
weeks no doubt the Taliban took that
position
um yeah you say this in your book and I
wanted to call this out because I think
it's pretty cool
um just from a being humble perspective
you say uh seals are expected to be
excellent everything they do but on a
physical level this was a constant
struggle for me on two separate
occasions I failed to climb a double
length caving ladder during
pre-deployment training once while
hiking a jungle mountain with a foreign
partner for us both my legs cramped due
to my inadequate Fitness and my knees
were completely locked out I was ordered
to give my Ruck to a junior seal who
carried it the last few hundred meters
to the top to say this was the most
humiliating moment of my life would be
an understatement and
yeah um and then you go on to say but I
never let my team or country down and
heat a battle and because of that I can
sleep peacefully at night so you you're
pretty humbled to just throw this into
the book that you had to have someone
carry your gear for you yeah and and
just so you know you're not the first
and you're not the last that yes has had
you know had their their M60 or their
Mark 48 taken away from them or care you
know giving up their radio or their rock
or their med pack that stuff happens man
like guys go down from heat or whatever
and so you weren't the first you won't
be the last you might be the first that
that openly admits it in a book so good
yeah well I think the the most important
thing is you know um you know later on
the book and and even in life today it's
like I make mistakes all the time I'm
not perfect and I think there's I I
wanted to always try to avoid uh trying
to sit there and pretend like like I'm
some perfect person because I know
there's a lot of people who listen to
this podcast and listen to other
podcasts and uh who look at what I do
and they go man like they they said it's
inspiring they're trying to learn
they're trying to be better and so when
you always present yourself as you
always present your best perfect self
like oh I'm perfect I'm you know I never
make any mistakes like I need to be the
the role model well in reality you know
nobody's Superman right so if you can
present yourself as a role model or you
can or you can explain the challenges
that you've been through as as as a
human everyone else is having those same
experiences like they're failing they're
failing whether it's in their in their
in their marriage or their business or
their work or whatever it is like
they're failing and they want to be
better or they've made mistakes and they
want to be better and so I just felt
it's important to be honest about this
and say like yeah I've messed stuff up
and you want to know what we keep we
keep going either way and you improve
and you get better
um and I'm not gonna sit here and
pretend like I'm Superman because Lord
knows I'm not yeah well that's the
opening chapter of the first book that I
wrote
um it's talking about being in a Blue on
Blue and I'm the guy in charge and it's
freaking it's an awful nightmarron uh
you know it's interesting that chapter
wasn't in the book and I used to it was
I retired before you came in which is a
little crazy but I retired in 2010 right
but in when I came home from that
deployment in 2006 I would brief all the
teams on what happened during this Blue
on Blue and how to prevent it from
happening and what mistakes I made and
all that stuff and that was part of when
a team would start their work up I would
give them a whole like combat leadership
brief and that would be one of the
sections of the brief was like hey I had
a blue we had a blue and blue with my
guys here's what happened
and as we were writing extreme ownership
life was like hey you should put a
chapter in about that because that was a
huge impact to guys going through
training to know that oh this is this
could happen it happened to you and it
could happen to them and so when I got
done writing that chapter I was like hey
yeah I wrote the chapter and I'm like I
think it's the bleed chapter in the book
and probably the name of the book too so
throwing that you know uh admission and
I mean look this is what happens like
you said no one's perfect like combat is
freaking crazy and the crazier it gets
the more opportunity there is for you to
do dumb mistakes and have things happen
that you didn't expect and
things that you look back and go I
should have done something different but
the hope is I can explain that to you
and you can go oh this happened to Jocko
here's how he stopped it so let's let's
make an adjustment
um all things that are important uh
you you in that you're a new guy
and you guys you know you're getting
some gun fights you have some uh you
talk in the book about uh Afghan get
wound on one of your Afghan soldiers
gets wounded yeah
um
you've got actually there's one part
where you guys you guys are basically I
think you get into a gunfight and then
you go into you back off a little bit
and you're kind of setting up uh you set
up a perimeter and you're sort of
expecting you're hearing probably radio
reports that the enemy is going to
attack yeah and so you're in a perimeter
and for those of you that don't know
what that means you're basically in a in
a position where you've got 360 degree
security you've got guns pointed in all
directions you try and get in a good
piece of terrain and that's kind of
where you're at you're hearing reports
that the enemy is going to attack and
then I'm gonna go to the book here it
says movement 50 meters away at the tree
line jutting out the open field the
unmistakable bobbing of heads caught my
eye that was fast looks like they're
here should I shoot no wait until you
see a weapon the bobbing heads were
moving swiftly I placed my finger on the
trigger and gently pressed come on let
me see your hands the heads made their
way the final few feet to the edge of
the tree line the crosshairs from my
weapon scope waited for the fighters to
emerge adrenaline course through my
veins while I tried to slow my breathing
aim Center Mass my finger tightened on
the trigger as the two little forms came
out from the tree line and sprinted
toward me what the hell are those girls
one was maybe eight years old the other
one no more than six my scope filled
with their faces tears streamed down
their cheeks as they ran toward me both
were wearing pink backpacks IEDs suicide
vests and this is earlier in the story
there's a backpack that is an IED that
was found and these these girls are
wearing the same type of backpack I
leveled the Crosshair on the oldest
girl's face and began screaming and
waving my left arm at them if they got
much closer I would have no choice go
away get out of here my voice Screech
with desperation as they ran at me stop
ten more feet and I was gonna kill them
both if they detonated their bombs in
our lines they'd certainly kill me and
my entire fire team and more seals would
die trying to evacuate our bodies I kept
screaming my finger on the trigger and
scope leveled at the first girl's face
but they kept coming my heart broke in
half exhaling I began pressing the
trigger when the girl suddenly stopped
I'll never forget the look she gave me
shock and horror
she knew I was going to kill her I held
the trigger and pleaded one more time
run get away
this time she got the message and
grabbing the other crying Girl by the
hand she turned and they both ran back
toward the Taliban lines
no Taliban attack ever materialized the
little girl's worthy attack reduced to
such by a culture that felt no shame in
sacrificing them to slaughter ultimately
using them as propaganda to recruit more
terrorists than to feed the Western
media a narrative about baby killing
Navy Seals
I assumed as I watched them their pink
backpacks bouncing as they ran back to
their caretakers
I thought back to my childhood when I
had been taught that you could Harbor
hatred and murder in your heart even if
you weren't acting on it in my head I
was certainly committing cold-blooded
murder I wanted Taliban heads to roll
and for the first time in my life I
understood what it was to truly hate I
began to deeply hate the Taliban I hated
them for what they did to those little
girls I hated them for putting me in a
situation where I had ultimately chosen
or had I ultimately chosen to kill those
little girls If Only They had taken
another Sev another step
several months later after more close
calls and violent firefights I returned
home the world around me was the same
but I had changed I was a seal and
violence was part of the job and that
part didn't bother me in the slightest
but my encounter with the little girls
had flipped a switch in me unlocking a
hatred for the enemy that continued to
well up
foreign
as you described like
that's an act in your head that you
committed I don't know if that makes
sense but as I read it I was like oh you
are a hundred percent ready to kill
these girls and thinking that you're
about to have to do this and by the
grace of God they stop and turn and run
away
but this left an impact on you
yeah I you know this was I don't know if
I mentioned it but this was this was my
second mission ever
um we'd been in a mission a couple days
prior to that that was my first combat
operation this is my second time in
combat ever and we were setting up the
perimeter because one of the Afghan
allies had been shot we were setting up
an hlz to calling uh hilos to to get the
wounded guy out and
yeah I I what was your job on the
platoon I was just a 46 Gunner at that
point yeah yeah I was just chilling God
bless machine Gunners yeah uh at the at
the time and then I ended up becoming
the the radio man again
um but the for those first two
operations I was just Karina Karina
machine gun which was great
um and so I I you know I I'd seen you
know movies and whatever about uh you
know suicide bombers and this and that
and the other thing and um as you
alluded to earlier that day right before
we got into this gun fight we had seen
an IED on the side of the road and a
girl's backpack the dog sat on it
meaning like hey there's explosives in
there we blew it in place and this is
why the Taliban attacked us because they
knew exactly where we were after that
bomb went off
um and so then these little girls come
running at me and they're wearing the
same exact kind of backpack now I don't
know for sure that they were suicide
vests but I I have to I have to treat it
like a threat now
and um
yeah this left a huge impact on me
because you know I'm looking for Taliban
in my head I'm like looking for some you
know some dude with an AK for me to
shoot and also now in my head I'm fully
committed I'm squeeze I remember I was
physically squeezing the trigger like
halfway waiting to put that last little
bit of pressure in
um and I was like I'm going to kill
these little girls I'm going to kill
them and literally had they gone any
closer I was like I have no choice and
um
so yeah this this left a huge impact on
me I couldn't I couldn't believe it I
just couldn't believe that I I knew in
my head I knew conceptually that evil
existed I knew in my head conceptually
that bad guys would would send would
would do these kinds of things
but just to see it
in person for the first time
um was was yeah left left quite the left
quite the impact on me and that's a big
reason why I do what I do now or but you
know we'll get to it later but I started
stronghold rescue and relief this is
because I realized man these civilians
are caught in the middle of these wars
and uh they have no one to protect them
they have no one to help them and they
they don't know what to do they don't
know which direction to run and it gets
them caught in bad bad situations
yeah and one of the underlying themes in
the book
um
you say here I didn't realize it at the
time but humans are not capable of
handling hatred it's an infectious
crippling disease spreading from person
to person bringing unknowable amounts of
violence and death
it's a selfish and cruelty that causes
all forms of evil which plagues our
world
so
and it's like this now you have this
sort of plague of hatred that's welling
up in you
um
and again I'm touching on points of the
book get the book so you can read all
the details of this I'm going to fast
forward a little bit here you say about
a year after returning from Afghanistan
I lost Consciousness during a dive
training exercise in San Diego Bay when
my equipment malfunctioned I nearly
drowned my teammates some of whom had
the same equipment malfunction but
regained Consciousness saved my life I
woke up to a fellow seal doing chest
compressions on me after having been
unconscious for about five minutes
during the ride to the hospital I was
extremely confused and although I'd gone
unconscious underwater from hypoxia I
thought I had suffered an age arterial
gas embolism which can cause brain
damage heart failure and even death as I
lay there essentially paralyzed from him
from having had convulsions while
drowning it seemed to me there was a 50
50 chance I was going to die but the
truth was I didn't care
I had no fight in me to stay alive
because life meant nothing to me I spent
two nights in the hospital and was then
driven home by a buddy in my platoon I
spent days alone in silence trying to
get my lungs to work properly this was
my lowest time in my life and the idea
of suicide crossed my mind more than
once
what was the accident would you guys
have bad soda sorb or something so we
were testing out a new rig
um and so what happened was the actually
wasn't so absorbed this was crazy
because we had these brand new diving
Rigs and
um so for the listener the the way that
the these diving rigs works is you have
100 oxygen put into the system you
breathe 100 oxygen and then you have a
chemical that scrubs out the carbon
dioxide and other things that you exhale
and then that way only oxygen gets put
gets put back in your system so we got
these new bottles brand new bottles and
we were trying out these new rigs the
problem was the bottles had only had
ambient air in them the brand new O2
bottles had not been purged of the
ambient air so they had like I don't
know two percent ambient air and then
they had been jammed with O2 so when we
did our pre-dive checks when we did
everything nobody had symptoms because
there wasn't enough
um there wasn't there wasn't enough bad
air in the system to have any have any
kinds of issues and so what happened was
is during the dive
the um the the basically everybody
started getting hypoxia the guys with
the bad bottle started getting hypoxia
without realizing it but you only felt
it at depth or like you it was like less
severe at depth and so when we came to
the surface
um the everything expanded and then the
everybody had basically shallow water
blackout so as I came to the surface at
about at about the last thing I remember
was that I checked my dive I checked I
checked my my depth gauge I think it was
nine feet it was nine feet was where I
was at I looked up saw the bubbles
making sure I wasn't going faster than
the bubbles
um uh as I was ascending the next thing
um there's a guy there's a seal doing
doing chest compressions on me and what
had happened was I passed out underwater
my die buddy saved me
um we'd also were carrying extra gear
and like these um like propellers and
stuff on our legs because we were trying
we're testing out this new equipment and
um so like I totally would have just
sank to the bottom uh so he grabbed me
uh you know inflated my vest got a bunch
of guys together there was three there
was at that point there was two other
guys
who went unconscious as well as soon as
they hit the surface but I slipped back
under at some point drowned and uh bit
my tongue crapped myself
um and uh actually I read the official
report from the OIC the officer in
charge of the scene he was one of the
guys who was diving as well he was
watching the whole thing he wrote in his
report uh something along the lines of I
looked at Matos I saw that he was dead
so I decided to move on to other guys
who I could actually save and could help
because the guys were working on me it
was totally blue uh and like white and
so they thought I was dead they were
just kept on doing compressions on me
and I woke up thank God was paralyzed
had no idea what's going on and then
ended up uh yeah getting basically
Medevac out to uh to one of the
hospitals it's about a few days there
yeah
check so yeah you are not feeling good
um at this juncture uh you meet with a
psychologist
um you know you're talking about
what you're doing with your life you
pretty much wanted to go back to war
um then again you you provide a lot of
details in this that people should get
the book for but ultimately
you decide you you
need to leave the Navy like you just not
going to do this anymore
um you start doing research to figure
out what you should be doing and you
find out about the free Burma Rangers
um
how did you find out about the free
Burma Rangers actually my my brother my
brother mentioned them to me because my
brother's done a lot of World Travel and
I've done like humanitarian work in a
bunch of different places and I said
like is there any place that I could go
to to use my military skills
um to to to some effect but more
importantly my my intention at the time
um was to during my second deployment we
were down in Southeast Asia we were
actually in Thailand and particularly
while we were in Thailand for like six
weeks
um I was very frustrated
um just with life in general and I and I
understood the global politics why you
can't just have seals go in and start
crushing souls in Burma but I knew that
we're you know we're at one hour
helicopter right away from Villages
where people are being raped and
murdered and massacred and now keep in
mind in Afghanistan those two little
girls
um you know caught in the middle of that
Crossfire that was that was a very very
um you know that was a very important
point in my life it was a turning point
in How I and how I view the world and
how and what I wanted to do and so I was
like hey man like you have a full we
have a full platoon of seals here we
have our weapons we're sitting here in
Thailand like just put us in put us like
put us in the game like we're we're
we're right there right and again I
understand the geopolitics why that
doesn't work but at the point I was like
well I have to I have to step out I have
to step out how well were you tracking
what was going on in Burma with like the
ethnic cleansing that's going on where
where'd you catch on to that story
um just from
um just I guess just just from the news
and just different places and I was just
looking at like hey like what's going on
in the world um I wasn't wasn't tracking
it super close I didn't know all the
internal politics of it or anything like
that but that was you know I knew that
there was stuff happening there I knew
there were stuff happening in other
parts of the world too but in that
particular case I was like dude we're an
hour ride we're an hour helicopter right
away right
um and so because of that I what I
decided I was like I want to start some
kind of an organization some kind of a
company I didn't I didn't know the
difference between a for-profit or
non-profit I had no idea how this would
work
um but I was like I want to start
something because I wanted to start
something that could hire former team
guys or spec ops guys to go in and help
and help these people we're not looking
for a fight but like if we can help
these people in Conflict zones if we can
help these people protect themselves
that's what I want to do like why why
would I like these people deserve these
people who are under horrible attack
they don't have seals to protect them
they don't have Rangers and Green Berets
and so calm to come in and protect them
they don't have the Marines they don't
have that they have they have a dude
with a with a musket maybe a dude with
an uh an M16 from Vietnam you know some
black market rifle and that's it and
then there's this overwhelming Army
coming in to crush them rape rape and
murder your wife kill your kids take all
your stuff and just leave you destitute
that's that's what's happening on a
daily basis in this place right in Burma
in particular and so I was like I can't
save everybody but it's like you know
what if we go in and we and we help in
some sort of way what if we help them
protect themselves what if we bring in
the aid that they need right so I wanted
to start an organization
and that would that would do that I
didn't know what that was going to look
like ultimately and it ended up becoming
stronghold rescue and relief what I do
now and I'm back in Burma very very
heavily involved there and
um so at the time though I was like I
don't know how to get into this I don't
I need to get educated I need to go
travel I need to go just just go just go
there and help just figure out a way to
go there and help and so
um that's when I heard I'd ask my
brother about it and I heard about FBR
so they work obviously in Burma but then
at the time they were also working in in
doing volunteer work in other locations
as well but your first your initial
Venture into this was actually into the
Thailand Burma border right so excuse me
yes I did go there just to to meet these
guys and see like hey like what's going
on introduce myself like what do you
guys got going on like how can I help I
want to learn I made it very clear I was
like hey I'm here because I want to
start something
um to you know for veterans to go do
this like as a profession and um so yeah
I went to I went to Thailand and I ended
up um going along the Thai Burma Border
in a boat to go check out one of the
refugee camps with um uh with one of the
uh with one of the guys who was
volunteering with FBR a guy named Paul
and so we go up we go up the river and
we go to this refugee camp which I've
never been to refugee camp before and
I'm walking around and I'm like man this
is this is rough this is this is your
life there is no there is no out there
is no way out this is this is your life
now and uh the the refugee camp was
literally right on the river that
separates uh Thailand and Burma and so
the the and then right across the river
there's a Thai Army Outpost basically
there to have help protect the civilians
to make to help to protect these
refugees because if the Burma Army comes
in they could go in there and Massacre
all these people basically the Thai Army
is there to stop and prevent that from
happening so we go into this refugee
camp
um it's quite the experience
um it was it was actually very peaceful
uh and uh but but I realized like these
people have no they have no way out
anyway we come back down the river and
as we're going back down the river these
guys stop our boat and uh they start our
boat pulls off to the side and these
guys come out and start loading rice
these big bags of rice into our boat
and um I'm not really sure I don't
really know who they are I'm just I'm
just kind of like all right whatever I I
don't know anything about this situation
and we get back down the river and as
soon as we as soon as these guys are
done loading rice into our boat the guys
I was with were like dude that was Burma
Army that was Burma army they literally
just stopped our boat and loaded rice
into it and that rice that they have is
stolen from the from the Korean people
in particular along the border there
that's stolen from the Korean people and
now like we're transporting it for them
into Thailand so they can sell it for
the Burma Army and so the Burma Army is
the is the oppressive group that is uh
they basically run Burma
um was that just like an in-dige boat
like a random endage boat yep I just I
just hired a random vintage boat to go
about it to go up to go up the river
yeah so they so the boat driver knew
whatever was going on yeah so he was
probably the deal was like Hey man next
time next time some uh some white dude
comes up the river don't worry I'll get
free transport for you down the down the
river so I think that's what happened
yeah how long did you spend in Burma on
that first or Thailand and Burma on that
first trip I think maybe a week or two
not much
and you're still not out of the Navy yet
I'm still technically in the Navy I'm
technically online by the way this is
not recommended for you young uh active
duty military personnel yeah don't do
this it's not highly recommended yeah
definitely don't try this at home um so
yeah so I still had I had two months of
regular leave saved up and the the
option was you can you could sell back
your leave you take terminal leave
and then you use like if you have 60
days you can take your last 60 days you
get out of the Navy but when you do
terminal leave you lose all your special
pays and everything like that it all
goes away because now you're no longer
serving and or the other option is you
can just continue to stay in the Navy
until the end of until the end of your
term and then you can sell back the the
time or whatever they'll give you a
paycheck or something for that and I was
not cool with either I was like nah man
so what I did was I just took regular
leave I don't know where I was saying I
was like I'm gonna go to Wisconsin I
took regular leave for like 29 days or
whatever it was ended it on a Saturday
and then started with the trip to Burma
yeah and then ended but I the way I did
the paperwork was uh and end the trip on
a Saturday and then my next leave chit
starts on Monday and so I just I'm like
all right I hope in the middle of this
that on the one day that the one day
like left in the Navy like but it's a
weekend I just hope I don't get called
yeah because I'm not going to be in the
country so um yeah so I went to went to
Thailand and then I ended up at that 30
day Mark during that weekend I actually
ended up being in Iraq So within 30 days
I had no intention I had no idea I was
gonna end up there ended up in Iraq
um yeah on leave on literal leave and
then one of the days technically I
wasn't even on leave I was still on
active duty not on later
yeah so you get to Iraq I'm gonna fast
forward a little bit here in the book
you say the procession of Humvees came
to a halt outside garbala
as the bmps finish spreading out into
their battle positions like setting
pieces on a chessboard General Mustafa
the Bathurst era General from saddam's
Army and the commander of the 36 Brigade
walked beside his Humvee shouting orders
into His Radio while his Entourage of
assistance and Junior commanders
followed close behind in a huddled
massive camouflage rifle and notebooks
David Eubank stepped out of the Humvee
directly in front of us and grabbed his
rifle motioning motioning Shaheen to
follow they would support the assault on
foot David providing Immediate Care to
troops on the front line and guiding our
ambulance into the chaos if needed and
Shaheen are lethargic yet somehow Brave
interpreter would be David's mouthpiece
to the Iraqis
um you you talk about the fact that you
are gonna be kind of hanging back for
this initial well the initial plan is
you're gonna be hanging back a little
bit sort of as a reserve component which
you don't like very much because you
want to go get some uh and again uh I
guess I fast forward a little too much
this is we're setting up for a big
massive assault this is this is on on
karbala right yes
um
and you again you go into the details in
the book get the books you can learn
about this stuff but you say the salt
the assault began with an earth-shaking
volley of fire from the Iraqi 36 Brigade
big clouds of exhaust and the rumble of
engines filled the air as the first wave
began to move on the village Iraqi
soldiers in giant metal machines were
bearing down to destroy the Isis
Defenders and Liberate the people of
garboola Isis returned fire immediately
mortars and Rockets impacted and
exploded in sporadic plumes of gray
smoke within the assault Tracer rounds
and heavy machine gun fire raked the
tanks sending bullets arcing at obtuse
angles across the battlefield fast
forward boom Another explosion rocked
the ground behind us we both spun around
as the Humvee we've been using for cover
less than 30 seconds before exploded the
driver's side wheel right where I'd been
positioned had struck a mind I should be
dead faiz and I immediately began to
hurry back to the Humvee to treat the
wounded we tried to stay in the tracks
made by the tanks as much as possible
looking for more mines as we moved to
say it was terrifying moving through a
field with now confirmed Minds would be
an understatement we reached the Humvees
the Humvee as the vehicle's occupants
were crawling out tears streamed from
their dazed eyes they'd obviously gotten
concussions how severe we couldn't tell
but they were otherwise okay I ran to
ran over to check on the FBR ambulance
directly behind the exploded Humvee to
see if they'd been hit all good Kevin
said with a quick thumbs up the
ambulance and the people inside were
still intact boom Another bigger
explosion a fiery mushroom cloud dwarf
the BMP and the assault wave that phias
and I had been running towards Car Bomb
we had not turned back for the men in
the Humvee or had we not turned back
from the med for the men in the Humvee
the shrapnel from the second explosion
would have sliced Faison and I in half I
should be dead again
so you br this is just chaos out of the
gate chaos out of the gate yeah
and your job I mentioned that you were
going to be in the rear with the
reserves obviously that didn't work out
too great for you your your selection of
your rear position wasn't all that all
that accurate No you guys started
receiving mortars and car bombs you know
almost immediately but your goal is is
to provide support
primarily medical support that's the
alleged mission that what you're going
to try and do is you're going to try and
provide medical support for the Iraqi
troops that are assaulting karbala yes
that's what you guys are doing but you
guys get so close to the front lines
that it ends up you you just can't
you can't not get engaged in
combat exactly
um
I'm gonna fast forward a little bit the
top hatch of our BMP flew open in a few
Iraqi soldiers popped their heads out
smiling and shouting at us in Arabic
none of them were wearing helmets or
paying attention to the whole Isis
Menace only 100 meters away I threw up a
peace sign and they did the same they
seem to be having the time of their
lives grinning and waving at the two
white Americans taking cover outside
their tank
you guys are going to get sniped any
second now the soldiers then began
yelling yala yala and waving us away
the BMP suddenly twists on axis David
faiz Shaheen and I jumped out of the way
as the BMP roared to life and sped off
leaving us exposed less than 100 meters
from the garbala from garbala and the
hidden Isis fighters fighters without
saying anything we ran David led the way
and I brought up the rear pushing
Shaheen forward and dumping rounds for
my AK-47 into every dark Village window
facing us cover and move the rifle
kicked into my shoulder as I watched the
bullets tear through the doorways and
slam into walls cover and move we made
it to the BMP at the edge of the village
just as the Iraqi soldiers were
dismounting to begin clearing homes as
soon as the soldiers had jumped out the
BMP sped off again
so
what are you thinking at this juncture
what are you are you going through your
decision-making process and maybe uh
questioning it so fun fact this
particular battle that we're talking
about this was actually technically my
last day in the Navy in the US Navy the
next day was like my day off or whatever
um so when I got to Iraq our mission was
to I was I was working with this other
group of volunteers FBR guys and uh
basically our mission was to provide
medical support for the Iraqi Army
because Iraqi Army didn't have Medics at
all and so the Iraqi Army was charged
with clearing Isis out of out of Iraq
with a little bit of there was a little
bit of U.S Special Operation support
um but not not a full not a full not
full support
um so this particular battle was
um they were clearing a small village
right outside in the outskirts of
mosulin the Plains of Nineveh so it's
just flat open ground flat open dried
desert all the way to this little
village and Isis is in there so as as
the book describes there's basically a
World War II style tank assault um the
Iraqi unit that we're working with is a
tank unit it so they have a bunch of
armored Humvees they have a t72 and they
have an M1 Abrams and they have a bunch
of like Russian bmps so these are like
armored personnel carriers and all of
these all these tanks are at the same
time just firing dumping rounds into the
small village and then they just rush
across the open Isis is in there they're
shooting back
um so again yeah our mission I was with
a Iraqi soldier named fize so here's a
big look of English I don't speak a look
of Arabic it's me and him
um and you know the the previous few
weeks I'd been in in Iraq at that point
we'd just done humanitarian Aid and that
was like why I was there I was like
let's do humanitarian Aid and and let's
see what we can do to help the people
but now we're doing medical support So
as we go across this field and assault
into Isis positions
um we realize that we're in a Minefield
and so uh the vehicles are blowing up
um the t-72 ended up blowing up it ended
up having its tracks knocked off and so
I was right next to I was using a Humvee
for cover because we didn't realize
there was anti-vehicle mines so I was
using this Humvee for cover and then
um the medic I was with the Iraqi medic
I was with there was maybe 200 yards
between us and the front line of the
first line of troops and this Iraqi
medic he wasn't really a medic but he
just was like the medic guy uh he was
like he was signaling to me to go
forward with him he wanted me to go
forward with him so he just takes off
running and my job was to stay with this
guy in particular so I was like you've
got to be kidding me so we leave cover
we leave the cover of these armored
Humvees and tanks to run across several
hundred yards of flat open ground we can
see we can see Isis positions right
there rounds are coming you know mortars
mortars are dropping and so as we're
running across the open that's the part
where you read there all sudden the 10
seconds or 15 seconds later the Humvee
that we had both been standing next to
the tire that I had been standing next
to for cover that particular Tire hit an
anti-vehicle mine blew the entire front
of the Humvee off only because it was up
armored the guys inside survived
um so I would have been blown into a
thousand pieces so I'm like you've got
to be kidding me so then we turned
around to go treat those guys because we
think there's going to be wounded as
we're running back toward the the the
the Humvee that's been blown up the
position that we've been running toward
before A Car Bomb comes out to hit the
bmps so to try and blow the bmps so that
then blows up and we're like oh my
goodness you gotta be kidding me so then
we run back so that the continuation of
the stories we then run back across the
field again to go see if there's wounded
so I'm just following around this like
super Brave Little Iraqi army guy and
he's no idiot he's well we're staying in
tank tracks he's you know he's pacing
himself he's like looking around but
it's his job to be the medic and so it
was my job just to follow him around
when we got to the edge of the village
as the as the the tanks then have to not
have to the the armored personnel
carriers have to get let their troops
out to go clear the village
well they hadn't gone in to clear the
village yet so Isis is still in these
buildings 50 meters 100 meters away and
the the Iraqi soldiers then you know
finally get out of these bmps
um and they go in and start assaulting
the buildings and they're horrible at it
zero training these These are tank
drivers these are um
truck drivers these guys aren't even
infantry they just are sort of like all
right man like your turn I'll drive now
you go you go clear the building over
there and so we end up just total total
mistake
um or not even mistake just just the way
it was uh we end up mixed in with the
Iraqi Army so now we're just Iraqi Army
infantry basically uh going room to room
clearing stuff and they're just shooting
wildly there's there's no unit
deconfliction they're shooting this way
the other guys are shooting that way and
there's IEDs everywhere there's trip
wires everywhere
um and then that's when at the beginning
of the podcast you talked about how we
ended up going into the one building
with the grenades and stuff that was
that was in the middle of all this
because we were just like so Dave had
been a special forces officer and a
ranger before and so it's like me and
him were like all right looks like we
gotta kind of take Point here and just
and like if either either we take point
or like everyone's gonna die anyway so
we gotta we gotta do what we gotta do
there's a whole underlying element to
this entire thing that is not going to
be clear to people that
weren't in the military and maybe even
didn't serve in Iraq and that is there's
like a layer of
you know when you're dealing with the
Iraqi Army
like if this was a story about you and
you were with an army you know armored
Battalion going into the city
you'd say oh I joined them and they
would look at you and you'd kind of have
some kind of mutual understanding about
what the what the world was like about
well the way things function inside the
military there's like a General Baseline
like understanding of what we're doing
what our mission is how we're going to
support each other what it means you
know what you and I working together as
a pair there's like and this is this is
with Special Operations to the to the
Army to the Marine Corps like I work
with the Army in the Marine Corps all
the time
you walk into a room and there's a
there's a baseline level of
understanding of what we're doing and
what we know and what we understand as
American fighting men
and it's a certain level of
of order there's a certain level of
order that just exists
with Iraqis that doesn't really exist
with the Iraqi soldiers like there's
it's a lower level like there's gonna be
crazy things that are happening like
like you're gonna see like this Iraqi
medic that you're talking about Brave as
could be and like he might just do
something that makes no sense whatsoever
and other people are doing things that
don't make any sense whatsoever so it's
like a decentralized command with with
decentralized command inside the US
military there's still a thread of we
all kind of understand a baseline of how
we're going to work together
sometimes with the Iraqi Army you just
be like what is this what's what is this
wait there's a tank over there they're
going in the opposite direction I have
no idea why why this is happening and by
the way it's like things are going to
happen that are just not even less
expected look combat is crazy and crazy
things happen and troops do things that
you don't expect there's another there's
another multiple of that happening when
you're dealing with the Iraqi Army in my
experience yeah absolutely and I'm and
I'm totally confused and it you know
this was also this was also difficult
not difficult but it was just very
strange for me because you know
literally still technically it's like so
I'm still technically a Navy SEAL and
I'm used to like a highly precise like
highly coordinated uh group of of like
military professionals and we have our
way of doing things and we're very very
good at it and so it was so strange to
be working at that level and then hop on
a flight and all of a sudden now you're
in this like heavy actual honest to God
combat like things are blowing up this
is insane what is happening right now
and you don't have seals with you you
don't have the US military air support
you don't have the like it's just you
and and some guy who volunteered for the
Iraqi Army who has basically zero three
weeks ago like three weeks ago or even
if he's been around a long time he
doesn't have any level of training he
doesn't you know there's no
standardization as you're saying and so
everything is just total chaos there's
no command and control I was looking for
because I wanted to make sure we didn't
have a blue and blue I wanted to make
sure because like forces are entering
the small village from multiple
directions I'm like dude someone's gonna
shoot like we're gonna end up shooting
ourselves or we're gonna end up shooting
some of our own guys
um and so then because of this
um yeah Dave and I we just basically had
to
um just you know no words no words
needed spoken it's like hey man we got a
job to do all right let's if we're gonna
survive this we just have to we just
kind of have to take point and that's
what ended up happening we ended up kind
of like leading in some some in some
sectors like the assault into the into
the city because it was like if we don't
we're gonna die
yeah there's a I'm trying to think of a
way to describe it maybe this is a way
there's some there's a little bit more
of a level of every man for himself when
you're dealing with like the Iraqi Army
where look they know that they're
together but that at a certain point
they're just like oh no I'm gonna do
this and so they might take it's every
man for someone it might be like this
squad or this platoon they're just gonna
let go and do stuff yeah and you're sort
of like well what's going on what are
they doing what are they thinking so
yeah this is Mayhem
um and again you detail this stuff in
the book get the book I'm gonna fast
forward a little bit towards the end of
this thing you say there have been a few
other brushes with death that day
finally the next morning the Iraqi
soldiers in garbala told us they'd heard
two explosions beneath the tunnel shaft
that had been filled in this is the
tunnel that you guys cleared trapped
Isis Fighters were blowing themselves up
Underground
that meant they'd been with us in the
tunnels the whole time armed with
explosives they'd hidden themselves in
the elevated passageway above our heads
only to be buried alive as soon as we
left
seeing me shake my head in disbelief
David just chuckled welcome to the free
Burma Rangers Ephraim
I was technically on vacation during the
assault of garbala using saved leave
time I'd opted and I have to take turn
to leave two months prior
I was until April 8th the day after the
assault my time in the U.S military
officially ended
fast forward a little bit here and again
I apologize I'm going to read
seven percent of this book or four
percent of this book right now there's
so many wild stories in this thing the
girl was maybe 10 years old she came
with her father
she was beautiful fair skinned and Sandy
blue blonde hair light-colored features
making her somewhat exotic in that part
of the world her father motion tore
towards me she burst into tears back in
a way and this is that you're like
clearing doing your falling off
follow-on medical support
um her father motioned her toward me and
she burst into tears backing away and
shaking her reaction was eerily similar
to Ranger our self-appointed guard puppy
who had been abused by people before hey
I said pulling off my gator sunglasses
and smiling I knelt down and held out my
hand gently speaking after a few months
she stopped crying and cautiously walked
over to me with a shy smile I knew it
wasn't appropriate to hug her so I shook
her hand and gave her a packet of of
sweet crackers I asked Shaheen to come
over and translate the girl's father
explained the problem to us he says the
girl started peeing the bed for no
reason Shaheen said Shaheen and I shot
each other knowing glance he doesn't say
he says he doesn't know why but I don't
believe him we both looked at the father
who couldn't understand our English this
is not good Shaheen went on not normal
something's upsetting her do you think I
trailed off but Shaheen knew what I
meant someone had been molesting her the
father Maybe buddhaish was here for a
while too either way the father
definitely knows or he's a complete
idiot I forced a smile at the father
even though I wanted to kill him the
little girl and her father disappeared
back in the village while we moved on to
the next patients in a war zone
follow-up Medical
follow-ups simply don't exist rather
than answers or Solutions you often are
left with only doubt confusion anger and
sadness
so you're going into these places after
Isis had been there and you know yes
it's a freaking nightmare yeah and so
there's all this there's all this trauma
there's all these different injuries we
would walk in
um and I remember one lady she was uh
yeah she was like light-skinned exotic
lady uh like again exotic for that kind
of part of the world but basically she
had been just repeatedly raped over and
over and over again by different Isis
Fighters she had been pregnant by an
Isis fighter as well and that they had
also tortured her so they would like
um so she showed me her hand and they
would cut off like one knuckle at a time
on different fingers and so like both of
her hands were all like a lot of the
fingers were like short and some of them
were completely missing because every
once in a while they would chop off one
section of her of her finger like at the
joint and they would just do this
repeatedly
um and I never obviously never got that
lady's full story because she didn't
speak English and whatnot but
um we you know gave her food and what we
could and you know the baby she had was
uh was was an Isis baby and yeah so like
Isis was going through it and when we
use the term daesh uh Dash
um the that's what the locals called
Isis so everyone nobody said Isis
everyone said daesh and so we were going
along
and the outskirts of mosul this is all
happening around mosul this assault on
garbala all these humanitarian Aid stuff
and all this relief it's all the people
who have just been affected by ISIS
around mosul as we're clearing the area
leading into the City and so we're
seeing all these atrocities and as we
get closer and closer and closer to the
city things get worse and worse and
worse and we see worse atrocities and
we're hearing these horror stories and
eventually it leads into it leads into
we go into the City and then things
exponentially increase in violence and
horror yeah
it's like
um I don't think I've actually ever seen
one of these movies but I know the basic
plot the movie Saw have you ever seen
the movie Saw yeah so so have you seen
the movie Yes yes
but like you take that and it seems kind
of you know there's some guy that plays
like whatever second Twisted games with
people and makes them kill each other
and makes them torture each other and
kills them and but this is like this is
what's happening it's actually worse
than that it's like the worst uh horror
movie that you can put together and
that's what's going on
um
I'm gonna get here real quick in the
book I had been in Iraq nearly a month
my Visa was going to expire decided to
fly to Italy for a few days of r r even
though seeing Italy was a great
experience the tourism luxury felt so
gluttonous and my last night in Rome I
felt I slept fitfully longing to get
back in the field fbr'd become my
purpose my team my family I arrived back
in erbil on the afternoon of May 1st and
my brother and Skye were there to pick
me up and I'm doing a really bad job so
you've got these characters in here
you've already we've already mentioned
the first one that I was mispronouncing
his names I what was his eyes zase which
ones um you got a bunch of characters in
here yeah
you got Skye who's a former Marine yeah
yeah your brother is actually here yeah
so how's that happen so
um so like I said my brother done a lot
of humanitarian work in a lot of
different places
um and he'd spent like a year traveling
and so when I got there and there was
you know the big humanitarian need was
there uh basically was like Hey man like
why don't you come out and join us and
so I found for him I was like yeah he's
a good dude he was no military
background or anything and so he came
out was like an ambulance driver and a
truck driver one of the things about FBR
is
um at least at this time and even even
now today is like pretty much like
anybody can kind of show up and just go
out there and it's uh you know it's it's
it's interesting to say the least
because you end up with a lot of you end
up with guys who have you know special
ops background and then you end up with
like some school teacher from Kansas or
something who has like who just like
really really wants to help and so it's
just it can be this weird like
unprofessional mix that doesn't really
accomplish the mission as effectively as
as it possibly as it probably should
um so there's some of those some of
those issues and things like that but in
my with my uh with my brother's case in
particular
um yeah he he was he did actually really
great job so he basically became an
ambulance driver and would just
transport wounded patients and things
like that
um especially when we got into the City
and um so that's that's why he was
that's why he was there he was there
volunteering as well
um
yeah I'm gonna fast forward a little bit
again
um
it'd been six weeks since I first set
foot in Iraq and we were now heading
into Western mosul the heart of Isis
resistance in Iraq Iraqi Army battle
takes and bmps from other brigades
stayed to the left of the field which
was certainly mined in a calm a in a
column and Advance toward the back end
of musharifa
they were tasked with enveloping the
Western mosul neighborhood from the rear
while General Mustafa and the men of the
tanks of the 36 were tasked with a
direct frontal assault against a
well-entrenched mind protected Isis
fighters bmps on a Left Flank erupted in
violent explosions from mines and Isis
car bombs as we Advanced across the open
while enemy mortars and Rockets
redoubled and exploded around us a
hundred meters to our left a BMP hit a
mine that blew off one of its tracks
Skye and I sprinted across the field to
see if anyone was wounded but the thick
armor had saved everyone inside we
reached the top of a small hill with a
trench and downed power lines strewn on
the ground
musharifa was just 300 meters away now
and the bullets rockets and mortars were
too thick to continue advancing on foot
Justin Skye David shafin Shaheen
Kevin Zhao and the two new Karen Medics
silverhorn and slowly who had joined us
all loaded into the Humvee on loan from
the Iraqi Army to follow the first wave
of tanks into the outskirts
of the city so again I I you've got all
these characters that I'm reading right
now they're all you describe who they
are in the book so
um get the book so you can get some of
those details but here you are you guys
are going into this again it's just a
freaking
assault and I will say this and I
recognize this as the assault was
happening I'm watching it on the news
from back here
the I even though I was just trying to
explain this sort of underlying chaos
that exists within the Iraqi Army it was
very impressive
to see the level of sacrifice that they
were willing to make you know in the
Battle of ramadi there was there was
that wasn't going to happen like there
was a whole Battalion that fled the
battlefield they like they just left
they just up and left they just were
done fighting and they left I think they
they had an attack on their commanding
officer they had a couple guys get
wounded a couple guys get killed and the
Battalion just left
and there was a another uh company that
got took a mass casualties and they just
disappeared like so when when I was
watching this from
you know the safety of you know my
air-conditioned house in California
I was very impressed the fact that the
the Iraqis were in the lead and they
were taking heavy casualties and they'd
go back again and they'd go back again
and go back again that was a totally
different that was actually a
totally different Army than we dealt
with now look where they're Brave some
Brave Iraqi soldiers in the Battle of
Ramada yes there were absolutely and
there were some really good small
elements of people of soldiers but
broadly speaking they weren't ready to
do what was going down here so it was it
was nice to see that some of the effort
that had been put into training and
selecting the Iraqi military forces by
America turned out to it seemed to have
worked because they were willing to make
sacrifices yeah absolutely that was that
was one thing I was I was very skeptical
going in as well you know working with
uh working with the Iraqi Army I'd never
served in Iraq during my time in the
military and so this was um this is a
whole new culture a whole new experience
for me and my only experience I'd been
in Afghanistan where again like you said
basically the same exact story most of
the guys at that point in 2014 most of
the Afghans we worked with uh they
didn't they didn't want to fight very
much and we have we have like I've like
helmet cam footage of us and like uh in
firefights where we're completely
surrounded by Taliban literally on all
four sides calling in air strikes to
keep the Taliban from overrunning us and
the uh the Afghans are just sitting in a
trench just chilling like eating food
and just relaxing and it was the most
strange thing to me so I kind of
expected that from the Iraqi Army
um but I was extremely impressed as well
when I went there and I saw the level of
sacrifice and the level of Courage the
skill was not there the tactics were not
there the proficiency was not there the
willingness to do the work was there and
that's how they made it happen and they
did take Mass casualties they did take
heavy heavy casualties and I remember
particularly this this day before we
walked before we did the direct frontal
assault into mosul which was just like
the attack on garbala times like five so
there's way more true way more way more
um
Iraqi army tanks because it wasn't just
the 36 Brigade now it was like the
entire first uh Iraqi Army yeah division
the entire division is there assaulting
across maybe like a three kilometer wide
area frontal assault straight into mosul
um but that morning as we've been moving
toward the city getting into position to
make the attack
um the first BMP in the in the column uh
drives up his Hill and Isis Car Bomb
comes out we watch it Isis Car Bomb
comes out hits the hits the first BMP
blows into a million pieces
the column of tank stops for a minute
and then you see the the next tank in
line you see it's you see the smoke
coming from the engine as it revs up and
it just
drives around drives around the rubble
and keeps going that one that that that
tank another car bomb comes out hits it
boom blows it up the next tank in line
gets in line and just drives straight
around the rubble they don't stop for
the wounded they don't do anything
because everyone in there is dead and
they just keep going and I just remember
watching this thinking like wow like
that's that's like that was it was true
courage and um they were they're
actually a real pleasure to work with
the Iraqi soldiers I was I was shocked I
was not expecting that they were
wonderful yeah in 2006 that would likely
not have happened you know you would not
have seen continued pressure like that
and follow on death you'd see probably
one tank maybe in the second one but
there wasn't going to be the assault
would get stopped it was just not it's
just a different time and they weren't
there yet so that was good and maybe
that has to do with the fact that this
was them in charge and it was their
their deal you know and they're you know
we always would kind of think to
ourselves like why should we die for
your country and probably they might
have been thinking why should we die for
your operation right yeah so now this is
their operation maybe that has a little
something to do with it I don't know
um fast forward a little bit
I poked my head above the trench and
held my breath as a family of women and
children and inched across the
battlefield toward us no more than 200
meters away
dear Lord what are they doing bullets
air burst rockets and mortars impacted
at random in the open
field beyond the trench where the
Bradley and I sat with a dozen Iraqi
soldiers nazahin
the soul the Iraqi soldier said Bradley
what does he what does nazahin mean he
responded like he already knew I was
going to ask it's the word they used for
refugees who are no longer at home in
their country in their own country just
like the Karen people in Burma we
watched as small as the small family of
nazahin moved towards us they had
nowhere else to go Isis Fighters were
pouring an ungodly amount of fire into
the advancing Iraqi Army lines the
bullets and Rockets that didn't hit
their targets zipped into the vast sea
of green before us the entire field was
a giant bullet catcher we've got to do
something they're going to die
at this point you you have the phrase uh
discretion is the better part of valor
and that came from your what your
basketball days yeah talk us through
that so in this particular situation the
as the Iraqi Army gets they get into the
first houses in mosul to get into the
very first line of houses there's a
large open field and then houses as they
get in there the civilians who've been
who've been under Isis occupation for
three years at this point they're ready
to go they're ready to get the heck out
of there and so they start running they
have their families with them they start
running toward the Iraqis but the
battle's still happening and so as Isis
and the first line of Iraqi Army troops
are fighting and battling it out hard
and they're still suicide bombers going
off there's car bombs going off uh the
the Isis forces deeper into the city
maybe a kilometer into the city they've
got all their mortar tubes and
everything set up so they're dumping
mortars and covering the um you know
covering the front line Isis guys and in
the middle of all that you have
civilians running around trying to get
out of there and there's kids like women
and old women can kids and they're
trying to get across and so this is what
I saw these these civilians were running
and the Iraqi army or excuse me the
Iraqi term for um people who are what we
would call idps internally displaced
people people who are running from their
home but they're still in their country
um they call them nazahin so these are
civilians running away from the fighting
and they're running toward us
and so we
um we decided we had to go out and help
them they were struggling they were
walking very slowly they might hit a
mine we just we just don't know there
are bullets Landing everywhere the
longer they stay out there the higher
chance that one of these random bombs or
bullets is going to hit them and so
um myself and Bradley we we've run out
into the into the middle of the field to
basically grab their bags grab the kids
grab the old lady and like let's get to
let's get them to cover so the the
reason I talk about the you know the
discretion is the better part of valor
that was one that was one thing that my
basketball coach told me growing up and
I never I never forgot about it
because you know I would I would
constantly
um you know I was always very aggressive
when I would play but I wasn't I
wouldn't always play tactfully or attack
tactically um I would just be like as
long as I try hard right uh so in war
that'll get you killed that'll get you
killed in two seconds and uh you know as
we talk about in medical scenarios
particularly if a sniper shoots somebody
in their wound in the middle of the road
you don't go get them you just don't or
you put together some kind of plan to
suppress the to suppress the sniper or
something the last thing you do is run
out and try to save the person because
you're gonna get shot now too right so
you're not courageous I mean so I think
you are courageous for running out there
to get the guy but you're not gonna
you're not gonna survive you're not
effective at getting your job done and
if you don't get the job done are you
really courageous or you know like no
you just you now you just died for no
reason so you got to think through what
you're doing first and so
um in this particular case I was
thinking it's like man like do do we run
out there and potentially get ourselves
hurt
um or do we just kind of like watch and
see see what happens and I was like no
at this at some point you just got to
put all cards on table and uh like we're
just gonna go for it and we got to get
it done because if we don't like there's
a higher chance that they're going to
die our job here is to protect these
people and to help these people so you
got to risk it sometimes and so
sometimes you just and then you have you
have to think through the scenario like
I knew the statistical likelihood of
getting hit running out there was was
fairly low I mean there's still 120
millimeter mortars going off there's
still rocket fire and machine guns and
Air Force rockets and stuff going off
everywhere but I was like the chances
that we can get them to safety before
somebody gets killed is better than if
we just leave them there yes I'm at a
higher risk now but they're risk lowers
and that's that's my job my job is to
lower their risk even at my own uh even
to my own detriment to get them out of
that situation so Bradley and I ran out
there and uh helped get them into into
the trench and get them to safety okay
fast forward a little bit
Ranger one this is Ranger two we're
moving into the city I set into the
radio I sat shotgun in the front of the
armored ambulance as Dilo is that how do
you say hello Delo drove toward the edge
of the city Columns of smoke in the not
so distant Horizon as random air burst
explosions dot of the sky with small
spheres of black smoke they look like
explosions from World War II style
anti-aircraft guns we made our way to
the high point on a small hill and
started over the edge toward the city
um this is full on man
fast forward again like I'm reading
little highlights little just you could
basically throw a dart anywhere in this
book and you're gonna end up in freaking
May Mayhem combat
um
and if it sounds like if you're
listening to this and you're just like
oh wait wait what's happening yeah get
the book so you know what's happening
fast forward a little bit Kevin opened
fire with the machine gun from the
turret of the FBR Humvee like a
professional he suppressed the enemy
with short burst but things were quickly
going from bad to worse bullets now
began to smack the side of our Humvee
the Iraqi soldier with the head wound
huddled with us trapped and wounded but
calm I'm running up there Sky said no
sooner where the words out of his mouth
when another bullet slammed to the side
of the Humvee as it finally began its
Ascent up to the top of the hill Isis
was getting wise our time was up we're
going to the top of the hill too Justin
yelled taking charge Medics get in the
Humvee Skye was echoing Justin's command
when a bullet snapped past me clipping
Skye's leg he jumped back and began
frantically feeling for blood are you
hit Justin asked he reached and placed
his finger on a bullet hole in Sky's
cargo pocket Sky simultaneously did the
same thing but poked his finger into a
different Bullet Hole one bullet two
holes no blood I laughed in relief as
Sky let out a woop of Joy the bullet had
gone into his pocket and out the other
side the thought that Isis had just
about shot Skye infuriated me besides
Kevin's short burst of suppressive fire
in the general direction of the
invisible sniper no one was returning
fire and that made me even more heated
we were pinned down behind a Humvee and
about to get murdered if no one did
anything the enemy generally uncontested
from our position had the upper hand I
switched my AK-47 to Fire and stepped
out into the line of fire dumping half a
magazine into the building where the
shooting may have originated from it was
a small effort and probably did nothing
but I wanted them to know we'd fight
back stepping back into cover I saw Skye
hold up his iPhone beside a tiny scrape
with a bullet brushed his leg Skye had
come out unscathed but his iPhone had
not been so lucky while passing through
his pocket the bullet had also passed
through his phone sorry if I don't call
you babe
even now Sky could lighten the mood
moment good dude
fast forward again how many do you think
there are I asked looks like there could
be easily a thousand Justin replied we
stood at the age station and stared
across the open field at a trail of
civilians more than a mile long in the
distance they were survivors from the
city fleeing in the wake of the ninth
armored divisions Advance on our flank
the civilians poured out of the city
like a stream Meandering upwards towards
The High Ground in the distance the
stream disappeared up the road we had
Advanced down earlier in the day the
people carried carried everything they
could sharing the load men carried their
families valuables on their backs and in
both arms women carried the smaller
children children carried backpacks
scattered among the people were carts
wheelchairs and wheelbarrows containing
the second elderly wow that's a lot of
people David said as he joined us we
need to make sure we get that documented
de Lowe's phone fast forward delos phone
rang and he picked it up listening first
then speaking a few rapid sentences in
Kurdish delowe hung up the phone and
slammed it on the accelerator whoa whoa
I put my hand out to calm him down easy
buddy it's Shaheen the low said and
burst into tears I told him to wear body
armor what Shaheen is hit they shot him
okay buddy I need you to stay calm and
focused I said it's our drop to help
Shaheen now the low wiped the tears from
his eyes and frowned bitterly he was
trying to be strong good job Ephraim we
need you guys to send up help David's
voice came over the radio again why is
he not using call signs we're pinned
down in our Humvee and we have patients
on board send help now copy that David I
said I'll send help ASAP where are you I
could feel the Panic starting to build
up inside me but suppressed it as best I
could we're right over the hill where
the BMP got hit David said our Humvee is
too shot up to move we are receiving
effective fire and we have two wounded
civilians with us copy that David on the
way
we reached the top of the hill and I
jumped out of the ambulance immediately
seeing Shaheen laid out on a stretcher
white bandages wrapped around his waist
were quickly soaking through with blood
gut wound
I wanted to run over and talk to him but
the words from my platoon Chief in
Afghanistan rang through my head
prioritize and execute in order not to
be overcome by events Shaheen was in
good hands my priority was now to help
the rest of the team stuck on the other
side of the Hill Delo get over here I
screamed to load jump from Shaheen's
side and ran over to me I'm going with
Shaheen to the hospital he said no
you're not I need you here my tone was
calm as I could make it delowe clearly
shaken up was on the verge of the panic
attack I knew if I raised my voice at
him he might break listen buddy I need
your help the rest of the team is
trapped I pause for a moment to make
sure he was paying attention when a man
is terrified it is often wise to give
him a task where others depend on him
that may seem counterintuitive but
giving a terrified man an important
Mission allows him to look Beyond his
own needs and focus on others
this is where true courage comes from
the ability to put others before
yourself I need you to tell the Iraqis
that I need two Humvees with machine
guns ready to fight delowe looked into
my eyes a veil of calm and focus dropped
over him okay he nodded he sprinted off
toward the nearest bombed out building
which was being used by General Mustafa
as a command post the low came running
back into the street as gunfire and
explosions echoed in the background they
cannot send helmvs down there they will
get destroyed too to low set out of
brothel will send a tank to push them
out okay but make it quick I said
moments later the M1A1 Abrams battle
tank roared to life and drove off to
rescue our stranded team members and
from that tank is no good David said
over the radio we need Humvees with tow
ropes tell the Iraqis we have wounded
understood David I replied I'm trying to
get these guys moving
I was standing in the rubble of the HQ
building with General Mustafa I informed
the major that the tank couldn't do the
job and he rolled his eyes in dismay he
wanted to help David too but he had to
he also had to prioritize an execute I
was beside myself but tried not to lose
my temper time running out Justin the
former Marine who had been wounded three
times in combat and an Iraqi soldier
named haidar jumped into a Humvee
without orders and drove Straight Into
The Firestorm I watched in awe as their
vehicle sped over the crest of the hill
and down the other side toward David and
the rest of the team they were knowingly
driving into an active Killing Zone that
had decimated one Humvee already David
you've got help on the way I've said to
the radio a Humvee is coming
part of me felt ashamed I wished I I
wish I had the brains and courage to
think about myself and hadn't gotten
bogged down in the bureaucracy of the
battlefield there is nothing worse than
watching your fellow soldiers ride into
hell while you sit and watch from safety
and comfort it could have been better to
it would have been better to die with
them the minutes ticked by like hours as
I waited for a return call that another
Humvee had been disabled then I heard it
the screaming engine of a Humvee pulling
more than its fair share of weight I
stood up from the rubble and watched as
Justin and haidar's Humvee pulled the
damaged F the FBR Humvee with a tow
strap the two Humvees drove in a low
lying Speck of land off the side of the
road and everyone dismounted I jumped
from the middle I jumped from the rubble
and sprinted across the field to reach
them I could hear the commotion on the
other side of the Humvee as I ran around
to get to the other side of what and see
what was happening get an IV get an IV
hold her stop that bleeding get a
tourniquet on him now she's unconscious
where's my IV
a middle-aged man lay on the ground
groaning he'd been shot multiple times
in the legs next to him lay a little
girl maybe nine or ten years old in a
bright yellow dress she had undoubtedly
been she had undoubtedly picked her
favorite and prettiest dress for today
because today was supposed to be a
special day today after three years of
living under Isis rule she and her
father were supposed to finally be free
but instead of Freedom she had been shot
in the head by a nicest sniper
her yellow dress was stained with blood
as she lay unconscious but alive in a
Twisted heap of dirt
Sky slowly and silverhorn were already
working on the man and his daughter
there was nothing I could do to help so
I knelt down beside the little girl and
fixed her dress to cover her legs
I tried to hold back the tears but it
wasn't working
I took the little girl's limp hand in my
hand as tears began to run like River
like Rivers down my face
who could do such a thing to an innocent
little girl
this was the first time I'd ever broken
down and lost my composure in a combat
zone
what's wrong with me snap out of it I
quickly realized that I had not
emotionally or mentally prepared myself
for what could happen that day what I
thought would be a simple stroll through
the countryside that morning it turned
into some kind of hellish nightmare of
death and blood and I hadn't readied
myself once I realized this I it took me
a split second to suppress all the bad
things and pushed them into a dark
hidden corner of my soul where they
would fester and infect me until I dealt
with them
I could take care of that later right
now I had a job to do
while the team loaded the little girl
and her father into the back of an
ambulance
two elderly Iraqi women in black hijabs
were brought to us by a few Iraqi
Soldiers the woman hadn't been able to
make the long walk back to the rear
assembly area and they would need to be
transported David helped one of them
into the front seat of the ambulance
while I studied the other
before she climbed into the vehicle she
looked at me with tears in her eyes and
kissed me on the cheek
on she said
thank you
so this is
um like you know this is definitely one
of the
seemed like one of the sketchiest
situations in the book that you guys had
to deal with
um you know a downed Humvee you get the
call that you're taking effective Fire
And just so people that are civilians
understand what that means that means
you're taking fire that can kill you and
there's a reason that people tell you
you're taking effective fire as opposed
to we're taking fire or it's a hot LZ or
whatever the case may be when you say
you're taking effective fire it's a very
specific situation where we're getting
shot at and and the shooting that we're
receiving is effective and can kill us
and if you show up here it can kill you
too
um
as you look back on this
what what stands out
the the thing that stood out was
you know first of all was the the the
courage of the
um the team I was with so everyone's
volunteers no one's no one's paid to be
there
um so Dave is there another guy Uh Kevin
he's a former Green Beret he's there
volunteer not getting paid seven kids uh
Skye for marine Justin former Marine to
actually been wounded three times in in
Fallujah
um all volunteers no one's getting paid
everyone paid for their own flights
there and now we're
you know in this in this battle
um we're just supposed to be there as
Medics but we end up on the front line
and so
um in this particular situation the the
team was trapped in a Humvee because
they went to get a little girl had been
shot in the head and her and her father
had been shot multiple times and so the
Isis sniper was basically using
um the wounded people as bait they would
they would intentionally start gunning
down civilians uh one to to keep Phil to
keep uh civilians from running away
because the civilians are are sort of
their human shield right because there
is Coalition aircraft above head uh
overhead that will that will drop on
their buildings and so the Coalition
aircraft are going to do less of that if
they know their civilians around so
that's one reason why the other reason
too was um we it was explained to us
later that the the Isis guys are you
know extremists and so they saw anybody
who was leaving the Isis caliphate
anybody who was abandoning them these
people are now apostates which now
you're you are worse than a Jew or a
Christian or whatever in the Isis mine
because now you're a Muslim who's a
who's a fake Muslim now you're an
apostate now you're leaving that
caliphate to go to the to the you know
the the apostate Iraqi Army right so in
their mind they're completely Justified
with gunning down all of these civilians
and so that's what they that's what they
were doing and the team had gone over to
rescue this little girl and um her
father but the I but Isis had had hit
them so much had hit them so much with
uh with machine gun fire and I'm not
sure I believe there's also RPGs and
stuff had hit right next to the uh right
next to the Humvee and completely
disabled the Humvee so the team is
inside it's an armored Humvee uh the
team is inside
um with two with two wounded patients
um blood everywhere the the the little
girl she's bleeding out she was
because she had been shot in the head uh
that she was still alive and uh so
they're trapped in this Humvee five or
six guys bullets rattling off of
everything and then the only way they
could get out there is if they had
someone come down to help them and and
it ended up being uh Justin uh he he
dropped he jumped into Humvee went down
there ran out Under Fire
hooked up a toe strap and hopped back in
his Humvee bullets bouncing around him
the whole time jumps back and keep mine
he's been he's been hit three times
before he's like he's three purple
hearts he's he's he knows what he's
doing this isn't the the courage of the
naive this is the courage of someone who
knows full well the cost of what he
might be doing of what he is doing and
um he pulled those guys out
and
um so so you know when I when I saw the
patient so that that morning when this
when this big assault happened into
mosul
um we had kind of settled into this
relative pattern with the Iraqi Army
where they would go out and fight or
they'd push for you know maybe three
hours and then stop at lunch time and
then that was it
um and so the morning of the attack this
massive assault with a full Armored
Division into mosul we didn't know what
was happening we had no idea this was
going to happen we thought we were
getting up to go on just a normal you
know two-hour push we're just there on
on medical standby next thing we know
we're in the city civilians are getting
shot in the head and so in my mind I
realized that I hadn't I hadn't actually
um I I was my my mindset was too
lackadaisical my mindset was to
um yeah I know it wasn't it wasn't fully
comprehending like hey what I was about
to walk into I was just like okay we're
gonna go on another stroll and maybe
there's a patient maybe there's not and
it's just another day in the office uh
however it turned out to be exactly the
opposite and I realized that I hadn't
mentally prepared myself
um and that this was sort of taking me
by surprise and then I was like dude
what are you talking about like what you
need to be always mentally prepared how
are you not mentally prepared for this
and so that's why when I started crying
when this with this little girl and of
course it's heartbreaking and horrible
um but in a war zone you don't have time
for that nobody has time for that the
battle's still raging this is you know I
don't know noon or one o'clock on day
one
um this this went around the clock for
three days straight As the Iraqis
struggled to get a foothold in the city
of mosul so and they're gunning down
civilians this stuff is repeating we're
treating countless wounded thousands of
people are running out of the city
um we're still we're there with the
Iraqi armies like sleeping on the front
line with them counter attacks are
happening and um
so you don't have time to sit there and
have this sort of mental breakdown it's
okay it's okay to be heartbroken at the
at the side of a little girl injured
um and I think I think part of it too
was you know going back to the story
from from Afghanistan you know I was out
there two protect little girls right
like in the in the most literal sense
that's what I was that's what I was
there to do and now there's this little
girl bleeding out you know uh with two
bullet holes through her head and you
know just blood covering her bright
yellow dress and
um
so that was a moment where I had to I
had to snap out of it and just say hey
man you're no good to anybody if you
don't get yourself under control and it
was just one of those momentary things
and then from that point forward I saw
much worse things much much much much
much much worse things what I saw that
day and I never lost my composure again
because I was like okay now I'm mentally
prepared now I understand what I'm
getting into here and I just had to flip
that switch
and you still had this uh Iraqi woman
saying thank you it's like they knew
what the hell you guys were doing and
what you're going through to try and
help them uh you know I'll occasionally
talk to people that you know they'll
give me the
the talk about how we were Invaders and
all this stuff and it's like no I mean
it's the same thing in ramadi the
civilians in ramadi absolutely 100
wanted us there they they did not want
the insurgents they didn't want uh
Al-Qaeda running their City the al-Qaeda
was raping and torturing the the
civilians there they wanted them killed
they wanted them out of their City they
wanted them dead uh and so
you know clearly the same thing going on
here
um just just you know you mentioning
that she's like hey
you know thank you
um
yeah powerful
you know what's interesting is as I was
like making notes for the book I'm going
from like chapter to chapter to chapter
and I was trying to use the dates as
like a reference but it's like so many
chapters it's the same day like this is
May 4th 2017. this is like the next
chapter it's this past like four
chapters were all May 4th 2017 like it's
just chapter after chapter after chapter
of this freaking Mayhem going on
um going forward a little bit sitting
there sporadic bursts of muffled gunfire
and the occasional explosion still
echoing from somewhere in the distance I
realized I'd lost any any and all
Illusions about the adventure of War
the initial flurry of action had passed
the adrenaline was gone and all that was
left was a harsh bloody and exhausting
reality until today War had been nothing
to me but an object of excitement sure
there have been fear and danger but I'd
always been on the side that won without
taking any serious hits War had been a
chance to prove my manliness and courage
it was a game to be played but today
while I helped wrapped a bandage that
held a soldier's guts in the illusion of
that game began to fade while I wept and
held an unconscious girl little girl's
limp hand that illusion was erased
Forever War was real
and it can only truly be described as
hell
so there's a little uh
I guess
mental transition that you make as well
yeah because one of the one of the
things you know from my from my time in
the teams we did that deployment to to
Afghanistan the we didn't take any we
didn't take any hits
um our sister platoon had one at the EOD
guy got around through his hand and that
was it during that entire time and we
had been in Fairly heavy combat like
fairly heavy close quarter combat but we
were so good and we had so much air
support that we never took any
casualties no one even got wounded it
was we were you know got basically got
off completely scot-free and killed a
lot of Taliban and it was great so it
was this War to me was it was it was
this uh
yeah it was this Grand Adventure to to
an extent and I didn't realize how much
of a grand Adventure I thought that I
had sort of internalized it to be and
the only you know horrific uh sort of
situation had been that situation where
I almost had to kill the little girls
right but we didn't see the mass death
and Carnage like I was seeing I didn't
see civilians shot in the back of the
head I didn't I wasn't putting soldiers
guts back into their body and wrapping
them and sending them off before going
to the next patient and this was now on
this day one of our time in mosul which
would which went for 30 straight days
um before I ended up getting shot
um was it was it was this non-stop just
insane violence and um yeah so it was a
very very different experience very big
mental shift that I that I had to go
through
um very very quickly uh in that in that
day did you uh start thinking you might
die
yeah absolutely
um and then you know fast forwarding
really far like the day that I did get
the day that I did end up getting shot I
um I knew I knew I knew I was like I've
got I think about like 10 10 or 12 days
left in the city I was like I don't know
if I'm gonna die or not because like I
know I'm not making it out of here
without without getting hit I'm going to
get wounded or I'm gonna die
um and it was that certainty I've heard
about guys in Vietnam who who talked
about that after extended combat they
knew guys would know like hey man like
I'm gonna die tomorrow on the mission or
like hey man I'm not going to make it
through this and like they're not being
pessimistic they're just like hey man I
I just know and um I knew that later on
I was like I know I'm going to get hit I
don't know if it's death or not but this
is going to happen and that was that was
very strange that was a very very
strange experience as well later on
um as as the the intensity of the combat
increased and as the
prolonged exposure to the combat uh
increase because keep in mind when
you're when you're done with the day you
don't go back to your fob you know you
know after after you're done with two or
three days you're not going back to your
fob and air conditioning and all right
guys let's debriefing like no no you're
sleeping in the rubble you're smelling
the rotting corpses of civilians and
Isis you're like that that's where you
live you're living like you're under
constant threat of counter-attack
there's mines everywhere and so there is
no break there is no going home there is
no going to the rear really you're just
in it and this is your life now until
it's done
yeah I was wondering when you reached
that point like um talking to a bunch of
guys and guys on this podcast and the
one that stands out in my mind right now
is a guy named Dean Ladd who is a marine
to World War II did the Pacific Campaign
and he was going into Tarawa and you
know like they're looking at the Battle
plan for Tarawa and
they'd already he'd already been on two
campaigns I mean he'd already hit like I
think one two maybe even three other
islands like he knew what the deal was
he knew what they were going to do and
you know I said like did you were you
scared and he's like no it's gonna
happen to somebody else so there's that
attitude of like which I definitely know
I had for a long time which is like like
nothing's gonna happen to me like it
might happen to someone else
um and then you make a transition where
it's like oh no this 100 can be me and
you got to be ready for that and then
you know I I
again not a fatalistic thing but like in
ramadi
I
didn't necessarily think I was gonna get
wounded or killed but
you are just running the numbers in your
head and the odds and you know every
time you leave the wire every time the
guys leave the wire there's
you just kind of have to
run the odds even if you're
subconsciously doing it you know that's
what gives you the knot in your stomach
is every day it's like
is today going to be an IED is today
going to be random machine gun fire
um an enemy sniper like what is it going
to be today and it's that's just what
that's just the way it's going to be you
know so that that sort of acceptance and
that's what I was thinking about with
you because you know in reading the book
I knew see there's no there's no going
back to a fob there's not even any
getting out of this thing like you're
there which is also an interesting
Dynamic is that actually that's not true
like you guys could leave I mean
essentially if you could get off the
front line you're like hey I'm done
you're a volunteer there yeah all the
they could say thank you and you could
leave
um which is an interesting dynamic as
well it's something that that uh
in that book
or who's the guy that made Restrepo
um the author you know what I'm talking
about he made Restrepo the movie
yeah I've I've seen
yeah yeah the famous freaking author
sorry I was thinking of Ernst younger
who wrote you know storm of Steel so I
got a little bit confused but Sebastian
younger what he writes is and it's it's
a really cool thing it's a really humble
thing for him to say he's like hey I
experienced a lot in I'm paraphrasing
hey I experienced a lot I was a reporter
if I wanted to leave I could leave these
young army soldiers they weren't they
didn't have that opportunity so
you know that's kind of a little bit of
what you had going on except for that
you guys were a you guys had formed a
bond that leaving would have been
unacceptable yeah so you may not have
been uh literally
mandated to stay but your you know your
own very principles mandated that you
stay and finish the job absolutely and
there was there were no other Medics
that was one thing and you talked about
two you know in ramadi there's you know
like what's going to happen today what
could happen today right what I and I
experienced that as well in Afghanistan
but in this situation it was it wasn't
like it wasn't like oh what's gonna
happen today it's like who's gonna die
today because with the Iraqi group that
we're with there's a 100 chance there's
a 100 chance that somebody is going to
die that day you just don't know who it
is and it might be you it might be the
other guy but there is every every
single day you are seeing someone dead
every single day you're seeing somebody
horribly wounded you're seeing both of
those every single day for weeks on end
and
um so the Iraqi soldiers they know this
too this isn't this isn't like what if
this is like this is going to happen one
of us in this group of 30 is going to be
dead today yeah that's you know in
ramadi was about there would there would
be wounded or killed every day and
what's weird is and this is not a this
is a sad thing to say we counted
Americans like we didn't really like
when Iraqis got killed and wounded it
was almost like they didn't go in our
numbers like I've and matter of fact
it's sad to say this I I rarely talk
about that fact I rarely talk about the
fact that like we always talk about the
Americans that were killed in ramadi we
never talk about the Iraqis because if
we did it'd be a whole different number
yeah
um
so yeah it was like every day and you
know every day guys are getting wounded
and killed and that's why you're like
guys are going out there's a chance
there's and it's not a small chance
either
um you know there was seven there's a
two mile road maybe two and a half mile
road that that went down the center of
Armani and it it had seven to ten IEDs
on it a day and so like you're and guess
where the road that you leave base is
that road exactly like it's
so that that
builds up
um that builds up and you're in an even
more extreme example because this is you
know dozens of people getting wounded or
killed every day you know uh and you're
in the absolute midst of it so it's it's
an exponentially more intense scenario
that you're in
yeah and and also at one point too
um I think I don't know I don't remember
how far it was into the into the battle
I ended up getting sick as well
um but
um I started feeling like this this like
level of combat stress I'd never felt
before a lot of it was just because I
couldn't sleep I couldn't set I couldn't
reset my brain every night and so it got
to the point I think a week or two into
this uh into the end of the battle that
my hands started shaking the whole like
uh you know Saving Private Ryan
handshake you know where the um Tom
Hanks character's hand was shaking that
was that was happening to me and I was
like what is what is happening and and I
mentally I felt fine but my my body and
my brain was like no dude no you're not
and like you're starting to like break
down and so I started having shaking
hands and and things like that and
finally I was actually I actually did I
was like hey I'm pulling back for a few
days I slept came right back and was it
was fine going forward but um yeah it
was just shocking that's a whole nother
conversation about about sleep and the
importance of sleep but
um yeah that's what this was leading up
to is just full-on like your body is
starting to shut down from the uh from
the from the constant stress all day all
night patients coming in all day all
night you're getting woke up at two
o'clock in the morning to go
put some you know uh you know try to
help some guy who's been shot in the
head so that's that's your dream it's
not it's not a nightmare you're waking
up at two o'clock in the morning with
somebody screaming at you to try to help
them and you're and you you know you're
trying to patch them up but you don't
really know what to do or they're
already dead and stuff like that so it's
yeah that was that was life I mean this
was the definitely I mean I guess
Ukraine is going to come back with some
more intense combat but this is the most
intense Urban combat since World War II
for sure yeah yeah uh this is kind of
continuing with the same thought that
you were that I just kind of went from
the book it says the city sat quiet
black and gray Columns of smoke Rose at
random intervals as fires slowly burned
themselves out I looked out onto it all
listening to the breeze as it whistled
and howled through the bullet holes and
leaky windows and empty rooms of another
abandoned home in the city beneath me I
could see entire houses laid to waste in
rubbled heaps of Ruin and debris I
wonder if this house is next would I die
quickly and painlessly if it collapsed
on me I knew there were dozens maybe
even hundreds of people buried alive
under the rubble in the streets beneath
me I didn't want to die that way slowly
and pin down that thought made me sick
what am I doing here
now that the desire for Action was gone
all I had left was my desire to help but
was that enough and was I willing to die
for it no matter what good I did here I
knew there would just be another War we
all knew the Kurds and Iraqis would go
at it as soon as Isis Was Defeated so
what's the point
those are some deep questions to ask
while you're sitting in a freaking
reveled out sitting way to die yeah yeah
absolutely and you know um for me my my
thought process with
um
for my time in the military to
Everything I Do even up to down in the
past and up to today for me I'm not I'm
not an ash I'm not an action junkie I'm
very much driven by
um the desire to to help and so I'm
constantly questioning do I need to be
here do I not need to be here and that's
one thing that's um that I'm actually
grateful for is that I'm not an action
junkie so the desire to get into combat
the desire to sort of get after it is is
not uh it's not a driving force because
I don't need the adventure anymore to me
it's no longer an adventure you know my
my interpreter just a few months ago
like one of my best friends in this
world you know I just had to drag his
body as he was slowly dying off the
battlefield for hours and hours and
hours and hours uh that was you know
right before getting overrun by the
enemy this was just a few months ago in
my current job and
um you know so like for me it's not it's
not an adventure so I I'm constantly
asking like am I doing this for the
right reasons am I am I does does what
I'm is what I'm doing as effective is it
as effective as possible is it
um is it going to have a long-term
impact is it is it worth dying for
ultimately at the end of the day
um especially you know continuing with
the work I do now it's like is this
worth dying for and you have to ask
yourself that every time you make a make
a decision
yeah interestingly I just did an event
and um an ER doctor asked me a question
and the question was basically I think
he was knee our doctor
but are you some kind of a doctor and he
was basically saying like hey I'm doing
the best I can but I can't help everyone
and I can't treat enough people and I
can't save them all
almost gave me like a what what am I
doing type question and again I
apologize
um for not being able to repeat the
question perfectly but but the but the
answer that I gave him
is it was and it was in front of a crowd
of people but I was like hey you help
one person like if you help one person
as a doctor
or an EMT or a firefighter or a police
officer or a person in the military or a
lifeguard or a school teacher or a human
being in life if you help one person
if you help one person
that's a win
and if you focus on the people that the
millions and millions of people that are
in terrible situations that you can't
help if that's where you focus your
energy I mean don't do anything right
just just don't do anything just go
freaking uh
you know drink a beer and watch Netflix
I guess and be a loser
um but if you help one person you won so
you know clearly that's a something that
you're that
I would guess is your driving force to
to be you know you can look at the world
and see all the people that are in
terrible situations throughout the world
you can't you know you can't help them
all you can help one of them you can
help four of them you know you can help
seven of them in this case you helped
you you help one woman get off the
battlefield and she's never gonna forget
that she's gonna be thankful like you
did your job
yeah absolutely and I think I think when
it comes to War as well we as a society
we're always everybody's looking to to
fight the last war like but this will be
the war to end all wars right and we're
constantly looking for the the final war
that'll end it all
um you know and we'll finally have peace
right and and and so you know I I would
often ask myself that question like when
when in Afghanistan or even Iraq or
whatever you know it's like at some
point this war is going to end right and
but it's the war is going to continue on
so I even fight it right it's like uh so
you have to ask yourself that but the
basically the answer I came up for for
myself was you don't go to war to end
all war you go to war to purchase a
limited amount of freedom for a limited
amount of people for a limited amount of
time and then you got to do it again and
if not you someone else has to go do it
again and again and again and that's
just how it works
um
the one of the founding fathers said
something along the lines of the tree of
Liberty must be watered with the blood
of uh tyrants and Patriots every once in
a while right from from time to time and
that's just the simple reality of it
this is an ongoing thing you have to do
to maintain so that doctor yeah man you
can save that one patient uh and then
the next day you're gonna save another
patient and it while it might seem
futile think about it this way uh you
get hungry today you're gonna eat a
sandwich
well why eat the sandwich when you're
just going to get hungry later right
well you gotta you gotta sustain you
gotta keep the the mission has to keep
going like life life goes on life
continues and so you do what you can
yeah
going back to the book bullets slammed
into the building just above our heads
they're gonna start flanking us any
second I was trying to hide the panic in
my voice but it clearly wasn't working
the others started to stared with Hollow
looks on their faces ready for a fight
all we could do is wait hey where are
they going Justin asked as he pointed to
the rear he already knew the answer but
the site was so difficult to comprehend
that it was worth wondering out loud
spanning the field we had crossed
earlier that day were the tail lights of
a dozen are Iraqi Army Humvees and half
as many bmps I wanted to throw up
multiple Iraqi army vehicles with their
machine guns guns ammo soldiers were
retreating
the enemy fire doubled bullets began to
Ricochet off the power lines connected
the off the power lines connected to our
house and spin off into unpredictable
arcs knowing if Isis reached us they'd
be coming from our direct front I
leveled my rifle in my field of fire at
the flimsy front gate I could already
see into the future and knew exactly
what was going to happen there is no
mystery in war dude if the Iraqis are
leaving we need to leave too we're going
to get flanked and then assaulted and we
all know how that's going to turn out I
said keep my rifle pointed at the gate
less than 10 seconds later after the
words were out of my mouth bullets began
to snap and crack from our Left Flank I
was surprised at how right I had been
but outwardly I acted confident see
someone needs to go talk to David now
Kevin's already on it Justin said from
behind me we definitely need to leave
but I know David he loves this stuff and
there's no way he'll agree to it
Justin's tone was not whiny but matter
of fact I shook my head in frustration
and glanced over my shoulder I heard
someone run up behind us hey guys Kevin
stood at the gate
David says we're staying
an RPG hit the Second Story the building
next door less than 20 feet from my head
it struck on the wall exactly where I'd
taken my shot earlier the explosion
threw me to the ground and temporarily
blinded me I cringed while I tried to
Blink away the bright flash waiting to
get peppered with shrapnel my ears were
ringing as I stood up looking for the
rest of the guys who were also emerging
from cover guys I'm willing to die
tonight I said too deaf to hear my own
voice above the ringing but I don't want
to die for nothing just because the
Iraqis don't want to fight anger welled
up inside me and I couldn't tell if I
was shaking from Rage or from the blast
I wasn't sure if I was angrier at the
Iraqis for running away or at David for
not agreeing to leave boom Another RPG
flashed in the same spot next door and
sent me to my knees ears ringing I stood
up and shifted over to guard the front
gate from a different angle that would
Shield me from the shrapnel for me once
shame on you fool me twice
you know the deal okay I'll try again
Kevin turned his red tactical light on
to see his feet as he quickly walked
back to the armored ambulance he emerged
a few minutes later with David what's
going on fellas David asked as if
everything was normal for a moment
everyone was silent
David we're gonna get overrun they've
gotten to honor to our flank and hit us
with multiple RPGs I said and then
repeated what I said earlier I'm willing
to die fighting tonight but I don't want
to die because all the Iraqis ran away
everyone else nodded in agreement
well David said folding his arms this is
what the free Burma Rangers do he
pointed over to the five Iraqi soldiers
who sat terrified in the dark we're not
here to win the war for Iraq we're here
simply to stand with them the rest of
the Iraqi Army has left us here with no
support and no Medics no matter how bad
it gets we do not run if there's anyone
left behind that's part of the Creed of
the free Burma Rangers he paused a few
moments tracers continued to light up
the sky and snap just feet above our
heads despite the noise and danger David
spoke clearly and calmly
it's too late for us to cross over no
man's land tonight to safety but in the
morning if anyone wants to leave they
can go no one has to be here
David no one's saying that we don't want
to help these people we just don't want
to be foolish and waste our lives for
nothing Justin said I don't want to die
either David said calmly
and you have to remember that neither do
the Iraqis trust me they don't want to
die their tactics and decisions are
strange to us but that's just the way
they fight the general and his Entourage
never sleep on the front line them
leaving night at night is nothing new
the bottom line is this we will not be
led by fear or comfort and we will
always stand with the people who
everyone else has written off we are not
leaving these soldiers
I nodded my head feeling ashamed and
cowardly our mission was to stand with
these handful of Iraqi soldiers even if
it meant our deaths am I really willing
to do that though I thought about that
for a moment is it worth having my life
snuffed out at age 24 is saving these
guys really worth my the pain my parents
will feel if I die is it worth all the
help I could have given to other people
if I had lived normally I would have
taken a sign of caution and lived to
fight another day but there are moments
in life when you must simply choose
courage and love over fear and
selfishness even though it makes little
sense when added up heroes are only born
when we rise above ourselves and choose
to lay down our lives for the good of
someone else
there's no math in that
the gunfire and RPGs continued until
well after dark and we remained braced
for an enemy assault but eventually the
Isis fire petered out and the city
became relatively quiet they must have
decided a frontal assault wasn't worth
it
we were relieved at their lack of
initiative to assault us
it probably saved Our Lives
and you go on to say that they actually
had left you weren't as abandoned as you
thought you were you going to explain
that
um
but this you also say this
I resigned myself to being willing to
Die For The Liberation of this city it
wasn't a crude or somber thing in my
heart I decided I would no longer be
just an American spectator and helper I
was now in Iraqi I adopted these as
these people as my people they were my
family now I would give my life for them
I'll stay I'll die with these guys in
that quiet moment in my soul
I knew
and so one of the things you mentioned
earlier like all these chapters this is
all day one yeah this is all day one of
30. and I only read a little tiny briefs
points of it there's freaking dozens of
pages about this stuff yeah so this was
my first time in war without without the
Amer well you know this this trip was my
first time in war without the American
Military and nobody's telling me to be
there no one's telling anybody to be
there and so you have this certain level
of soul searching and things that you
have to go through
um to justify why you're there and you
have to really really get very specific
in your own head why am I doing this why
am I here and do you have to answer
those questions and if you don't answer
those questions you're not going to last
long and so
um this was this was actually a very
good experience for me at the time as
well because it led into you know what
what it is that I do now with stronghold
rescue and relief and we have that same
policy that that I learned from from
Dave it's like we're not we're not
leaving these people and it's difficult
to understand
um I didn't fully accept that or
understand that until I was in the until
I was in the in this situation it had it
was so literally forced with this with
that with that decision do I leave or do
I stay right
um but it's one of those it's one of
those things where uh you have to you
have to decide uh what it is that
matters to you and you also have to you
have to shift your brain and like you
can't you can't just sit there and go
well I'm an American this isn't my fight
because I I would hear I hear stuff like
that all the time like oh that's that's
not your fight you're an American why
are you helping in you know Burma why
are you helping in any other place like
why are you why'd you go to Ukraine like
why'd you do this why why would you go
to that you're not you're not you're not
from those countries it's like yeah but
I'm human and they're human so therefore
those are my brothers and sisters those
little those little kids are my nieces
and nephews why is it why why would I
not go help them like what are you
talking about that's the warrior create
I'm gonna I'm gonna help anybody who
needs my help
um especially the people who no one else
is going to help and this was one of
those moments where that was solidified
in my heart you can sit there and say
all day I'm a warrior I'm a defender of
people I'm a this I'm a that I'm a seal
are you in your heart
um until until you're getting thrown to
the ground by RPGs you know slamming
into the ground around you and into the
buildings around you as until Isis is
flanking you in the enemy and your your
allies are running away
you know are you gonna stand are you
gonna run and it's a it's a it's a tough
decision it's a tough decision and
there's no wrong answer if you do run
away like that's fine that's you're not
you're not an evil coward horrible
person uh that's a sensible thing to do
but if you want to call yourself a
warrior hey guess what this is what war
is and like it has a meaning War means
death war means sacrifice War means you
know this could end very very badly for
you you could get burned alive you could
get paralyzed you could have your face
shot off you can watch you're gonna
watch your friends die you're gonna
watch people you know die and
you want to know what two years from now
three years from now 100 years from now
No One's Gonna Know No One's Gonna care
but are you gonna do the right thing in
that moment yes or no binary yes or no
black and white which which one is it
make a choice right now
and when you're forced to make those
decisions
um you're forced to see who you really
are and see what you really believe
because you can say whatever he wants on
paper but as you know until the chips
are down you don't really know
I think that this um
where do you where do you put when you
pull the thread on this
um passion to help other people where do
where does it land where does that
thread lead to
where does it lead to or where does it
come from where does it come from I
guess
um
honestly what if I really look back at
it I think it comes
um I think it comes from my time as a
kid going into the inner cities and
um seeing uh you know like that we call
the north side north side of Milwaukee
it's a basically all black area and I
think that's where it came from because
I remember as a kid going in and seeing
these neighborhoods decimated by drugs
and crime and bad policy and and all of
that and realizing wow people don't have
it like I have it and uh having and my
parents instilling the desire of me to
serve my mother through
um you know through the church that was
where obviously I was there as a church
ministry my father serving
um he went to he went to Iraq you know
he was in he was in mosul flying or you
know flew aircraft into mosul and stuff
with uh you know the Air Force so
service and thinking of others was
something my parents instilled in me but
I also had the opportunity to see it at
a very young age and see
hey man like you you need to go do
something you don't have to do
everything but you can do you can do
something
fast forward a little bit
um you get to a point where uh after
that night when you guys do like make a
stand it leaves an impact on the Iraqi
Army right they saw that you guys were
there to help and that you weren't going
to run away and that's a really powerful
thing and this is something you know um
um
you know even in ramadi working with the
Iraqi soldiers
there was a similar thing of like
some of the theory was well don't just
train with them and then have them go do
the operations and it seems good in
theory because why would you again I
already said this why would you risk
Americans to go out and do an operation
or you just send the Iraqis out there
and it's it's the same thing that you
talk about in the book is like you gotta
they gotta see that you mean what you
say and that you are with like with them
not just in word but indeed like we will
be out there with you we will take
casualties with you and we are here to
support and and help you
rid the town we're in this rid the city
of these of these uh terrorists and
insurgents and Evil just evil sub-humans
um there's a there's a statement I don't
remember where I heard this I heard
somewhere growing up it was uh people
don't care how much you know until they
know how much you care and it's the
simple reality is you could have someone
give you the best advice of your life in
front of you if you know that they don't
care about you if you know that they
don't give a damn
it's like you you don't take it to heart
you don't you don't really you don't
really hear it it just goes in in one
ear and out the other so letting people
know hey man I care hey man I've been
there hey I'm I'm with you in this and
and also too let's how we run however I
run my organization now stronghold like
we're in the fight with you we're not
there to fight but yeah we'll we will
protect you we will protect ourselves
and um we're getting ordered right next
to you we're getting shot at right next
to you uh except we can mentor you
um in the field we're going to train you
how to do this medical stuff and we're
going to be there
looking over your shoulder as you're
putting a tourniquet on an actual
wounded soldier as as bullets are flying
and that's that's what we do yeah
mortars don't they don't discriminate
they don't they don't care they don't
care
uh you got a little tank versus sniper
situation which is nice I like to read
about that
this is something we were in big support
of in ramadi is you know like people
would talk about anti-sniper like sniper
versus sniper and all this stuff and are
our chosen uh methodology was or you
they have a sniper cool we have a tank
exactly the Sun the Tank's not there
exactly
um
you know you you talk about this and
this is something that you know we got
to see on the news a little bit back
here you know you say it seemed the day
would never end as hundreds of civilians
flowed through our lines gruesome
casualties poured in both military and
civilian
and then fast forward here as the day
turned to night the stream of wounded
finally stopped or slowed down
um
fast forward a little bit
um this is now to May 6th so this is a
lot has happened in two days bro I need
water I sat up in my sweat soaked
makeshift bed and scratched at the fresh
mosquito welts peppering my face my bone
dry tongue tried to make sense of the
Moss coating my teeth day three
in the early Dawn light I could make out
a few Iraqi soldiers on their bed rolls
rifles sweaty Arms Reach away someone's
talk was walking past me now bits of
glass and concrete crunching beneath
their boots despite a poor night's sleep
the dehydration cramp in my side and the
thudding artillery in the distance I was
in a cheerful mood though we didn't have
many details Dr Osama was able to get
word to us that our previous report on
Shaheen had been false and again this is
all like part of the plot of the story
that I didn't read the whole thing and
it's uh integral part of the story and
and incredible part of the story he was
in the hospital but still alive like the
rest of the team I now felt no
Indescribable sense of relief no matter
what happens today Alicia he made it you
guys have gotten a report that this guy
this heroic guy had died yeah and now
you're getting you've been shot through
the stomach on day one and yeah we
thought he died now he was alive
um I laced up my boots nearly gagging
from the stench I surely sure wish I
brought my hygiene kit and a pair of
extra socks grabbed my rifle and went
outside the courtyard where soft voices
of nazahin could be heard making their
way past the Aid Station and you get
into
just more there's more fighting there's
more life-saving there's there's more
work that you guys are doing more risk
that you're taking to save innocent
people and helpless people I mean just a
a phenomenal story
um
fast forwarding this is something that
you kind of mentioned uh you mentioned
already when you got sick
um this morning I woke up really sick
fever racked my body so you go through
that and and
take time until that that fever breaks
but
what's interesting is even even as
that's happening you feel like guilty
that you're leaving and you just want to
get back there which is
powerful
um and this is when you say I I wrestled
internally and tried to deny it but I
knew deep down inside the constant
sickness sleep deprivation hunger thirst
Terror and death were taking their toll
on me when either the Mind Body or
spirit is damaged the other two
faculties rise to the occasion and
provide strength to heal and push
through a person running a marathon
overcomes the pain in their body by
focusing on positive thoughts with their
mind and using their Spirit to remember
why they're putting themselves through
such a painful trial however when two of
the faculties are damaged it becomes
exponentially harder to push through
imagine a marathon runner whose body is
in pain 10 miles into the run and they
also can't remember why they're putting
themselves through this painful ordeal
they will most likely give up if all
three parts of a person The Body Mind
and Spirit are damaged it's only a
matter of time before that person breaks
I was at my breaking point I could feel
it mind body and spirit were shattered
the uncontrollable shaking in my hands
was an undeniable indication of that the
sickness and sleep deprivation had
destroyed my body and mind the screams
of the dying especially the children had
drained the life from my spirit I was on
the verge of a total breakdown
David I need to go back to erbil for a
couple of days he turned and looked at
me confused why what's the matter he
asked David is a machine he's a robot
that feels no pain never gets tired and
is always smiling he has an iron will as
an easily the toughest person I've ever
met David is a textbook extrovert
revitalized and recharged by people in
action and noise I'm a textbook
introvert give me a few hours or even
days alone and I'll be ready to conquer
the world I understood David couldn't
understand and his look of astonishment
made me laugh I'm still sick and it's
only getting worse I replied he nodded a
bit I'll I just need a few nights to
sleep and a little mental break I'll
come back in a couple days good as new
the rest of the day was quiet I prepped
my bags and asked anybody if they needed
me
um
so you go to erbil
after three days of rest and eating
small amounts of food my body finally
began to heal so I geared up to go back
into the field with the next Supply in a
few days then came the worst possible
news
Shaheen was dead
at first we thought it might be another
case of false information Bradley called
Muhammad Ahmed who was at the same
hospital as Shaheen on the phone we
heard Ahmed weeping as he spoke to us in
his broken English he told us that
Shaheen had died suddenly from an
infection in his wound
and you end up kind of doing the Keiko
Duty right the like the casualty
um notification not the notification but
you go and attend the funeral meet the
family
um
that had to be a little bit
that had to be
um what's that word surreal yeah yeah it
was it was very surreal so Shaheen was a
yazidi so he wasn't Kurdish he wasn't
Iraqi he was easy so he was one of the
tribes that uh was
um completely decimated by Isis Isis
particularly targeted yazidis
um and so when I when I went to when I
went to the funeral one of the one of
the
um cultural things that they do and I'm
gonna get this a little bit wrong but
basically the the women from the tribe
the mother and the sisters and stuff
they go into a tent in the wilderness
and they sit there and they scream and
cry for several days and we walked in to
to see this so the women's mourn
separately than the men and so we drove
up in a vehicle myself and a couple
other people and
um we uh we went in there to to talk to
the family talk to the mother and
because I'd been there I'd seen I'd seen
him get uh I didn't see him get shot but
I've been there when he was you know
when he was injured and I was there for
the whole situation and so talked with
the mom
and um I don't remember how that
conversation went just sort of
formalities and you threw an interpreter
and it's and it's tough but this it was
it was like taking a step back a
thousand years women and you know as uh
like Middle Eastern uh Garb standing in
a tent in the middle of the desert
screaming and wailing
and it was like you said very surreal
um and so we went and talked with the
mom and then we went to the the funeral
for the men where the men were the men
of the tribe were and we went there met
the father and brothers and such
um and then yeah then it was back out to
the back out to the front
back out to the front the city grew
eerily quiet as we stood guard at the
nearest intersection to the house
roasting in the afternoon heat I can't
believe I'm on the front line of a
suicide bomber watch in Iraq right now
completely exposed both Skye and I
understood that we would be maimed or
killed of a suicide bomber ever did show
up so you're basically guarding an
intersection but that was part of the
risk
within the FBR wolf pack David was the
alpha and sky and I were Fighters it was
our job to defend the women and children
even if it cost us our lives we knew our
job and we accepted it within minutes a
man appeared walking down the street
toward us
I pulled out my scope and eyed the man
in the distance
The Mirage from the heat made it
impossible to tell if the man had
anything hidden under his clothing as he
approached a few more men appeared and
walked toward us I readied my rifle and
aimed down the street here we go I said
to Skye as we waited for the man to get
closer did you ever have to do stuff
like this when you were in the Marines I
asked oh yeah all the time you hell no
we had Marines for that sort of thing I
joked seals are too valuable for this
grunt work
you should have stayed in the Navy man
Sky laughed you could be hanging out on
the beach in San Diego right now making
good money and living that seal rock
star life not having to do anything
except shoot guns and train you're the
idiot good point I grinned my finger now
resting on the AK-47s trigger
the men were getting closer and their
gaze was fixed directly on us but in all
seriousness I said I'd rather get blown
up right here right now helping these
people than living in safety and comfort
back in San Diego
this is where the war is so this is
where I belong same said Skye we can't
stand by and do nothing Isis is our
generation's Nazis
um
so to expound on that a little bit the
the reason we're regarding that
intersection was because there was
reports that uh two suicide bombers were
going to come hit our building where we
were doing food distributions and
um at that point Dave had his family out
there like his kids
um uh yeah like high school and like
Middle School age kids there with him
and his wife and
um so they're there at the house so
they're on the center of the house
hiding and so we're waiting and all the
Iraqi armies we all uh the Iraqi army
soldiers well spread out looking you
know waiting for the suicide bomber well
as we were standing there
um you know we were like all right looks
like there's no suicide bomber we
started making our way back to the house
behind us maybe 50 meters behind us the
entire time they were in Iraq or
assuming Isis fighter had climbed onto
the buildings and was looking down at us
and looking he was trying to get closer
to shoot down into the courtyard of the
building where we had been doing food
distributions and so as we walked back
to the building so 50 meters away he
there's an Isis fighter right up there
he starts dumping around trying to shoot
us but they're going over our head and
they're slamming into the into the
Humvee as we as we're walking right past
it and then everyone else starts
returning fire and ultimately I think
they I don't know if they ended up
finding the guy and killing him or not
but we get into this point blank
shootout with this Isis guy who's on The
High Ground you know now at this point
10 yards away just he's just right there
in the next building just shooting down
at us and so the threat was real there
was a coordinated effort and they did
that rocking Army did find a guy with a
suicide bomb on him uh he didn't
detonate it and they captured him
um so there were two guys coming to
coming to coming to hit the building and
so yeah this is just um again just
volunteer just volunteer humanitarian
work
um and uh you know finding yourself in
these crazy crazy situations just so
everyone knows there is humanitarian
work that you can get into where you
won't be exposed to uh High Ground Isis
with AKs yes yes
fast forward a little bit
uh the Humvees packed with dead and
wounded civilians began pouring into the
Aid Station one after the other
what happened small groups of civilians
coming from Isis held territory began to
trickle in from up the street despite
their escape from Isis they were absent
of Joy there was no waving or smiling to
indicate Liberation they just walked
past with empty Hollow eyes women sobbed
and hung their shoulders while men
mumbled to themselves their heads down
we handed out water bottles and you
could tell they were grateful but
otherwise it was this as if the dead in
small Sullen groups were marching past
one of the men mumbling to himself led a
small group of weeping women toward us
pulling out my pirate scope I checked
the hands from a distance and studied
the women to see if their hijabs
contained any odd shapes or might
indicate a hidden weapon or suicide vest
there were no children David walked into
the street to greet a man as the group
came closer the man looked at me and
then in my rifle his expression
unnatural in its desperation I slid my
finger to the trigger
he's ready to die
the man looked at David his eyes dropped
to the ground and his shoulders began to
heave he allowed on a terrible cry and
fell limp like a ragdoll into David's
arms clear the way clear the way David
Held the man and gently guided him to
the shade beneath the young tree the man
began to wail with sorrow he lifted his
eyes Skyward and started to yell in
Arabic Delo what is he saying David sat
down behind the man and put his hand on
the man's shoulder trying to comfort him
he says that Isis was killing everyone
all morning the low began they went into
the street and started shooting every
person they could the man continued to
tell his story through his sobs they
shot his daughters right in front of him
he watched one of his daughter's heads
get shot off
the low listened as the man continued to
speak there was a massacre everyone ran
we stood in silence knowing the only
thing we could offer him was to Bear
witness to his grief
Allah and Islam one of the only words I
could make out as he shook his finger as
he shook his fists and anger tears
streaming down his red in face he says
that Isis are not true Muslims the law
was translating quickly they are not
true Islam a law does not approve of
Isis the man continued to weep
there was nothing I could do but walk
back over to the Humvee
and continued to stand guard
so this is just a atrocity just a
full-on
No Holds Barred
atrocity this was this was uh the
morning of June uh I believe June 1st
2017 and I looked it up before
um I I forget where I found the source I
should have I should have kept the
source but basically there was somebody
who was tracking the amount of
casualties that happened during the
Battle of mosul so again at the time
like this was the deadliest Urban battle
in the world since World War II
um obviously Ukraine is going to totally
swamp this but
um at the time that was the case and
June 1st was the deadliest day of this
deadliest battle and that was because of
this massive Massacre that had just
happened that morning that we were now
seeing the people who had survived the
massacre they were now in Iraqi Army
lines and they were coming to us and
they were that's why everyone was so
shaken they weren't even like that happy
to see us because they had all just
witnessed this Slaughter and so at the
time we didn't we didn't know this we
didn't fully understand that there was a
massacre we didn't fully understand what
had happened we knew that Isis was
shooting people we're like yeah it's
another Tuesday in in mosul man like
yeah of course Isis are shooting guys so
we didn't fully understand what was
going on or the level of what was going
on until the next morning when we were
the first ones to come across at the
very front of the front line come across
the actual Massacre and come across all
the bodies and it was hundreds hundreds
of people I'd been slaughtered in the
street uh women kids babies
um pregnant women
I saw a a baby so the both of the
parents had been shot in the back of the
head or had been both have both been
shot in the back about six feet before
being able to turn this corner and get
down to safety because you can see where
the bullets had come from they're about
six feet from the edge of just of safety
but they'd both been shot and the story
you could tell the story of how they had
died the mother was to the right of the
father both the bodies were laying there
and the mother had like bags next to her
and the father had nothing next to him
except for the child so the father had
been carrying the child the mother had
been carrying the bags when the parents
had been shot
the father had fallen onto a pile of
rubble and the babies had been cracked
open and bashed open and so the baby its
head was completely exposed a giant hole
in its head
um and like maybe not even like a six
month old baby just a tiny little thing
laying there on the rubble six feet away
from uh safety and so we saw the the
level of death and Carnage and the next
morning uh when we when we saw all this
stuff so less than 24 hours later so
maybe you know 16 hours later we came
across this massacre and the man who had
told us about his daughters being killed
we don't know for sure if the two bodies
we found were the daughters but they fit
the description it was two girls who
would have been about 15 uh 12 12 to 15
years old both of them have been shot
one of the girls had been shot in the
back of the head and her entire face was
gone she must have been hit with a 50 or
something I don't know so she was shot
in the back of the head and her face
from her from her hairline down to her
jaw and then out to her ears the whole
thing was just a big black hole of black
dried blood
um because she and that's how she died
right next to another another girl and
they'd both been been running and
um so this is this is what these Iraqis
had seen this is what we it's this is
what we saw this is what we came across
the next morning uh and piles piles of
bodies not intentionally piled but
people had been shot and other people
have been running over the bodies and
then then had been shot and fallen down
and then more people had tried to get
over those bodies and had been shot and
fallen down and so there were piles of
bodies where people uh basically a small
wall of um bodies had been had been and
sort of piled up as people tried to get
to safety and it was all just unarmed
unarmed civilians saw a man in a
wheelchair the wheelchair who just
slumped over in his wheelchair that's
another man he'd been hit the top of his
head was gone and his whole brain was
still was still intact sitting like in
his head uh the whole thing's still
intact but the whole crown of his head
was gone uh like I said pregnant women
um kids like young kids two three four
five years old
in with all the bodies and it was
in the middle of all that as we as we
looked at this we saw Movement we saw
that there were still a few people alive
and one of the one of the there was a
wounded man or two wounded men and a
little girl and um the little girl was
like hiding under her mother's body
and it was about 36 hours into the after
the massacred when we launched the
mission to go rescue that little girl
but so you know you you see this we
talked about the nature of evil we'll
talk about the experience in Afghanistan
where I thought man like this is so evil
why would these Taliban guys send these
little girls
I remember looking at this looking at
this massacre which is right in front of
Isis headquarters so we're looking at it
through the rubble of buildings we're
looking at it through bombed out uh
holes and things like that in the
concrete so that way we don't get shot
as well because Isis is still there
they're 50 meters away looking right
down on this
um and I remember as I turned the corner
and poked my head out and saw
saw these bodies it didn't make sense to
me because I'd never seen images like
this in color I'd only seen them in
black and white a killing field of
bodies this was something that happened
in Vietnam this was something that
happened in uh Cambodia this was
something that happened in World War II
this doesn't happen today and even in my
in my my brain struggled for a few solid
seconds to kind of make sense of what I
was looking at and then I realized oh
wow
like I'm I'm looking at a massacre and
it's something I never thought I would
ever see in my entire life I never
thought I would see something like this
and there it was in full color and
survivors still hiding in the bodies
including like a little girl who's maybe
maybe three years old hiding huddling
under her mother's uh hijab
and
yeah
there was
some of the um news around this time
even prior to this but you know the news
was there was um
like the recruiting for Isis like they
were just if you were a freaking
psycho or a sociopath in the Islamic
world
in 2000 and you know 2016 2015. it was
like hey we got a job for you and we're
gonna take care of you you're going to
be able to rape women you're going to be
able to do whatever you want you're
gonna be able to fight kill like I
I dread the think how many just truly
sadistic
evil people showed up to be part of this
to be part of Isis at the time I would
love to go back and look at what kind of
recruiting they did to bring just people
that are willing to fight and kill and
rape and murder it's like
it's a it's a like that's what you need
for for to carry out this kind of thing
you got to get six sadistic evil people
and then brainwash them even more
um
fast forward a little bit
exhaustion that was all I felt as
ambient sunlight began to filter through
the hazy skies above missoul and light
in the abandoned living room we we'd
slept in
I stepped into the early morning light
and saw the blood and iodine soaked
bandages scattered across the ground
where we had treated the wounded today
is going to suck
fast forward hey we got bodies over here
more bodies Skye said peeking around the
edge of the wall to see more of the
highway he pulled back for a moment and
looked at us shaking his head I stayed
where I was scanning the rubble across
the street looking for any movement from
an Isis Gunner
it's a whole family Bernard said his
shoulders hung heavy as he held his
camera and reviewed the photos as we
climbed through the rubble of the house
to get a better view of the highway I
suspected
there were we were all sensing the same
thing this is just the tip of the
iceberg
reaching a large Second Story room with
massive Windows a highway of death
rolled out before us like a movie in the
big screen
the decimated Road below was littered
with dead civilians
Warriors don't gasp and gawk at death
and destruction they remain composed and
stoic remember fear panic and rage are
contagious so a soldier must rise above
them and remain disciplined inside I
wanted to put my fist through a wall and
scream but instead I moved silently to
the edge of the window and peered down
the highway below as if there were any
other logical assessment Skye and David
also Warriors behaved in the same calm
manner
everyone count how many bodies you see
David instructed I'm gonna report this I
began counting across the highway bodies
lay and twisted heaps of Flesh and
clothes against the wall
one two three four two little girls were
face down in the middle of the highway
shot in the back five six I choked back
to yours seven eight nine ten
we got a lot more dead over here a sky
called from deeper inside the house he'd
found a room where you could see further
down the road toward Isis but still
concealed from the sniper there's at
least a dozen wait there's we've got
movement some of them are still alive
I moved to take a look as Sky pointed
them out to us peering through my pirate
scope I took a took in the ghastly scene
a large pile of bodies lay up against a
wall bloated and rotting in the sun
heaped in a morbid tangle of blood and
body parts images of mass Graves sprang
into my mind pure evil
movement a little girl stood up from the
pile drifting like an apparition from
body to body she stared at each body for
a moment with an emotionless Hollow face
and then moved to the next one her
clothes were matted with sweat and dirt
and dried blood
you cowardly Savages I said Beneath My
Breath the thought of slitting Isis
throats engulfed my mind I wanted to
kill I wanted Justice you damn cowards
more movement one two three four I see
four kids moving around that pile of
bodies one two and two men
we were all seeing the same thing a
little five-year-old girl and what
appeared to be her three-year-old
brother sat huddled next to their dead
mother hijab
the wandering little girl only a few
feet away meandered through the bodies
and sat next to a little boy who's
slightly older than her he gave her the
last of his water she drank it and then
she laid down on the ground the boy laid
a shirt on top of her to Shield her from
the scorching sun he then laid down next
to her
that was the last time I would ever see
them move
a couple Iraqi soldiers who had now
joined us desperately screamed at the
children to run across the highway to us
the children glanced in our Direction
but seemed to be staring a thousand
miles past us
they had passed Beyond Reason
they were dying
we have to do something
fast forward a little bit
bullets rained heavier
I turned and looked in the direction of
the incoming fire the hospital was
invisible again
I need to start shooting Ephraim David
screamed to me he never screamed like
that unless something was very wrong
turning away from those black windows I
wanted to be filling with lead I saw the
old man had slipped from the table he
was just too weak to hold on now and
tank tracks were about to run him over
stooping down I rolled him to the side
but the Highway's median prevented him
from Rolling far enough there was
nothing I could do the old man's head
was up and he stared at the machine that
was about to flatten him starting with
his feet up his legs spine and finally
his skull then for the first time during
our backward movement the tank adjusted
its course and missed the old man by no
more than a hands with the old man
stared at the tank as it rolled past him
and turned his head back toward me the
smoke was dissipating and bullets were
flying everywhere moving outside the
cover of the tank was suicide the
military taught me never to attempt the
rescue Under Fire without cover you're
no good to anyone dead over the past
month I'd made my fair share of
decisions that had directly resulted in
people staying alive this is my first
time I had to make the decision to let
someone die I was sorry but felt no
guilt we didn't kill him Isis did
stepping back to my place on the flank
behind the tank I walked backward crack
I felt like someone had just teed off
with a sledgehammer against my right
calf I'd been hit the many stories I'd
heard from guys who'd been shot
instantly flooded my mind it's just like
they described like half of me was a
spectator watching the other half of me
fall in slow motion bam the ground came
up in full force I'm hit I yelled
and I sat up to look at my leg
did it Miss the bone fortunately the
bullet had entered through the right
side of my calf and exited the left wait
what the hell is that noise I glanced
over my shoulder the tank damn it I
sprang to my feet two seconds before
getting crushed my leg burned as if
someone had stabbed the burning shot a
burning hot metal rod through it but I
could walk just don't bleed to death
reaching for my tourniquet that I kept
easily accessible I walked backwards
trying to stay within the Tank's small
cone of cover while cinching the
tourniquet grateful for the many times
I'd practiced
we were finally in line with the street
that was our Escape but we still had to
cross 100 meters of open ground to get
to safety and my leg was quickly locking
up the muscle seizing as the adrenaline
wore off with the smoke all but
dissipated it would be near suicide to
attempt to run across the street the
burning pain doubled then tripled Humvee
David screamed at the Iraqi soldiers who
watched us from cover bring us a Humvee
he waved one arm frantically I joined in
screaming in Arabic it was no use they
weren't gonna budge and they probably
couldn't hear us anyways we needed
someone to run across and carry the
message my head began to spin and
breathing became more difficult I
started to feel light-headed I'm losing
too much blood if I pass out here
they're going to die trying to carry me
I need to be the one I needed to be the
one who would run across the open ground
and tell them we needed a Humvee and I
knew that my Karen medic friends toe and
leija Leia Elia Elia would be there to
treat me the tricky part would be just
making her cross the open ground without
getting shot Again David I'm feeling
lightheaded I'm gonna move across I
started to get in position to hobble
across the open use the berm as cover
David pointed out a small pile of debris
that lined the highway
and almost useless cover but better than
nothing I sprang out damn it that hurts
skipping was my best option as I tried
to pick up speed and cross the open
ground Isis Gunners immediately opened
fires bullets snapped and cracked past
me impacting the walls and Rubble around
me and kicking up the dirt at my feet I
struggled to run Towing Leia had huddled
by the wall waving me in and I locked
eyes with them trying not to think about
a bullet striking the side of my head
and ushering me into eternity they need
a Humvee I screamed as I cleared the
wall to safety they echoed the call
their medical supplies ready to treat me
they were on me in a Flash trauma shears
cutting away my pant leg as another
tourniquet was ratcheted down on my leg
dust dust I screamed as a Humvee sped
past us no more than two feet away
kicking up filthy missouled sand and
dirt the Medics leaned in and shielded
my wound from debris that would almost
certainly cause an infection I didn't
know it at the time but the heroic
driver of the Humvee rushing out into
the battle to rescue the team Under Fire
was the French journalist Bernard ganier
had I indeed need he had he had indeed
needed to learn how to drive the Humvee
which is from a previous section where
you taught him how to drive a Humvee my
happiness that the Humvee was rescuing
my team was short-lived a Leia drenched
a piece of gauze and iodine and twisted
it into the entrance of my wound
clutching my AK and Burying my forehead
into the dirt I grunted under my breath
I'm not gonna scream no how bad no
matter how bad it hurts
she trenched the more gauze and iodine
this time forcefully twisting one end
into the raw Flash the exit wound
I gritted my teeth and tried to maintain
my courage as suddenly as it started it
was over
moments later I was in the back of the
armored Ambulance with Daryl and the
Mennonite at the wheel driving away out
the back window I saw the Humvee come to
a screeching halt and a crowd of Medics
and Iraqi soldiers rushed to help
I was beyond relieved
mission complete
and and uh oddly enough this whole
freaking well not this whole thing but
this event was captured on video on and
it's on YouTube you can just look up
your name and look up freaking getting
shot or something along those lines and
you can see this thing unfolding it's
actually captured from a couple
different angles yeah there were there
were multiple sort of more
correspondents in the area who were
there documenting Isis atrocities and
some of the FBR team their job was just
to document atrocities so they get all
this footage of things happening and uh
none of us knew that everything was
under like was was being filmed we
weren't like we weren't even thinking
about that at the time
um but yeah every everything from
um you know there's a uh a very famous
video or uh sky and I give covering fire
while Dave runs out and grabs uh the
little girl because we had driven down
that road or an Iraqi army tank had
driven straight down that road into Isis
territory uh we'd actually convinced the
American Military to give us a smoke
screen so they were firing white
phosphorus air burst to try and give us
a smoke screen into the into the City
and so we're behind the tank on foot and
we give covering fire Dave runs out and
grabs a little girl we tried to get the
two men we were able to get one of the
men but the second man um we were
basically dragging him on a um he was
wounded heavily in the shoulder she
couldn't carry him because he was going
to bleed out
um and so if we were dragging him on a
uh a piece of metal that was in the
street he fell off almost got run over
by the tank and that's what I described
so I literally moved him out of the way
four or five inches from the edge of the
tank tread and then you know five
seconds later I get shot and the moment
I got shot that's on that's on camera as
well
um I fall down and you can see me turn
around I look at the tank it's about to
crush me and it was like Hey man like
you just got to get up and keep moving I
had already read this book when I
watched the video so this was a within
the past week and I was like I'm gonna
go watch that video and having worked
around a lot of tanks tanks don't care
what they run over and they can't stop
and they can't see anything yeah so it
is just like a it might as well be the
the force of nature just an ensemble so
even knowing what was happening even
though I was getting ready to talk to
you in a couple days when you got shot
fell down I still had like my gut went
like bro like you're gonna get run over
get up and sure enough you barely got up
and you're able to get out of there but
um yeah and and the the one thing kind
of tying into that so
um as I was as I was walking backwards I
was walking backward trying to keep my
eye toward the enemy
um my eyes toward the enemy and I was
putting my tourniquet on as I was
putting my tourniquet on and walking
backwards
um the guy started screaming at me again
and it was too late I looked down and I
tripped over the bodies of one of those
little girl the girl had been shot in
the back of the head and her whole face
was gone so I looked down you know
there's uh blood pouring from two holes
in my leg uh there's dead bodies
everywhere and I'm sort of stepping in
and stepping on this this girl's body
and her
lifeless face or lack of a face or the
hole where her face used to be it's just
staring straight up at me
um as I'm like tripping over her body
and we're still taking fire from the
flank we're still taking Isis was also
dumping mortars and stuff so there's
random mortars going off none of those
none of the mortars were caught on video
I don't think
um and yeah so then we just had to we
had to get out of there and get a Humvee
one of the one of the cool things where
I I do one but probably one of my
favorite parts of this is there's a
French journalist Bernard ganier uh he
um he he so not a not a you know just an
observer just an observer
he was the one who hopped in the Humvee
and drove out Under Fire
after seeing me get shot he watched the
whole thing he drove out there in an
armored Humvee everyone they threw the
little girl and the one man who was able
to uh who we were able to rescue they
all hop in the Humvee and then crossed
that open terrain that I had just run
across and uh yeah just like as civilian
as civilian can be and he did that and I
was like dude right on like that's
that's just the best I like he's his
that one little part is like one of my
favorite this is one of my favorite
things you've seen this total civilian
guy just drive straight like dude you
are in Iraqi excuse me like you are in
Isis territory now like the like the
Iraqi Army ends here and you're now out
there with blood and death and Carnage
and uh I was yeah I just thought that
was one of the one of the best things
and and uh yeah huge shout out to him
yeah and it was incredible was it you
that taught him how to drive the Humvee
at some point I wasn't the one who
taught him how to do the Humvee um I was
assigned to do it but I ended up having
someone else do it or whatever but the
conversation had he had come up to me a
few days before that and been like hey
man like can you show me how to drive a
Humvee just in case I was like yeah no
worries
um but then when I went when I followed
up with him it's like you know somebody
else had already showed him uh but yeah
he'd like he's like hey can you guys
show me how to drive one of these movies
just just in case and I cracked the joke
I was like dude if you it's like if you
have to drive the Humvee things have
gone really really wrong I just and he
we were both laughing he's like yeah I
still want to know anyway I was like you
know of course like that's like the
Hollywood foreshadowing moment right
yeah exactly yeah exactly uh but he he
did a he did an awesome job and then um
so that night I ended up in a hospital
in erbil like a Kurdish Hospital an
award filled with um guys who'd been
wounded in mosul all peshmerga so
there's no Iraqi Army there so when I
when I got brought in
um I spent the night
um there and
um in the middle of the so it was it was
the most bizarre thing
um I don't I still don't understand like
what happened or how it happened or like
what was going on with the human
psychology of it but
when they shut down the ward that night
they turned off the lights for everyone
to sleep
the doctors left the room and they so
we're in this large room I'm with maybe
30 or 40 other wounded soldiers I'm just
by myself
um and
the amount of screaming that started
going off like it still like echoes in
my in my brain to this day these guys
screaming for their mothers these guys
in horrible paying other guys much much
I mean my injury was you know literally
just a flesh wound right it wasn't that
big of a deal these other guys been shot
in the hip and shot in the shoulder
broken bones and they're just laying
there screaming in pain all night and so
I'm just listening to this I don't of
course I don't sleep a wink
um and just listening to the screaming
in the middle of the night A Guy Walks
In into the ward with a flashlight and
he starts going person to person he
starts shining this flashlight on
everybody and then at some point he he's
looking at this folder and he point he
points the flashlight at me and I'm down
I'm down all the way at the end of the
room and so then he just keeps the
flashlight on me I can't see him he just
walks all the way down this dark Ward
where everyone's like screaming and he
comes right up to me
and he speaks broken English and he says
uh he's like I'm with Kurdish
intelligence I need to ask you a few
questions
and at the time uh you know and I like
in in the U.S like special ops like we
all want to grow our beards out because
like that's what we like to do like
where we grow our beard out and that's
needed in places like Afghanistan well
in Iraq it's the exact opposite Isis has
beards and the cool guys have uh you
know um Saddam Hussein mustaches that's
with all the cool that's that's the
thing everyone does it's the mustaches
so I'm a white guy with a beard who'd
alone who'd been shot in mosul so I fit
perfectly a foreign volunteer fighter
who'd come to fight ice as I fit the
profile perfectly so they were coming to
make sure that I wasn't Isis to fight
with Isis yes excuse me to fight with
Isis correct uh so they thought I might
be Isis and so the this guy comes in to
interrogate me and uh so I'm laying
their prostrate in this bed completely
helpless my leg raised and so he starts
asking me a few questions and my
identity and where I'm from and I was
able to provide them documentation who I
was and whatnot and So eventually he
just kind of he he just kind of folded
up his uh his his folder and just kind
of set it on the desk next to me and
just sat there and and I and and he he
was like he just kept on asking me
questions uh but like he wanted to know
he kind of set it aside he stopped
taking notes he realized I wasn't a
threat and he just wanted to hear my
story and so I sat there telling this
Intel guy in the middle of the night
with the flashlight my story everything
I'm telling you guys right now
um meanwhile there's like crying and
screaming in the background and then he
was like he's like oh man thanks for
helping that's that's really great he
shook my hand at some point an hour
later and then just walked off into the
darkness and never saw him again
um and that's how the whole ordeal
basically ended yeah in Iraq at least
yeah
um
yeah you get Medevac flown home you go
through that stuff you say here and I'm
gonna close this out with the close out
the book
um with this and again I covered three
percent of this book uh get the book you
say when I returned home I spent several
weeks of decompressing from Shell Shock
after the incident on the plane which is
like this is on the plane you basically
like woke up in a flashback scenario
um I knew I would have some demons to
purge my sleep was fitful I wouldn't
want to talk to anyone for days at a
time my headache for seemingly no reason
sudden noises made my heart rate Spike
there were dreams filled with screaming
children but slowly my sleep became
better I began to open up to my family
about what I saw the headaches became
less frequent and my nerves calmed down
eventually I evened out and became my
old self again as much as I could be and
the dreams of death and destruction
melted away
I gave up the hate
and that's again you know what will kind
of wrap the book on
um
that was 2017 2017. that was a long time
ago yeah six years ago
um
how was it
when you got home
so this was you know you imagine if
you're if you get wounded in the in the
military you come home and you've got
you know the full Military Support
structure
there's nothing I literally just uh had
some crutches and I got booked a flight
home and flew home and it was I was I
was in line
um
I was in line to get on the plane and
there's a bunch of other like military
contractors there and so they just
assumed I was a military contractor and
so I just was in there I had my crutches
and they let me board the plane first so
as I go to get on one of the uh one of
the contractor guys he's like oh like
workplace injury you know like meaning
like did you like get hit by like a
forklift or something you know and I was
like yeah something like that and I just
laughed and then I got on the plane so I
did like you know no idea
um but yeah getting getting home um so I
flew back to Wisconsin and my parents
picked me up at the airport actually I
flew back to technically Chicago my
parents picked me up at the airport we
drove back to Wisconsin and yeah it was
just surreal it was just this insane
amount of violence and everything and
then also now I'm back in the States
with my parents driving back to their
place you know and I've been out of the
military for a couple of months at this
point you know uh so this is June like
mid-june I just gotta technically my
last day in the Navy was in April and um
so so getting back the
um the initial decompression was was
was was rough initially just
decompressing from everything it was
really good to be home at like great
relationship with my parents like
they're just the best nicest people in
the world
um but you know in the book there I talk
about how my sleep eventually got better
and I was able to decompress from that
initial sort of Battlefield stress that
you're feeling just initially right off
the your nerves are all on edge because
you're in fight or flight mode
um but it wasn't until a couple of years
later that
um really a lot of that stuff really uh
messed with me and uh yeah it had a lot
of issues with like yeah yeah just uh
depression and and all this different
stuff that would just come out of
nowhere I'm like dude like Life's good I
have no reason to complain like
everything's fine everything ultimately
is fine
um but there was a lot of just like just
dark demons and stuff and again like you
said we talked about three percent of
the book all this other stuff that I had
seen and experienced and then continuing
on like I'm still like to this day still
working in Conflict zones not to this
same exact level I mean recently I
wasn't something to this level but
um you know now I've run a humanitarian
Aid group called stronghold rescue and
relief and we go into conflict zones we
seek out these places and we provide
rescue and relief services and it's
primarily emergency medicine Refugee
protection and and just standard
humanitarian relief and
um so I'm still constantly going back to
conflict zones and I have over the last
few years and
um you know so the the decompression is
still this ongoing thing and it's less
of less of ability to decompress in more
of a
you have to learn to cope with it that's
one of the things I'm personally
struggling with even now at the moment
is because I just basically got off a
six-month combat deployment in Burma
um you know and again I'm not there to
fight necessarily I'm there to help but
you end up you end up in you end up in
the fighting I watched like I said
several times now it's like I watched my
best friend die
um you know I'll watch a bunch of guys
around me get shot and killed and we're
treating lots of wounded and things like
that and
um you know I'm going back in a couple
of months again for another five to
seven month deployment so it's this it's
this constant deployment cycle
um and it doesn't it to an extent it
doesn't end so I'm still at this point
where I'm trying to figure out okay how
do I how do I balance that how do I uh
not go completely crazy you know but but
also how do I continue to help because
that's the other thing too is how do you
walk away when you when you see when you
talk to villagers and you make friends
with the guys I work with in Burma
you know and you hear their stories yeah
the Burma Army raped and murdered my
wife yeah the Burma Army killed my
father yeah the Burma Army tied me to a
tree when I was a 12 year old uh beat me
half to death and then made me watch as
they chopped my father's head off
these are very typical stories of these
guys that you talk to and so how do you
say hey man like I need a break I'm I'm
I'll be back in a couple of years you
know whatever how do you not help them
how do you not go back and it's uh it's
difficult because you want to help
everyone right but also at the same
point too you're going to burn out
um and so like in 2020 I had a you know
quite the experience with burnout
um I talked about it a bit on stumps
podcast but I realized at that point
that I actually was very very much
addicted to like bread and sugar and I
know that sounds very strange but I
became I was I was like honest to God
full-blown addicted and that was I I was
the addiction started when I was in the
teams that was one of the issues that
helped or that was that was causing my
lack of physical fitness at that level
I'm still in good shape but not like
seal shape like you need to be in right
uh and that was because of like
full-blown addiction and I was my way
like dealing with stress I didn't
realize it at the time but going forward
um it got worse and worse and then in
like 2021 I realized it's like dude like
what the hell man I was I was like 110
pounds heavier than I am right now for
like for like a year what the hell were
you eating everything the the answer is
like literally everything and I was I
was depressed and how much did you weigh
I weighed at my high 300 yeah yeah I was
at 325.
yeah I was at 3 25 yeah yeah not good
not good so my point is then I had to go
through this whole process of like all
right dude I got to deal with addiction
I gotta get over this um ironically at
Russell Brand's book helped me get over
the addiction because it's basically the
12 steps program but with Russell Brand
uh his point of view it's more fun oh
it's hilarious dude it's honestly it's
even if you don't have addiction like
listen to it it's the funniest thing
um but yeah I dealt with I dealt with
that and I realized that I was using
food or whatever because I've never been
much of a drinker um it's just you know
that's typically what a lot of guys they
over they overdo with the alcohol right
um fear about those Oreos I'm about
those Oreos
and then yeah and then all of it and
those Chipotle Burritos yeah exactly so
uh yeah so you you have an Instagram and
I this is this is what I said on the
Instagram
um November 10th 2022 you said over the
past two years I've had some major
demons to process and deal with
primarily operator syndrome catastrophic
burnout and also addiction I was under
the impression I'd already dealt with
the mental and emotional repercussions
of war and was good to go but I was very
wrong in 2020 without warning a
multitude of dormant deep-seated issues
suddenly resurfaced and put me down hard
humbling me and showing me an internal
Darkness I've never experienced before I
knew I simply wasn't going to make it if
I didn't lose if I didn't Focus all my
energy on facing these issues head on
because of this I've mostly stayed off
social media to focus on myself not
because social media is bad but because
I needed to maintain my focus on other
priorities ultimately I feel stronger
now than before this unpleasant Journey
began and it's now been more than a year
that I've been back to functioning
functioning at 100 going forward I plan
to post occasionally and hopefully share
some of the principles which have helped
me through this process
so operator syndrome this is like bad
sleep this is uh hormone dysfunction
this is chronic pain headaches substance
abuse in your case freaking Oreo abuse
depression suicide family dysfunction
this is this is a pretty new term
operator syndrome caused by like all the
stress the blasts like all these things
and and you were definitely feeling this
yeah absolutely I was somebody sent me
an article at some point I was uh I
basically read through what operator
syndrome was because I'm like you know I
yes I've had whatever traumatic combat
stress related stuff but like everyone
does you know if you're in this line of
work that's going to happen I'm like do
why is this affecting me so so so much
like why you know just this total
burnout and all the different things so
I went through and I read through the
operator syndrome uh stuff and I can't
quote it off the top of my head but I
went through and I was looking at all of
these symptoms I'm like dude this is me
I'm like I'm like and the thing is like
I know dudes that have this who've never
been in combat though too that's the
thing that's why I was like oh this is
the guys who were in the teams who
haven't been able to deploy to combat
zones they're like this they got these
headaches because they've got all this
all these other issues and it's because
of all of the uh micro concussions from
all the explosives from the shooting the
Carl G's so like all all this stuff
right
um and so I realized like oh you know
this is this is definitely something
I've um yeah definitely something I'm
definitely experiencing and I think even
today I'm still I'm still experiencing
it to to an extent because like I'm by
no means am I done uh the war continues
and um so it's something where I'm
trying to figure out okay how do you how
do you cope with that how do you keep
you know keep it under wraps and still
continue to do your job and uh and help
people what was the catastrophic burnout
I is this also known as watching a lot
of Netflix
so the yeah that's true uh the the
catastrophic burnout came from as I was
starting stronghold rescue and relief I
had spent a bunch of time I'd spend a
bunch of time overseas I spent months
living in The Jungle by myself with uh
you know being the only Foreigner with
this tribe of people in the areas I was
working for months and um I've been
trying to get my organization up and
running and as you know starting up
starting a business starting a small bit
it's a lot of work and again granted
what I do is not a business it's a it's
a non-profit and so I'm not getting paid
I'm working my butt off I'm trying to do
I'm trying to trying to raise funds I'm
trying to get back there and help these
guys and I was just pushing and pushing
and pushing and pushing myself and not
being healthy still dealing with
addiction all of this stuff made this
perfect storm of eventually and then my
and then the back injuries from from
hell week and all that stuff hit me
again in the early in early 2020. so it
was just this perfect storm of just
everything hit me all at the same time
it just totally flattened me it just
absolutely just I was just burned out I
was just done and all of that stuff hit
me at the same time and that's what I
mean by just catastrophic burnout I've
been working so hard to get the the
organization going things were not going
well I mean things were going fine but
they weren't going well I couldn't
support myself doing the job and uh you
know I needed to be back there helping
these people and I wasn't able to and
that's that's also that also adds on to
the issue so
um a lot of uh yeah just basically a ton
of stress I would say chronic stress
would probably be a better better term
for the burnout and so you just felt
like you were kind of done at this point
you are having trouble with your
organization that you started your
freaking way in 300 plus pounds
um was there like a wake-up moment was
there something that you know something
that shocked your system back into like
dude get it get your together so
every morning I woke up and was like
dude get your together I've been
staring myself in the mirror I'm like
well why can't you and this was part of
the process part of the issue was I
would I would look I would look at
myself and go dude like you're freaking
seal man like you made it through hell
with BGE back injury like you fought in
Wars like you've been like you got shot
you just like literally stood up and
walked it off right so you're tough
you're disciplined so what is what like
what the hell is the matter with you
like what is the issue what is what is
the real issue here
and
um ultimately ultimately there is the
single biggest thing was the addiction
that was the single biggest factor that
was the Domino that was messing
everything up the one thing that finally
shook me out of
um my of my issue uh and started where I
started to heal was in early 2021
um I basically was like dude I'm at my
last leg here I don't know how to fix
myself I don't know what's wrong with me
um and I just don't I don't know I don't
know what to do so I drove from
Wisconsin to Florida and I went to
Jacksonville Beach Florida and I got a
hotel at the
um at I think Four Points by Sheridan
you know juice might just use my credit
card uh I got a top room at the at the
Sheridan facing the ocean and I sat
there for a month I just sat there for a
month and I just stared at the ocean I
was like dude I just need to sit here
and like think about my life and figure
out what the hell I'm going to do moving
forward I'm not giving up on stronghold
I'm not giving up on myself I'm not
going to give up I'm not gonna go commit
suicide I'm not gonna I'm not gonna do
any of that stuff I'm gonna I'm gonna
lose this 100 plus pounds I'm gonna
figure out how to get this stuff done
I'm gonna figure out because I'm
fighting to get back to these people who
need my help I need to do this I'm going
to figure it out I don't know what the
answer is I sat there and I stared at
the ocean for a month
over the course of that month
my stress levels just slowly slowly
slowly start decompress my brain started
opening up if everything started making
sense and I was able to at that point
um a couple of months later was able to
like make peace with the fact that I was
an addict
um and that was what finally set me on
the trajectory to to fully heal and get
back to get back to 100 and better than
I was before what was the first move to
overcome the addiction or like even the
few moves and the 12 steps that Russell
Brown would need I'm going to link you
up with Russell Brown he would love to
hear this okay I would love to talk to
him it would be great his his book his
book uh absolutely changed my life and
is helping how did you how did you
connect all right
um this isn't a like a real legitimate
addiction this just isn't me like liking
snacks this is a freaking addiction this
is a problem it's controlling me what
was the mental transition there the
mental transition was I had um I got to
the point where I'd lost like 25 pounds
I was like all right cool I'm like I've
got a good diet like at this point now I
know how to work out now I know how to
do nutrition you know like I'm a grown
man like all right cool
um the breaking point came where I was
uh I was doing really good and also just
did another binge I just went on the
binge for no reason whatsoever even
though I just hadn't I was like I've
been so good for like like a month or
two like what the hell is wrong with me
like I just totally go off the deep end
and I sat there was like this isn't
normal this isn't natural like what the
hell is the matter with me so I just
started I was like dude I have to be an
addict because like I'm acting like I'm
acting like a heroin addict my brain I
know that what I'm putting into my face
right now is killing me it's not really
killing me this is stopping me from
being able to go to help people who are
being killed this is stopping me from
being able to like people are dying
right I know as I eat this 57th burrito
today people are dying because I can't
stop eating this damn burrito people are
dying and it's that simple because I'm
not there to help them and I'm still
doing it why am I still doing it I was
like that's an addict I'm thinking
selfishly something's wrong so I started
Googling or just you know researching
like okay what is what's the deal with
uh addiction what's to do with food
addiction what's all that about I'd
heard of 12 steps you know it helps so
many different people I didn't know
really know what it was
um and so then
um I I kind of looked it up and I was
like okay this is all you know this is
all well and good it seemed all a bit uh
you know a bit intense and super serious
and then you know I listened to like you
know Rogan or whatever and he had some
uh obviously he has Brandon from time to
time and I'd listen to that and so brand
you know
um I've been a fan of his for years
right and so then I see him go from you
know the the drugs and stuff I love his
documentaries about uh drug about um the
drug epidemic and how it's um uh it's a
disease not necessarily a crime and like
if you shift your mindset anyway those
are really good
um so I loved all this stuff and uh so
then I saw that he had a book called
recovery and I thought oh I can like
perfect I'll get that so I got the audio
version of that and I and I sat there I
think for like two days and I just went
through ever I listened to every word I
did all the different steps I did the
initial like four or five steps which is
really the addiction getting over the
addiction portion the other steps if I
remember correctly have more to do with
like fixing the damage in your life that
that the addiction is causing if you get
through the first like four or five
steps like that will help you control
these four or five steps that you do
like immediately yeah yeah you kind of
go through it's like it's a mental thing
so the first one is you have to admit
that you have a problem right which I
know sounds really simple but it's like
no no do you really have a problem and I
don't remember the next steps in
specific order but basically
um in in Russell Brand's book what he's
doing is he he goes through and he asks
like a series of like I don't know 50
questions what stuff along the lines of
like what um what is this what is this
what is this addiction uh taking from
you and so and but he asked that same
question in like 25 different ways what
is this taking away from your life right
and then the next series of like 50
questions is what would your look life
look like very specifically if this
addiction was suddenly gone like if what
if like what would your life look like
and so I went through all of these steps
and I remember like at different points
I was like literally sitting there like
tearing up because I was like man I was
like visioning this beautiful life I
know I could have which is the life I
have now I'm married I run a very
successful organization I'm helping a
lot of people I'm very happy and I know
this could be my life if I just get over
this addiction so that's the first
couple of steps as you go through you go
through that and eventually I don't know
if it's like step number four or five
total abstinence that's it today going
forward there is no more you do not have
the substance anymore if you're an
alcoholic you don't you don't ever have
a drink you don't ever go oh well it's
just it's my birthday I deserve it none
zero zero total abstinence most people
can do moderation addicts cannot do
moderation and you have to make you have
to make peace with the fact that you're
an addict you don't you don't get to
there is no cheat day there is no
um I'm gonna you know just all things in
moderation you know be balanced all that
stuff like no no you have to be extreme
and all the exercises you had done
before is you having to sit there and
write out all the things the ways that
your life sucks because of this
addiction and the way that your life
could be if you just got over the
addiction or like control the addiction
that always comes back into play you
always think back to that you go oh man
yeah now now I get it I'm not going to
touch this anymore I'm not going to
touch this so for me from from that
point forward this was I think like July
9th 2021 I want to say
um I think it's 2021. since then I
haven't had like bread or sugar or
sweets or anything like that with the
exception of a couple different times it
was like literally no option like in
Burma to like eat this food or like the
village Elder is going to be like very
very offended and like it's going to
cause problems so so bread
sugar
sweets just bread and sweets basically
so like white flour stuff so like white
bread tortillas stuff like that if it's
like corn it's fine I don't fully
understand what what it is on the
chemical level I don't know so sometimes
like I'll have something and I'm like
whoa whoa that tastes too good and I'll
immediately spit it out and I'm like I
can't I can't have that um because I get
this I get this physical reaction I can
feel it I could feel the physical
reaction in my mouth I can feel that my
brain starts to go crazy like an ultra
dopamine like happiness crazy like this
is so good yes it's like this is for
heroin you're just like mainlining
freaking good taste yeah yeah and you
know it you know you can't handle it I
know it and I know this and so for the
rest of my life I'm not gonna have those
things ever again and that's that's what
I do in the last two years I haven't and
I that's what I plan what's your diet
consists of right now
um pretty much I try to keep stuff
pretty much as natural as possible so
I'm very lazy with with uh cooking so
any kind of meat vegetables and like a
like a massive amount of fruit I just
love fruit because I still have that
sweet tooth but I can have the fruit
because it's got the you know the um you
know you can't binge it it's not
possible
um lots of fiber and all that stuff in
it so yeah
like zero junk food like zero I just I
can't have it zero yeah
okay well we're going to try and get you
linked up with Russell Brand he's a good
he's a nice guy he's a good guy yeah he
would be very interested in this yeah I
haven't heard anyone talk to him about
food addiction and overcoming that um
so
how about this like internal deep-seated
darkness and internal issues like what
was that was this the food stuff what is
this so I had a lot of
um a lot of anger a lot of um
uh
I didn't quite give up all the hatred
that I thought I had right so I had a
I'd still had a lot of anger I still had
a lot of uh the world isn't fair I'm
very angry so it's one of those
situations when you're down on your luck
and you're the dude at the bottom of the
totem pole just getting punched in the
face and life isn't happening well for
you and it's when it's working well for
other people and you know you deserve
more and you know that you're capable of
more
um and I don't mean it deserve more in a
selfish way but it deserved more like
you're like dude I'm meant for more I
can do more and things just aren't
working out uh there's a lot of there's
a lot of anger and bitterness that I was
dealing with at that time
um just toward just ultimately was
because I was I didn't um I was ashamed
and angry at myself for not being uh at
the level that I needed to be
particularly to go help people in Burma
and to run stronghold in these things
there was also a lot of yeah a lot of
demons and stuff like just just from the
war and all the stuff and you're like
you have you're having I'm having
difficulty difficulty sleeping with
having all this stuff and each
individual thing is not all that bad
what happens is it's it's a death it's
death by A Thousand Cuts it's you have
all these different things all at the
same time are negative and I wasn't
processing them well and that was on me
I needed to fix my my own brain my own
mind and one of the things that also
helped me too with that is like stoic
philosophy I love Seneca I read letters
to Seneca
um not every single day but pretty much
every single day I read a chapter or
look at quotes and stuff like I study
his stuff because it it really really
really really helped me just keep my
keep my brain uh get help out my brain
yeah
so these are the when you talk about in
that in that uh Instagram post that you
did when you talked about the principles
that helped you through this this is
like the stoic principles this is the
Russell Bland Russell Brand 12-step
principles these are the kind of things
that you did yeah
get yourself back on track you're sat in
this hotel room for 30 days like and
just what looked at the ocean expand on
that man I don't get that that's what I
did uh so what I did was I needed to
work out did you do burpees in the room
um no so so yeah there was there was
like a gym at the at the hotel so I'd go
in and do workouts I'd go walk on the
beach
um but 90 of my time was just sitting in
the room like staring at the ocean and
yes um so the part of that time was
um I was fixing my diet and I was like I
was eating healthy and stuff like that
um so all of that absolutely did factor
into it I was getting in workouts you
know not every single day but three or
four days a week and I basically I
needed to just sit there and mentally
process everything and that's what I did
I just sat there mentally processing I
was like hey this is this is a this is a
problem this is something that's bugging
me I need to sit here and think about it
and I would just sit there in the piece
uh and just stare at the ocean and think
through all these different things and I
would take notes on it and I would you
know just kind of go through piece by
piece by piece and then ideas would pop
into my head and I'd kind of go down
that rabbit hole
um and I honestly couldn't tell you on a
piece of paper what exactly I did for
that month but I can tell you I sat
there and stared at the ocean and just
in the quiet and just like let my let my
body and my brain in my mind yeah just
alone yeah yeah my parents came down and
visited for like a couple days because
they were like oh you got a hotel on the
beach like all right we're gonna drive
down and uh you know enjoy a couple days
I was like yeah come on down so they
were down there for the last few days as
well which was great to be able to do
that for them but yeah yeah you know
I've been talking about this a little
bit lately
um just the like when you go through a
traumatic event
um
there's some things that are going to
happen to you
most likely you're gonna be second
guessing like some of the stuff you did
right you're gonna have those second
guessing you're probably gonna have some
bad dreams because you were in a bad
situation
um you're probably gonna do some big
contemplation about the meaning of life
and what it all means and all that you
may or may not depending on the
situation you're in have some kind of
survivor's guilt where like oh I lived
and you know whether it was an innocent
person whether it was a teammate I lived
and they died this is something that's
gonna
be in your brain most likely and
when as I've been talking to people
recently about this I'm and as people
approach me to ask me about these things
I tell them that
um yeah that's normal like you're gonna
feel this stuff and I think that
reassurance is very very helpful to
people to say oh yeah you weren't you
you were getting shot at or you almost
died yeah you have nightmares about that
yep that's normal uh you're second
guessing some of the moves that you made
yep that's normal oh you're not sure
what the hell we're doing here yep
that's normal
um oh you're feeling guilty about some
other people that died yes that's normal
like all these things are normal they're
going to take some time to process
they're not abnormal though it's not
like there's something wrong like if I
were to talk to you after this if I
wouldn't have taken five years to reply
to your letter or whatever
you know I'm like hey dude you're gonna
be feeling some stuff man it's like this
normal for you to feel like that you saw
a lot of death people aren't meant to
see that kind of stuff they are meant to
see little girls that have had their
face blown out of their heads like
that's not normal
and for you to feel think about that and
have some nightmares and lose some sleep
that's you're gonna be okay it's gonna
take some time you're gonna process it
but you're gonna be okay because I think
people get caught in the number one
there's something wrong with me and
number two
this isn't going to end or it's not
going to get any better and there's
nothing wrong with me because
you may still have bad feelings but like
understanding that that's normal you're
a human you care about the world
like okay so
um these things are going to leave a
mark right these traumatic situations
are going to leave a mark on you and
it's okay that you feel a little bit
different
it's okay so I've been trying to
encourage people with that how long did
the uh physical transformation of
Ephraim take
um the the bulk of it took probably
about a year
um you know I would I would love to say
that I did the the Goggins approach and
got it done in like 90 days that didn't
work you know but I did I did try uh
lots of different stuff I had to get you
know my my diet and everything in in
order and and whatnot and I was still
dealing with a lot of the mental aspects
and such uh one of the unique things
that I actually tried out was um like
dry fasting so you would not drink no no
food and no water the longest I did was
uh four days and 16 hours no food no
water and that was with like two or
three workouts in there
um we're not recommending that yeah to
be very good to me baby let me be very
clear like we're not recommending it but
like I tried some of that and some of
that different stuff out some like
different extreme approaches and
ultimately I'm glad I'm glad that I did
those things because it was right for me
but like definitely don't try it um
because it's not the sustainable way to
like cut weight I was like you're gonna
like have uh some uh you know health and
hold an exercise and all that stuff but
no doubt but um yeah so that that the
initial bulk of it took me about a year
until I was like I also was dealing with
the back injury so I finally got all
that kind of figured out and was back in
the field and since then it's just
gotten progressively better and better
um yeah so I'm back to feeling almost at
100 so we're there and so now the full
focus is Stronghold rescue Yep this is
what we're doing right now stronghold
rescue yep so talk to me about that
what's going on with that yeah so when I
when I
was in Thailand during that 2016
deployment again I wanted to start
something that would uh basically allow
veterans to go into conflict zones to to
help people and I didn't know what that
was going to look like I didn't know
what a nonprofit was or a for-profit I'd
know anyone in that stuff was so
um my foray into Iraq which we've just
talked in depth about
um that was me my mission there my
personal mission there was to figure out
like hey how does this work how are
these how are there American people here
helping in a conflict Zone what does
that even look like what is this so I
learned a lot of like what to do learned
a lot of what not to do ways that I
could um you know take my organization
and do things slightly different and
ultimately I decided to found stronghold
screen relief so we're a non-profit
organization and we basically provide
um humanitarian and uh like Rescue
Services basically to people completely
free of charge we'd never charge anybody
or we provide our services completely
free for them and we send in small teams
of uh veterans and we go into conflicts
my rule is no more than four of us we go
into conflict zones our primary focus
right now is Burma but we've been in
like Haiti Ukraine we were smuggling
stuff into Venezuela through like
partner like uh um
so the thing I wanted to get at was so
let's let's say we do it in the future
have more than four guys
um we will split them into different
teams and this is this is what
um I focused on with stronghold
um I call it charity with dignity and so
what that is is we go in and our job is
to enable and work with the locals so
they can build up their own capacity to
to do these things what happens and I've
seen it over and over and over again is
well intentioned but not not well
organized groups you like 20 Americans
will fly over to some to some area to
want to help and that's great that's a
great impulse I get that and if you're
if 20 of you are going to go that's
great but go split up into three or four
different locations because what happens
is you have 20 Americans show up
you know everyone each person spending
you know three to five thousand dollars
to be there for a couple of months
um plus gear and everything like that so
that those those 20 Americans that's you
know
um if you if you factor in food and
everything that's like that's well over
a hundred grand just just for you to
exist there now for that same hundred
grand if you were to enable locals who
had don't have jobs because they're
refugees they've lost their every
they've lost everything but they know
how to organize they speak the language
they already know what's going on so if
you can embed with them work with them
live with them Mentor them then now they
can run the relief operations they can
run the rescue operations they can be
the ones doing the medical care and
you're there with them in the field
supporting them not not just training
them and leaving them mentoring them
suffering with them improving with them
that is much more sustainable because in
the end
um
you know well I'm Gonna Leave right I'm
here in San Diego right now at this
moment I'm not in Burma but I'm getting
messages on my phone just this morning
and last night of patients being taken
care of by guys that we trained and
organized and so that's a lasting impact
long term the other thing uh part of the
other aspect of Charity with dignity is
um you've just had the worst day of your
life you just watched your wife die you
just watch them rape and murder your
wife your kids are missing you're
running through the jungle completely
alone you've just lost your home you've
lost everything and you finally make it
to safety and you uh somebody you know
somebody's going to bring you food or
something now imagine if it's some
Foreigner
coming up to you with a camera behind
them taking pictures and taking selfies
with you
to give you a bowl of rice and take a
selfie with you and give you some fake
empathy and put their arm around you and
put a little sad face on as they give
you the rice of course you'd be grateful
for the rice of course you'd be grateful
for the food but the insult and the
humiliation of that we completely avoid
that all of our humanitarian virtually
all of our humanitarian operations are
run directly by locals there's a local
on it so you just have the worst day of
your life hey you want to know what it's
a member of the tribe who's also a
refugee they've also lost their family
they've that you know six months ago or
a year ago their family is affected by
the war just as much they speak your
language they know the culture and
they're going to come help you out and
they're going to be the one to listen to
you to listen to your story record your
story give you the food give you the
rice give you what you need that's what
we do by with and through it's like the
exactly when the military by with and
through the locals which is always
superior yes and that's cool because if
you send 20 people in to do something
then they're basically going to give
people fish and not teach them how to
fish exactly so that's an awesome
methodology and then you using the
locals so it's familiar and it you know
it's it's just like a ego removal right
exactly for the for the howly that's out
there like oh I'll just you know cool I
get my picture with the local dude nope
you don't get that you would you
wouldn't believe the amount of stuff
like that that I've seen and I'm not
going to go into it because it'll like
really pissed me off uh but that's
that's what happens is guys go in there
the camera guy following them around
they're the hero and then they like make
the I've seen this like they make the
refugees who've just lost their home
make them all sit there in nice rows and
they they stand in front of them with a
camera and they give a nice speech about
who they are and how awesome they are
this is like a white person in like
Burma right and then and then they're
like all right cool camera's rolling the
whole time and then like now you got to
come up and I will hand you the thing so
you know you know that it was from me
the the white hero like you you know and
I've seen this stuff I've seen it happen
I've seen the videos I'm like it makes
me want to throw up and it makes me so
mad
um because it's it's such an insult uh
such an insult to the people and it's so
ineffective and cause it's so there's
there's a million reasons I've actually
have an article I just wrote for uh uh
black rifles coffee or die magazine uh
that'll be coming out within the next
week or two or so I believe
um but I I kind of go into this a little
bit the charity with dignity piece
um the example I give was just a couple
of months months ago in May it was May
9th or 10th I forget the date off the
top of my head the Burma Army went into
a village and they massacred 17 people
eight of the 17 people were kids under
the age of 10. uh only God knows what
they did to the women beforehand they
then slaughtered all of them piled their
bodies and burned the bodies
I got a video of it about like the next
morning after it happened I got a video
of it because I was about three miles
away uh working with another uh working
in another sector
um in Burma when that when that
particular attack happened
um and so all these people were
massacred fast forward about a month my
team and I we had been working in this
area for uh this one particular sector
of Burma for a couple of months straight
setting up ambulances setting up a boat
ambulance we have a we have three
ambulances that extract wounded we have
a boat ambulance that goes across we
train the local Village Defenders we
teamed between we trained the villagers
on the medical medical evacuations we
set up radios so people can communicate
between village Village hey where do we
run where do we go what do we do
um just like those little girls in
Afghanistan they didn't know where to go
or if maybe they were sent out by the
Taliban but if they weren't sent out by
the Taliban maybe there's running around
scare they didn't know what was going on
they didn't know where to go right but
that happens on a mass scale where 500
people don't know where to run to and
sometimes they run the wrong way and you
know uh bad things happen so we've been
sent we'd spent months
um building up all this capacity well
then in early June a big attack came the
Burma Army came into that exact area
where we had been working uh and
building up the capabilities of the
locals in that sector and they responded
incredibly well the villagers the
civilians who had been trained in the
medical stuff they they patched up their
own people and extracted them
communicated on the radios that we
provided and knew where to run the local
Village Defender guys they went and
defended as long as they could The
Villages eventually were overrun they
took casualties killed and wounded they
evacuated all their guys using the
tourniquets that we gave them and put on
them that they they put those
tourniquets on their own guys they
extracted um their their patients to our
ambulance boat got it across got it
across this large lake to an actual
ambulance saved a bunch of people's
lives the villagers when they ran away
all the food all of that stuff was given
to them by people uh that all the
supplies and stuff they got was provided
by stronghold and have been
pre-positioned for just this kind of
emergency because this stuff happens all
the time so my point is the best part of
that whole story is none of my team was
in the country when it happened not a
single member not a single member of
like strongholds like foreign team like
Outsider team was there and that's
that's the beauty of what we do and
that's how it works so people are
standing on their own we give them what
they need we teach them how to fish but
we also give them a fishing pole stay
with them long enough to make sure they
actually know how to fish and then when
when crisis happens they're able to take
charge and control their own destiny so
how do people support stronghold rescue
so we're a non-profit We Exist
completely off of donations if people
want to help so we we do things slightly
different at stronghold uh what we do is
we ask people if they want to support
give 50 cents a day or a dollar a day
The Way We Exist is we have thousands of
people all across the country and the
and the world who each give us a little
bit every single every single day or
excuse me every single month just a
little bit every single month and we
actually limit the amount that people
can give us per month when they when
they sign up so the mat the max you can
sign up for to be a monthly donor is a
dollar a day because what we don't want
to have happen is we don't want people
to hear the story and then they go well
this is so great I want to help and they
sign up for 500 a month or something
crazy because we've had people do that
and you're like no no that's that's too
much that's great why don't you get why
don't you give us a dollar a day to
support the work that we're doing and
then if you have that in your budget to
go help hey go help other groups go go
give to FBR go give to another local
charity that needs your help go give
your local church go we want people to
um to not just give to us we want people
to give to others so the way that we
raise our support is we have thousands
of people who each donate just a little
bit every month just like a Netflix
subscription and uh whenever somebody
signs up to be a monthly donor we send
them a t-shirt with a stronghold logo on
it and our
um our motto on the back the only thing
necessary for the Triumph of evil is for
good men to do nothing
people can't go to these War zones they
can't go and help directly people have
lives to live you know I get that I
don't expect everyone to drop everything
and suddenly care about the people of
Burma like it's like I do you know my my
wife is a a refugee from from Burma
um I don't expect people to care as much
as I do but everybody can do something
everybody can do a little bit and so if
people want to support us yeah go to
strongholdrescue.org and uh that's
that's the best way to support and
that's where we can sign up that's where
people can sign up to support yep
Ukraine Unity Ukraine I did go into
Ukraine I went to Ukraine um the
Russians were still advancing on Kiev so
I was in Kiev during that time
um with your fingers crossed with my
fingers crossed yeah uh so I was in Kiev
during that time
um my job we we were not we were in key
for or we were in uh Ukraine for maybe
just a few months
um I think in mid-may we I think we
pulled everyone out at that point such a
small team I went in um solo with one
other guy he had an emergency so we
actually had to leave but so I was there
on my own in Kiev and uh Odessa when the
Russians were still advancing on Kiev I
was there in Kiev and basically I found
myself helping these civilians who were
basically hey here's a rifle
congratulations here in the Army when
the Russians come down this road your
job is to uh shoot shoot at them and uh
don't leave this road that's your job
and so what we basically did was we set
up a central location to do medical
training uh T Triple C basic stuff but
not even that not even the full level
the teacher T Triple C and to make sure
that they could yeah basically defend
themselves and what they needed to do so
I was there basically mentoring
mentoring them for a short time thank
God the Russians stopped
um so then I went down to Odessa during
that time I was completely on my own the
rest of my team was in Burma at the time
uh so I went to Odessa and did basically
the same thing we set up uh a full like
T Triple C we brought an actual
teachable C uh certifier to come in and
certify guys in that and set up a school
basically to start just training
everybody and we started training
trainers to to give like uh Ukrainian
military guys who started training them
on How to Train others on basic military
stuff so then those guys were able to go
out to their units and then we brought
in tons of uh tons of medical supplies
the biggest the biggest difference that
we made and if anybody who's anybody's
working in Ukraine and here's this uh
get skeds skedco litters
um those those litters work phenomenally
on the battlefield
and there was recently a video that went
viral of some Russian or some Ukrainian
soldiers dragging one of their wounded
guys on a sked and we're 99 we don't
know for sure we're 99 sure was one of
the scheds that we gave because there
were lots of Med kits a lot of stuff
like that being brought in but we
brought in a bunch of schedulitters and
get him to got them to Frontline units
two of the guys on my team
they I I left Ukraine at this point and
they were still there for another couple
of weeks they ended up going all the way
to the front front line I was never on
the front line in Ukraine these guys
were at the front line doing Medical
Care like the front line like getting
murdered with their with the Ukrainian
soldiers
um one of the guys the the guy was in
charge out there Jason he uh he gave me
he gave me a call he's like hey man
these dudes are about to get overrun the
Ukraine's about to get overrun like
we're gonna die here like they're not
like requesting permission to pull back
and I was like yeah man like you're on
site you make the decision you don't
have to call me like you make you make
the right decision he was a former
Ranger like a real real really awesome
guy
um and so him and another guy who's with
him Adam they they had been living in an
underground soviet-era bunker uh with
the Ukrainian soldiers and just you know
all this artillery coming in the whole
time anyway so they leave they're like
hey sorry guys we gotta pull back they
pull back I think 24 hours or 48 hours
later the Russians overran that exact
position and some of the Ukrainian
survivors of the attack
mentioned specifically that Russian
soldiers with night vision goggles went
into the bunker where these guys had
been sleeping went into the bunker and
killed everybody in that bunker where
these guys had been sleeping uh the two
stronghold guys and then they you know
left and you know I don't really know
most of that unit was massacred and
everything so cutting it cutting it
close to the edge but that's the courage
of the guys on the team willing to be
out there in the first place but also
the discretion to say hey man we're
gonna we're gonna pull back a little bit
so we got Burma and that's just ongoing
Burma Burma is our primary focus right
now because we have like I said three
full-time ambulances with oxygen tanks
in the back and advanced life support
and we have a crew of all local guys who
have medical backgrounds like guys who
are refugees and stuff who have medical
backgrounds they're the ones who drive
the ambulances and man the ambulances
and provide the care but we provide all
the support and we provide all the
funding we provide all of that stuff and
we organized all of it yeah and this is
an ethnic cleansing effort is that is
that a stretch or is that accurate it's
it's a
it's not inaccurate in some instances so
so what's really going on is the Burma
army they are the government right it's
like if General Mattis or General Mattis
or whatever like just use the Marines
and like hey congratulations the Marines
are now the government right
um that's basically what's going on in
Burma so what's happening is the Burma
the ethnic bermans they want to control
the entire country and
um they ethnically see themselves as
Superior to everyone else and so they
don't necessarily want to ethnically
cleanse and completely destroy
um they don't they don't want to murder
everybody necessarily they want to
control everybody and if you do resist
them yeah then they'll Slaughter your
entire Village and of course they see
you as lower so they'll rape you and
murder you and do whatever these
massacres like this stuff like this
happen all the time
um it's it's and they they bomb Villages
knowing full well there's no military or
defense Personnel in those areas so it
is it is racial in a way but also it's
more like cultural cleansing because
they want you to get rid of your
language and speak only Burmese they
want you to get rid of all all of your
any other religions and stuff you need
to be Buddhist and so they want to
control in that way and
thailands across the river what's what's
preventing all these Karen people from
just leaving is it because it's their
Homeland and they're like no this is
where I'm from and I'm staying or is it
the Thai government can't take on any
refugees what's going on with that so
there are I don't know the exact numbers
but there's probably there's millions of
refugees from the current drive but then
also from the kareni from the kitchen
from the shanawa there's there's a you
know there's a bunch of different tribes
there's lots and lots of of refugees in
the Thai government has actually been
very very kind and is is very supportive
and takes care of people they even set
aside like uh reservations specifically
for refugees from these other countries
where they can have their own land and
sort of settle and um sort of like a
Native American uh Refugee kind of thing
uh Refuge uh they can go there have
their own land and set up their own
stuff for the most part the you know the
Thai government still keeps an eye on it
so they're you know but the Thai
government's very very supportive and
actually very kind the thing is like the
Thai government you can't go to war it's
you know are you gonna go to war in
Burma you know like so they're not
they're not going to do that which is
which again is understandable but um
yeah they're they're actually very very
supportive it is a safe haven for the
for the refugees to go to when you go
back there do you bring your wife with
you is she already there she stay there
um so she's gonna go she's gonna go back
um and she actually she and I met she
was working at a clinic in the uh in the
jungle where we were bringing our
patients to
um so that's where we actually met um so
she's she grew up in Canada
um so she's yeah she's gonna go back
she's going to go back with us we just
were recently uh married uh so she'll go
back on this trip as well and she'll
also help in in the ways that she can
she's very intelligent like a really
good teacher speaks English fluently
obviously growing up in Canada so that's
a big a big thing that she can do and
she has a degree in science so she she
can teach math and science at the uh the
clinic where they're training more
Medics and things like that and are you
picking up the language too slowly but
surely she's uh she's she's teaching
she's teaching me
yeah I'm just like yeah so does that
what else is there anything else does
that get us up to speed that pretty much
gets us up to speed yeah that's why I'm
here today I'm going back uh to Burma in
a in a couple of months
um and uh we'll continue doing the doing
the work that we're doing so anybody
that wants to help us we yeah we we
truly appreciate it and um yeah so it's
stronghold
rescue.org is where we're at for that uh
you're also on Instagram stronghold
rescues on Instagram yeah and uh it's at
stronghold rescue yeah you're on Twitter
you have like one post on Twitter so
yeah your effort is yeah basically I I
just I just recently set up the Twitter
yeah yeah if you want to if you want to
save room up to go to go to more like
Instagram so your Instagram is is
afromatos at e p h r a i m mattos
m-a-t-t-o-s which we were discussing
before we hit record is is a Portuguese
name yes yes so yeah some of that
Portuguese blood yeah
um and that's where we can find you
that's where we can support you again
it's a very interesting system you got
like a
a Netflix model except for Netflix
weakens you and doesn't help anybody
except for a bunch of weirdos in
Hollywood and this at
strongholdrescue.org will will actually
help uh uh people around the world
be free be healthy save themselves learn
it's it's freaking amazing amazing thing
um
Echo Charles yes sir you got any
questions oh going back to the
hotel stay yeah yeah look in the ocean
or whatever do you think I know you said
that you're you know you're not sure you
know trying to figure out why that's
even that helpful it's worth it do you
feel like it's kind of like an actually
asking YouTube It's like a method of
detaching like getting away from your
like normal routine that that tends to
trigger certain thoughts like almost
habitually sometimes and then you get
away from that in a in an atmosphere of
like no ocean kind of brings peace you
know when you look by the ocean or
whatever were you high up were you on a
high floor yeah I was on a high floor
yeah um yeah looking at it looking at
the ocean I think I think the Detachment
getting out of your normal routine and
um getting away from the different yeah
the different uh
different things that might just sort of
set you off into normal in a normal
spiral yeah that absolutely is an
element of it I think more importantly
uh for me in particular was it was just
it was just quiet and peace and being in
nature so I think going and sitting in a
cabin in the woods would have been would
have been good also like I said I'm very
I'm very like introverted in that not
that I'm shy but like for me when I'm uh
I do my best work alone I do my best
work I heal and stuff when I'm alone I
think maybe this method wouldn't work
for people who you know are more
extroverted and they want to you know
engage with with other people and they
want to talk with other people so I know
there's a lot of different Retreats and
stuff out there for for veterans and
things like that where guys can go and
get away from a get away from everything
for a little bit with their families and
be with other veterans and things like
that I've heard of a lot of those things
um so yeah I mean if you're more
extroverted that might be the way to go
I knew for me that wasn't going to work
for me I just had to go sit alone like
like an angry bear and just kind of just
stare at the water and uh contemplate
life yeah there's something about the
ocean and and being high up that kind of
exposes or or kind of is this feeling of
openness you know where especially so
you're not in the routine anymore you're
not being triggered by habitual thought
patterns or anything as much anymore and
then you're exposed to this kind of
peaceful openness and no one's bothering
you you're by yourself you don't have to
accommodate anyone especially if you're
an introvert
um and then so it's almost like you
detach and kind of in a way you can
mentally and emotionally set everything
out on the table and kind of be like
okay that works that doesn't work you
know kind of thing in this almost like
this protection of of this peaceful
environment yeah and I think I feel that
yeah that's exactly I think what what
ended up happening because I sat there
and I just started picking through I
literally had like a list of things on
my phone where I was like all right I
just need to sit and think through this
and make peace with it and and uh and
that's what I did yeah just item by item
and just that really that really really
helped yeah it was just something I
didn't have the idea from that from
anywhere I just was sitting there
thinking like okay I know me what do I
need to do to fix me in my unique weird
situation yeah and that seems to work I
felt like I kind of felt it when you
said like oh I just sat alone looking at
the ocean I was like damn that okay I
can feel that right now now that you
just said that that I could see how that
could be held yeah that's very helpful
something tells me I'm gonna get a
vacation request
Echo Charles is gonna have to go
contemplate those stresses I actually do
do that though well what's interesting
is if you remember uh all the
conversations I've had with with Andrew
huberman right yeah and there's a
physiological
and psychological thing that occurs when
you broaden your your spectrum of vision
so if you're if you're focused on
something that's right in front of you
that's a signal telling your brain and
your body that there's an emergency
basically an emergency going on when
you're looking at something up close
when you're staring at something when
you're focused on something it's you're
you're telling your body hey you got
something going on you've got something
you need to deal with you know this is
how we as cavemen survived like oh you
know whatever saber-toothed tiger focus
on that blood uh uh sorry breath goes up
blood starts you know pulse goes up
those things happen when you're focused
so what the opposite happens when you
broaden your Horizon and you open up
your field of view so what you're
talking about Echoes like
scientifically a thing what you're
saying broaden Your Horizon and open
your view you mean literally literally
literally like you're saying up high
stare at the ocean it's open literally
that's why you know why people go watch
the sunset
because that happens and they get that
feeling they might not know it they
probably didn't know that until you know
more recently I don't know I'm not the
Neuroscience historian but it was
interesting because as Andrew huberman
and I were having conversations about
this you know I had always sort of in
order to calm down in order to detach
which was another thing I taught before
I retired in the SEAL Teams like you got
to attach you got to take a step back
the take a step back I would tell guys
take a step back look around
I always did that I did that because it
made me calm down look around and I
didn't really put the physiological
thing together with the with what I
actually did but it's yes it is true
that's why when that's why people like
to go to the mountains and they like to
look you know see the see the beautiful
view of a mountain there's something
that there's a way that you feel because
of that you feel oh I'm not worried
about anything also think about this
when you're patrolling Through the
Jungle or patrolling through the city
you can't see everything so you're a
little bit like hey hold on like I don't
know what's gonna hit me that is some
kind of a little psychological
animalistic thing that you have I can't
see what's going on around me so I'm a
little bit sketchy but you're in a hotel
room
and you're looking at the ocean you can
see there's no threats it's probably one
of the few you know for you this is a
huge moment for you to not have any
threats right right you're like hold on
you know so that allows you to as Echo
said detach take a step back and now you
can start processing these things hey
what about this what about that and and
think through them so those things it's
breathing as well you can you can
you can control your physio physiology
to some extent right and some of the
things you can do is that's one of them
is broaden your field of view another
one is you can manually slow down your
breathing and that that calms you down
so again this is another thing that I've
talked about is
I would never want to key up my radio
and be like out of breath or panicked so
whenever I was about to key up my radio
and say something
take a big breath and slow down so I'm
was the the the collateral impact of
that was that I had stepped back I
looked around I was taking a breath what
I was doing was being calm and I was
calming myself down I was forcing my
physiological system to calm down and it
made me come and it made me less
panicked and it made me able to make
clearer decisions so this idea that
you're talking about of just taking a
step back staring at the ocean from
altitude as well that's a bonus program
yes bonus program yeah what else Echo
Charles that's it keep up the good work
it's awesome you have to say the least
uh
any any closing thoughts from you ever
no that's all I really appreciate yeah
you're having me on it's been it's an
honor it's been fun yeah well um again I
I feel like I owe you five years worth
of
um
recognition for what you've done uh and
I apologize for that uh but thanks for
coming here today finally and I think
you know what hey everything happens for
a reason right at the junction that
you're at right now you got your
organization you're doing work so
Russell Brand has a podcast Russell
Brands yeah he's got a podcast now
um so everything does happen for a
reason and and we always look at the
positive things so we'll say right now
you're ready for an influx of support at
this time and you know I think the
people that listen to this these are
people that are are definitely people
that care about the world and care about
helping other people out so I think we
can see some support there but thanks
for coming on thanks for for um sharing
your story thanks for sharing your
lessons learned it's been awesome and
thanks for your service and the teams
you know um out there getting it done
and thanks for the service that you're
doing now since you left the team you
know putting your life at risk in order
to help other people that can't help
themselves uh can't think of a higher or
more pure calling so thanks for what
you've done and thanks for what you
continue to do man I appreciate it
thanks for having me on
and with that Ephraim Mattis
has left the building
a lot to process yes sir a lot going on
and as I mentioned many times I only
um touched on it here a little bit in
the book and he's got another what four
or five years worth of these things that
he's been through over in Burma
um as he mentioned you know he's in
situations these are combat deployments
for him and his team he had one of his
best friends and interpreters killed
well just a little bit ago
so
yeah
if you can support Ephraim I would
highly recommend it
um
yeah so there we go that's crazy man
it is crazy how you know how you say
when you kind of come out of the war and
it it helps regardless of your condition
but it helps to find a new mission
where this kind of I constantly was
thinking that with him I felt like man
this is the guy who's just like you know
what I'm gonna just find this new
Mission and just go hard and it keeps
going hard yeah yeah
I know obviously he has a um uh A Love
For Humanity yeah that's just
amazing yeah you know to continue to do
this to continue to risk his life and
pour his entire life into helping other
people to this extent it's just it's
it's uh it's amazing amazing God yeah
for sure the world would benefit from
that way of thinking when he was talking
about yeah they're like in different
countries and all that stuff but we're
all human we're all humans so these are
my nieces and my nephew these are my
brothers you know kind of a thing and
it's it's one thing to say that but his
actions are like Pro that's the yeah
that is what he's doing yep 100 that's
what he's doing yeah it's amazing so if
you can support Ephraim please
um make it happen it's uh it's without a
question a worthy cause yes sir there
you go uh with that if you want to
support this podcast and what we're
doing and you kind of want to support
yourself too you can go to
jockoffuel.com you can get yourself
you can get yourself some go which I've
had to today good by the way yeah I had
one well one a couple of these cans are
left over from the last podcast which we
did yesterday we got another we're
racking up a lot of podcasts yes we need
some Jocko fuel
mentally sharp physically you did squats
today that's right yep right on that
mulch training you got in here yeah they
got 30 grams yep 50 money uh
jockerfuel.com you get out every every
everything that you need to be healthy
go check it out we got joint Warfare we
got super krill oil we got immunity
stuff we we just got everything that you
need you get it at Wawa you can get a
vitamin shop you can get a GNC
you can get it to military Commerce
commissaries AAFES Hannaford Dash doors
wake Fern ShopRite HEB down in Tejas
Meyer up in the midwest Harris Teeter
Lifetime Fitness Shields
that's where you can get this stuff
right now and we're expanding as rapidly
because we're starting to get a presence
a good strong presence in Tennessee
we're in there so if you're in Tennessee
and you go like buy a local store see if
they got it
go buy it go buy yourself some get
yourself some uh go
if you have a gym
maybe it's a CrossFit gym because we're
doing CrossFit maybe it's a Jiu Jitsu
gym because we're doing Jiu Jitsu email
JF sales at jacofuel.com if you want to
have the people
at your gym
get faster stronger and better and need
a little help with that you can sell
Draco fuel too so there you go
jockofuel.com check it out stream also
origin USA this is American made gear
the real deal
um Jiu Jitsu stuff that's where that's
how it primarily started right the
Jujitsu stuff but never mind primarily
that's where it started yeah yeah so hey
it's a new age now we got more than Jiu
Jitsu stuff now we got jeans boots
because look technically can you wear a
ghee to the supermarket technically
speaking you can sure yeah hell yeah but
how do you feel
under some circumstances not the best
move for sure yeah you know I might be
uh wearing the jeans that might be a
better scenario that's why we make jeans
that's why we make shorts because you
know you got to go to the supermarket
you know you got to take your wife out
to dinner you know she doesn't you show
it you you're gonna go out on a date
with someone you know yeah you're gonna
doubt out on a date with a girl sure and
you show up you're wearing a ghee right
right it just might not be the message
it might not land yeah so that's why we
make jeans make t-shirts hoodies all
that good stuff and it's all made in
America so you don't have to worry about
you know we're talking Ephraim he's
talking about people that are getting
abused getting murdered getting raped
terrible
terrible that's going on in the world
slavery is going on in the world right
now too by the way there's countries
where slave labor is being used to make
the clothes that you might be wearing
right now if you're not careful you're
taking a chance at a minimum you're
taking a chance at a minimum unless you
buy from originusa.com then you're 100
not supporting slavery
of other human beings you're supporting
Freedom you're helping the National
Security of this country
talk about originusa.com and buy a pair
of jeans you're going to support America
you're going to support Freedom you're
going to keep people out of
slavery and you're going to look cooler
when you go to pick up your date for
dinner hell yeah so that's what I'm
saying bro I told well I told you
actually I told you many times my tiered
system of attire uniform let's call it
uniform because it's kind of all I wear
so the top tier is the origin genes
Delta 68.
the new Delta 68 there's like a new one
right like a new cut or something I
prefer the OG one okay yeah Pete was
very surprised just because the new one
like a lot of people like the new one
yeah interesting I like the new one too
but the OG that's the one well we're
constantly improving them and making
them better yeah so I don't know what
your little personal preference thing
that you're dealing with over there yeah
but I can tell you right now the new
ones yeah sick maybe because I stick
with you know if it works I just sort of
stick with it you know if it ain't broke
don't fix it okay for that before yeah
yeah that's judge for yourself people
but I should keep an open mind at all
times I think so you might be right
about that so I get it nonetheless hey
they're all good even the factory what
do they call them the factory things
right the OG the original ones they have
a little bit less stretch to them or
thicker they're just they're the same
stretch but they are thick oh yeah
thicker so it's probably more feels like
yeah yeah but how if you if you let's
say you let's pretend for instance that
you had a job that required work
if you weren't like literally sitting in
an air conditioned you know office for
20 minutes at a time right you can turn
the air conditioning on you turned it on
nonetheless hey look you're right
regardless of my
scenario so there you go originusa.com
get some it's true also chocolate star
called Jocko store this is discipline
equals this is apparel this line equals
freedom good you know shirts hats
hoodies that that kind of cool stuff
there's a lot of stuff on there so yeah
if you like something get something also
speaking of stuff that's on there so
it's a subscription scenario for shirts
new shirt every month called the shirt
Locker
people seem to like these designs
because they go outside the box
sometimes
it's true there's been some objections
too by the way that's the that's part of
the game probably objections oh yeah a
few yeah for sure there's been two
objections but with every actually there
there was no a few yeah but for every
objection there's like someone who's
like this is the jam this is the one you
know this is my favorite one because you
know when you go outside the box it's
like you can go outside the box either
in a good way or a bad way and that
whether it's good or bad that's just a
matter of opinion man depends on your
personality toxic productivity that was
when they got some backlash oh really
yeah but that's it at the same that's
the third one so that one the everybody
must get stoned which is about a stoner
63 machine gun and uh don't it up
don't don't worry it doesn't have the
word on it but but let's face it
yeah you don't have to be a genius to
figure out what it says correct and you
said it yes sir so those are three out
of probably what what do you got 25 30
shirts at this juncture yeah so you're
rolling about Echo trucks you're rolling
about a 10 objection rate but then again
and each one of those three shirts there
was a whole group of people that were
extremely fired up that's their favorite
one so there's a handful of them that
people are like hey this is my favorite
one those all three of those by the way
were part of that handful of them the
other ones was the good high level
problems a lot of people like that one
day
um and then that original the one with
you on the tank
but there's some good ones on there
right on uh so there you go there you go
jocostore.com speaking of um get some
speaking of getting stronger get
yourself some steak
from primalbeef.com this is the good
steak let's face it steak comes in
different levels right yes sir you know
what I mean you got stake them that you
can get technically I guess it's steak
right you know what steakums is it's
like a little Frozen thing you pull out
of like a box you get it at the
supermarket like in the frozen food
sections right next to the fish sticks
and the chicken patties oh is it real
steak or no
it's called steak um stick real thin no
anyways that's one in the end of the
spectrum I don't even know if it's
necessarily steak but it's it's on the
Spectrum sure other end of the spectrum
Primal beef primalbeef.com farm-raised
you know so it's raised on a farm not in
a factory grass-fed and they finish it
this is a good thing with fruit and
grain like little combination they
figured out because let's face it dude I
mean look we like lean meat I get it I
get it but if you're eating a steak you
want it to be you want to have a little
bit of Marvel you want that quality you
want that you want that so there you go
this is next level
primalbeef.com steak up
Sean glass you know Sean glass hell yeah
Echelon front team team Echelon front
it's him
him and a couple of his buddies kick
this thing off and it's freaking
outstanding so check that out uh
subscribe to the podcast obviously
subscribe to Jocko underground obviously
subscribe to the YouTube channel if you
want to know what Ephraim looks like you
can go check it out on there also
origin USA has a YouTube channel also
Jocko fuel has a YouTube channel so
check all those out and what else we got
we got
psychological warfare we got flip side
canvas Dakota Meyer making cool stuff to
hang on your wall
a bunch of books obviously the book I
talked about a bunch today city of death
by ephraimatos get that book it's it's
it's it's heavy
final spin
leadership strategy and tactics code
evaluation program look I've written a
bunch of books too the ABC is a jiu
jitsu check out that book that's written
by Adam Mason amazing coach Adam
all the kids books that I've written
those are really good for your kids man
and your neighbors and your your cousins
your nephews your nieces just get them
those books it's such a game changer for
kids out on the Jocko live tour how many
people came up to me and thanked me for
those books and I signed those books
these are game changing books for
children that you know
so go get them
we got extreme ownership dichotomy
leadership we got about Facebook Mike
and the Dragons It's all those books
check them out we got Echelon front
which is
our leadership consultancy we solve
problems through leadership go to
aslamfront.com if you need help inside
your organization if you want to come to
one of our Live Events whether it's the
the muster next muster is in San Diego
by the way because the Dallas one sold
out
because everything we do sells out
so if you want to come and do one of our
things then go to aslamfront.com if you
just need help inside your organization
go to epsonfront.com we have the women's
assembly coming up September 14th
through the 16th in Phoenix Arizona
Jamie Cochran the CEO of echelon front
is running that
and it looks like the CEO of Jocko fuel
will be there Diane it looks like the
CEO of origin will be there Amanda so I
was like we got three companies
run by females
Jocko fuel origin USA
and what am I forgetting Echelon front
three companies run by females they're
all the in the Chief Operating Officer
positions so they're going to be at that
event in Phoenix Arizona
I probably shouldn't say this but my
wife's gonna be there and my wife is on
a panel they're having like a panel
discussion yeah yeah my wife agreed to
me and you know my wife doesn't doesn't
agree I want to talk to anybody about
anything yeah especially about none of
this stuff but she's going to be there
Jamie somehow convinced her to be on the
panel asked me some questions for Big H
damn it don't be solid so there you go
uh go to echelonfront.com for any of
that stuff we also have a an online
training platform
because we have techniques but this is
not
something we are trying to hang on to
I'm not trying to hide this it's not I'm
not a magician that has magic I don't
want you to know the trick I actually
want you to know the trick because I
want you to be able to utilize this
because it'll make your life better to
make life better for everyone around you
in your family in your work in your home
wherever
so we have extreme ownership.com learn
the techniques of life
extreme ownership.com learn how to
interact with other people
learn how to get disciplined
learn how to lead lead yourself lead
others extreme ownership.com check that
out and if you want to help service
members active and retired you want to
help their families Gold Star Family
check out Markley's mom mama Lee
she's got a charity organization if you
want to donate or you want to get
involved go to America's Mighty Warriors
dot org also check out
heroesandhorses.org we got Micah Fink
taken
veterans up into the wilderness
so they can find themselves again
not everyone has the methodology of
going and going looking at the ocean for
a while like Ephraim does did also
speaking of Charities if you want to
help out go to strongholdrescue.org
you already heard for the last three and
a half plus hours what ephraim's doing
around the world
so go and check that out also if you
want to connect with us or him on the
interwebs you can go to at stronghold
rescue on Instagram also ephraim's on
Instagram at ephraimatos
and of course that goes out Echo Charles
I'm at Jocko only just watch out
just watch out for the algorithm which
is trying to grab you
and thanks to all the uniform military
personnel around the world doing your
best to help the world be a better place
than thanks to these types of
humanitarian organizations like
stronghold rescue that are out there
risking their lives
also to help people around the world and
make the world a better place and also
thanks to our police law enforcement
firefighters paramedics EMTs dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
Secret Service and all First Responders
that are out there right now right now
there's no break
there's no deployment cycle you're on
deployment you're there helping us
and we thank you for what you do to keep
us safe here at home and everyone else
out there
foreign
the world's a rough place
the world is a very rough Place
depending on where you are
and and just about
for everyone for almost everyone no
matter where you are in life someone is
having a harder time than you are
something to remember
maybe help you stifle some of those
complaints
but also it's a reminder that if you can
when you can try and help people out
and this doesn't mean you have to storm
into battle like Ephraim and
and the guys from stronghold rescue you
don't necessarily have to do that
but you can still help other people
maybe you can donate to one of these
organizations maybe you can donate to
stronghold rescue maybe you can donate
to to America's Mighty Warriors maybe
you can donate to
Heroes and horses
and maybe you can't even do that but
maybe it's just a word of encouragement
to somebody that's having a rough day
there's a whole spectrum of things that
we can do
that make a difference
and if we can all lift each other up a
little bit
we can all make the world
a little bit better
and that's all I've got tonight
until next time this is Echo and Jocko
out